[Musique]
la séance est reprise notre ordre du
jour appelle la discussion du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 dont le Sénat
a été saisi en application de l'article
47-1 alinéa 2 de la Constitution et
je crois que je suis
il est demandé un rappel au règlement de
madame la présidente du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen madame
assassin
l'orée du débat de la plus grande
importance qui engage l'avenir de notre
peuple je souhaite affirmer ici quelques
principes qui vont guider l'action de
notre groupe et formuler une exigence
nous exigeons avec 90% des actifs les
millions de personnes qui manifestent et
l'ensemble des syndicats le retrait de
ce projet de loi il est donc
article 42 chapitres 14 du règlement
monsieur il est donc pour nous un devoir
de manifester notre opposition la plus
vive dans cette hémicycle qui ne peut
être en dehors du réel et ne pas
entendre l'exigence d'un grand débat
dans le pays ne pas entendre la colère
froide sérieuse mais déterminée et
massive le débat doit avoir lieu et
notre groupe comme les autres groupes de
gauche utilisera tous les moyens
constitutionnels pour relayer ici les
préoccupations populaires je le dis
monsieur le Président les moyens
constitutionnels le droit d'abonnement
la liberté de parole et d'expression des
parlementaires le droit d'opposition en
amont sont des principes de la
démocratie la répéter la force sont de
notre côté par contre une certaine
fébrilité semble agiter certains au
point de menacer d'utiliser des moyens
de procédure pour accélérer encore un
débat déjà tronqué par l'application du
47.1 monsieur le Président du Sénat nous
appelons donc certains à la raison
n'ayons pas peur du débat et surtout
ensemble écoutons le peuple je vous
demande donc solènement d'agir pour que
nos droits constitutionnels soient
pleinement respectés de mettre un terme
aux menaces express à l'encontre de
notre expression avant même le début de
la discussion le gouvernement n'a pas
voulu d'un vrai débat il a détourné la
Constitution pour cela comme je vous
l'ai de montrerai dans un instant
présentant une motion d'y recevabilité
le Sénat sa majorité son président ne
peuvent accompagner monsieur Macron et
son gouvernement dans cette partition
dangereuse pour la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
aux règlements
dans la discussion générale je vais
donner la parole au ministre du Travail
du plein emploi et de l'insertion
Monsieur Olivier Duss
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur madame le
rapporteur pour avis messieurs les
ministres chers Franck et Cher Gabriel
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
y sommes nous y sommes à nouveau si je
puis dire il nous y sommes enfin je suis
particulièrement heureux de vous
présenter cette réforme et de soumettre
ce texte à votre discussion cette
réforme des retraites j'y crois
profondément j'y crois parce qu'elle
sort d'abord notre système par
répartition d'un état structurellement
déficitaire et avec cette réforme nous
permettons de ne pas faire peser cette
responsabilité sur les générations
futures alors que nous savons tous à la
lecture des rapports du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites que dès 2027
le déficit annuel du système de retraite
sera de 12,5 milliards d'euros par an
pour atteindre 20 milliards d'euros par
an en 2035 et 25 milliards d'euros par
an en 2040
dans un peu plus de 10 ans si nous ne
faisons rien le déficit cumulé et donc
la dette sera alourdi de 150 milliards
d'euros cela nous oblige et notamment
tout au long des débats que nous ouvrons
de rester extrêmement attentif à cet
objectif d'équilibre et de retour à
l'équilibre du système des retraites
cette réforme j'y crois aussi parce
qu'elle rend plus juste notre système de
retraite en répondant à de très longs
attentes des Françaises et des Français
et j'y crois enfin parce que c'est tout
simplement une promesse tenue celle de
réformer les retraites et avec elle de
continuer à transformer le pays et notre
modèle social et je dis tout en
soulignant que croire à cette réforme
n'empêcher évidemment pas d'entendre des
contestations je n'oublie pas que ceux
qui ont élu le président de la
République ne l'ont pas tous faits pour
soutenir cette promesse là d'abord
certains ont voté pour lui pour cette
réforme d'autres ont voté pour les
malgré cette réforme et d'autres encore
ont voté contre lui à cause de cette
même réforme cependant est tout au
couteau tout au long de la campagne
présidentielle cette réforme n'a jamais
été un projet caché elle était assumée
elle a été portée annoncée par le
président de la République et par toute
la majorité lors des élections
législatives elle s'inscrit dans la
droite ligne des engagements pris depuis
cette ligne qui fait du travail la
meilleure et la plus forte des réponses
apportées aux difficultés de notre pays
c'est également vrai pour retrouver
l'équilibre du système de retraite et
puisse encore quand nous considérons que
le travail est la meilleure des
politiques pour plus d'autonomie de
dignité et pour lutter contre la
pauvreté c'est ce que le président de la
République a construit réformes après
réformes depuis 2017 et que nous voulons
ainsi poursuivre dans la série des
réformes déjà nombreuses de notre
système de retraite cette réforme ne
fait pas exception bien au contraire sur
plusieurs points elle est d'abord
difficile difficile car vous savez comme
moi la complexité de ce sujet la
complexité de notre système de retraite
rendu plus opaque à chaque fois qu'on la
modifié et qui aujourd'hui cache
d'innombrables imperfections sous chacun
de ces détails imperfection que l'on
découvre en avançant et personne ne peut
véritablement en réalité croire ou même
se vanter d'en avoir fait le tour c'est
pourquoi réformer notre système de
retraite et toujours une gageure
toujours été cela le reste une cageur
que nous devons conjuguer nos priorités
avec toujours plus de complexité de
complexité et souvent d'inégalité
même un funambule n'y verrait pas un
chemin aisé et en vérité que je parle de
chemin le seul chemin que je connaisse
pour aborder cette réforme c'est celui
du débat et du dialogue républicain
d'abord par la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux et les forces
politiques du pays qui ont répondu à
notre appel et permis d'emprunter ce
chemin cela n'a évidemment pas permis de
surmonter tous les désaccords notamment
sur l'âge ou la durée de cotisation mais
sur d'autres points nous avons su acter
des avancées que certains jugent
insuffisants d'autres excessives je
pense à l'emploi des seniors ou au
carrière longue mais toutes ces avancées
sont aussi frites cette concertation
elles sont autant de preuves et en faut
que le débat la discussion sont toujours
féconds et que le consensus est toujours
possible quand on veut bien lui laisser
une chance
en réalité parler des retraites est
présenté cette réforme devant vous c'est
aussi regarder les choses en face et
éviter toute forme de déni quand on
demande aux Français de travailler deux
ans de plus même progressivement même en
tenant compte de la pénibilité des
carrières longues c'est demander un
effort aux Français un effort pour
assister pour sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition un effort pour
financer de nouveaux droits mais cela
reste un effort et il faut aussi dire
que demander un effort de plus c'est
parfois aussi bousculé des projets de
vie et en fait parler des retraites
c'est parler du rapport des Français à
leur travail alors carrière c'est parler
de leur vie de leur famille de leurs
aspirations j'ai eu un maintes reprises
l'occasion de rappeler combien est
difficile l'exercice qui accompagne un
départ en retraite liquider sa pension
peut parfois avoir l'air d'un solde de
tout compte et l'administration vous
demande finalement de faire le point de
retracer de reconstituer votre carrière
et de se retourner sur sa vie qui n'est
pas toujours une chose facile pour
certains ce sont de bons souvenirs pour
d'autres des moments plus contrastés et
la retraite peut arriver comme une
délivrance ou comme le moment d'un
rappel de cette mémoire vive et donc
c'est aussi à ce titre que cette réforme
question de rapport au travail au sens
que nous donnons au travail question qui
que se pose pardon de plus en plus de
français parfois dans sans angoisse
c'est donc bien comme ministre du
travail conscient se rapporte personnel
à l'existence que le sujet qu'on voit
que je veux vous présenter cette réforme
et en débattre avec vous les prochains
jours elle s'inscrit dans la suite de
mon action ministère du Travail en
posant quelques fondations des chantiers
qui nous attendent encore elle continue
de poser les bases d'une nouvelle
société du travail d'abord impulsée par
les lois pouvoir d'achat pour n'en
rester qu'à aucun canal débuté en 2022
par la réforme du marché du travail et
chantier qui sera prolongé d'ici peu
avec un nouveau projet de loi nous
souhaitons vicieux pour l'emploi le
travail la formation avec comme objectif
le plan
en réalité toutes ces réformes en tant
commun même objectif que je viens
dénoncer le tel emploi pour tous mais
aussi le bon emploi pour le plus grand
nombre c'est cet objectif qui requiert
toute notre responsabilité et tout notre
courage
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
dis aussi à cette tribune pour souligner
la complexité la complexité de
l'exercice et le fait que toute réforme
des retraites est difficile je dis en
ayant bien en tête qu'ici même vous avez
régulièrement éprouvé le fait que
décider de telles réformes c'est
s'exposer à la critique à la
contestation c'est aussi faire preuve de
courage et faire cette réforme c'est
aussi avoir le courage de la monnaie et
d'affronter les difficultés inhérentes à
cette entreprise d'affronter les
difficultés que d'autres gouvernement
d'autres majorité avant nous n'ont pas
nécessairement eu au fil du temps et qui
nous invite aujourd'hui à agir et agir
vite nous le faisons nous avançons nous
assumons cette difficulté la nécessité
aussi de partager des contraintes les
contraintes budgétaires notamment qui
pèsent sur notre état et notre système
de protection sociale
j'ai eu la grande chance d'être mère
député ministre de la Fonction publique
puis du budget et s'il y a bien une
chose qui m'a été rappelée par
l'exercice de chacune de ces fonctions
sans équivoque et sans nuance c'est bien
que les équipes budgétaires fonde notre
système et détermine notre capacité à
agir et puis son corps la permettre à
ceux qui nous succèdent de continuer à
des idées souverainement pour eux-mêmes
c'est une certitude cette attachement à
l'équilibre budgétaire et je sais que
vous êtes très nombreux à la partager
comme vous et avec mon collègue Gabriela
taille ministre délégué au compte public
j'en saurai le garant nous en serons les
garons bien entendu et nous le savons
les moyens ne sont pas une fin et
vouloir sortir un système du déficit
pour le réformer ne signifie pas que
l'objet unique de la réforme serait cet
équilibre mais je le répète à nouveau
toutes les interprétations du monde ne
suffiront pas à contourner un constat
simple autour du caractère structurel du
déficit de notre système de retraite
c'est vrai pour les 25 prochaines années
avec une moyenne déficitaire quel que
soit la convention et le scénario retenu
par le corps et en empruntant ces mots
aux auteurs du rapport je le cite à
l'instant ce souci exclusivement
d'évolution des dépenses sont préoccuper
des ressources qui les permettent n'est
pas une vision alternative ça n'est pas
une alternative parmi d'autres c'est à
supprimer une forme d'incurie financière
certains par ailleurs quand ils
reconnaissent l'existence d'un déficit
parviennent encore en se satisfaire ou à
le relativiser et pour le coup c'est
vouloir renvoyer nos responsabilités aux
prochaines générations le prix du déni
quand on parle de retraite c'est la
trahison des générations qui n'ont pas
encore voix au chapitre pour décider
pour elle-même c'est aussi ouvrir la
voie une dénaturation tout ou tard de
nos systèmes de retraite les plus
protecteurs notre système qui protège
les plus fragiles qui réduit les
inégalités et qui garantit la solidarité
entre les générations finalement nier ce
déficit ni la nécessité de l'équilibre
c'est peut-être mieux et penser que le
présent mérite de déverrouiller l'avenir
ce que nous préférons pour nos retraites
c'est effectivement et je l'ai dit
demander un effort à ceux qui le peuvent
comme la majorité sanatoriale le propose
d'ailleurs depuis de nombreuses années
ainsi le choix qu'il neutre et de faire
que l'âge légal de départ sera ainsi
relevé progressivement pour être
atteindre 63 ans et 3 mois à la fin du
quinquennat puis 64 ans en 2030 nous
accélérons aussi la mise en œuvre de la
réforme Touraine afin d'atteindre 43 ans
durée de cotisation à la fin du
quinquennat et nous menons ces deux
entreprises en maintenant l'âge
d'annulation de la décote à 67 ans nous
faisons ce choix un moment de notre
histoire ou le taux de chômage ne cesse
de baisser ou le taux d'emploi bat des
records et avec cette certitude que par
le travail par l'important c'est
l'augmentation du volume de travail dans
la société nous pouvons apporter les
réponses les plus efficaces et les plus
justes nous le faisons aussi en sachant
reconnaître au Sénas qui a été
initialement conçu au Sénat et je le dis
devant madame la Présidente de la
Commission comme demande monsieur le
rapporteur en pensant à ce
traditionnellement adopté avec la
volonté d'une réforme de courage et
d'équilibre qui ont à agir sur ces deux
leviers à la fois et la durée de
cotisation sans jamais nier la réalité
de l'effort demandé je veux aussi dire
devant vous qu'au-delà des initiatives
de votre assemblée il y a eu évidemment
avant que nous soyons réunis pour cette
réforme d'autres réforment des retraites
avant celles-ci et quel que soit le
gouvernement elles ont tout en commun
deux choses d'abord avoir relevé l'âge
et où la durée de cotisation pour le
premier point et ne jamais avoir été
remise en cause quel que soit les
alternances une fois qu'elles ont été
adoptées elles ont tout enfin eu comme
priorité le retour à l'équilibre
financier plus que la création de
nouveaux droits et c'est peut-être sur
ce dernier point que cette réforme se
distingue avec cette volonté d'améliorer
le système mais aussi de financer
massivement des nouveaux droits dans une
empereur sans précédent puisque nous
demandons de travailler plus pour
produire plus en retour nous
retrouverons l'équilibre et nous
financerons ces nouveaux droits je les
dis là aussi inlassablement améliorer
sans équilibrer serait irresponsable et
équilibrer sans améliorer serait injuste
et c'est pourquoi nous voulons faire les
deux
de fait sur les 18 les 18 milliards
d'euros que génèrent la mesure d'âge en
2030 un tiers c'est à dire 6 milliards
d'euros sont consacrés des mesures de
justice et de solidarité c'est
d'ailleurs précisément ce qu'ils fonde
la justification d'une telle réforme
dans un budget rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale puisque l'effet des
différentes mesures en dépense comment
recettes sur les branches vieillesse sur
les branches accident du travail à
maladies professionnelles justifie
pleinement le recevabilité dans ce bel
effet SS aussi de leur impact sur les
comptes sociaux de 2023
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
dit peut-être un peu vite tout à l'heure
que cette réforme est une évidence mais
il est vrai que c'est évident c'est
parfois contesté fort heureusement pour
nous qu'il a défendons il n'y a pas de
meilleur moyen pour s'en convaincre que
de faire le tour rapidement des
alternatives qui lui sont opposés
alternative qui sortent toutes à un mur
de contradiction certains ont proposé
dans une nostalgie qui ne trompe
personne de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans mais sans toucher au 43 annuités
pour avoir le taux plein c'est un yen
comprendre ça va penser que le projet
derrière cela et de mettre les Français
au travail le plus tôt possible ou leur
proposer un système qui soit une machine
à décote une machine à petites pension
et donc une machine à pauvreté d'autres
proposent de revenir à 60 ans avec 40
annuités comme vingt ans 20 ans en
arrière en diminuant la durée de
cotisation c'est en réalité nous
condamnait collectivement à chercher 85
milliards d'euros de financement chaque
année bon courage pour cette entreprise
à moins de vouloir ruiner un quinquennat
de restauration de notre compétitivité à
moins de vouloir peser sur le pouvoir
d'achat des Français à moins de vouloir
asseoir notre système sur l'imposition
de profil aléatoire je ne vois pas
quelle est l'avenir raisonnable d'un tel
projet mortifère qui a d'ailleurs été
critiqué encore cette semaine par une
partie de cela même qui en font la
proposition d'autres contradictions sont
en réalité plus grave car elles disent
beaucoup du manque de sérieux des
projets alternatifs nier la réalité des
déficits tout en prévoyant des dizaines
de milliards d'euros de recettes en plus
pour y répondre ou encore penser défend
l'égalité en défendant les régimes
spéciaux vous l'avez compris nous n'en
prendrons pas assez chez moi aussi
escarpak sans issue et c'est donc une
réforme d'équilibre une réforme
équilibrée qui répartit l'effort que
nous demandons de la manière la plus
juste possible
la réforme que nous présentons est
d'abord une réforme soucieuse de justice
travailler plus longtemps oui mais pas
pour tout le monde et pas de la même
manière nous allons conserver et
améliorer le dispositif des carrières
longues en le rendant plus juste plus
lisible en élargissant aussi aux
périodes de congé parental nous
apportons également une réponse aux
carrières très longues en permettant aux
travailleurs et ont commencé avant 18
ans de partir quatre ans avant l'âge
légal nous le faisons en préservant les
dispositifs déjà prévus pour soyons
débuter avant 20 ans et si vous
l'acceptez bien sûr nous vous proposons
d'inclure ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans comme l'a évoqué
la première ministre devant l'Assemblée
nationale
ces améliorations ne pourront pas pour
autant dénaturer le système dans le
principe fondamental et que la durée de
cotisation est un minimum un plancher
sans jamais avoir été un plafond nous
vous proposons un système plus juste qui
est aussi un système qui prend mis en
compte les travailleurs les plus
fragiles les victimes d'accidents et
maladies professionnelles ainsi les
travailleurs handicapés pourront
toujours partir à la retraite à 55 ans
et les travailleurs invéliers d'où ils
nappe percevront toujours une retraite à
taux plein dès 62 ans comme aujourd'hui
dans le même temps maintenant le
dispositif de départ anticipé à 50 ans
pour les salariés exposés à l'amiante
avec ce texte nous vous proposons aussi
de mettre à profit cette opportunité
pour compléter les lois DJ Hassen du nom
du président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée nationale en particulier à
première en considérant comme complète
la carrière des exploitants agricoles
qui auraient été interrompu avant son
terme pour une aptitude ou invalidité
cette condition d'une carrière complète
et que c'est exigée pour bénéficier de
la pension minimale et l'aménagement
proposé dans ce texte permettra ainsi à
45 45 000 exploitants à la retraite de
plus dans policiers avec une
revalorisation d'environ 80 euros par
mois concernant les aidons nous créons
une assurance vieillesse pour les
aidants qui viendra compenser les
interruptions de carrière par
l'attribution de droits nouveaux et nous
veillons ainsi à tenir compte des
particularités des parcours comme de la
difficulté des métiers exercés nous
voulons aussi avec cette réforme crée de
nouveaux droits et faire de cette
réforme une réforme de progrès vous
entendons donc améliorer la prise en
compte de la pénibilité et notamment
l'usure liée aux conditions d'exercice
de certains métiers l'accès les droits
acquis avec le compte professionnel des
prévention seront considérablement
renforcés avec un abaissement des seuils
avec une meilleure prise en compte des
polyposés avec la création de nouveaux
de nouvelles utilisations possibles
comme un congé de reconversion afin
d'éviter l'enfermement dans des métiers
difficiles sans perdre en rémunération
nous demanderons aussi aux branches de
négocier des accords de prévention
l'usure professionnelle pour les métiers
identifiés comme difficiles par les
instances de la sécurité sociale
notamment la branche à TMP afin de tenir
compte de l'exposition aux critères
ergonomique de part de charge lourdes de
posture pénible ou de vibrations et pour
accompagner ce suivi pour financer les
mesures des accords de prévention nous
créerons un fond d'investissement dans
la prévention l'usure professionnelle
doté d'un milliard d'euros sur les cinq
prochaines années pour les travailleurs
les plus exposés à la pénibilité nous
voulons aussi renforcer le suivi médical
à compter de 45 ans pour garantir la
possibilité de départ d'anticiper quand
c'est nécessaire mais aussi avec une
visite à 61 ans et entre les deux un
rythme de visite défini par les branches
professionnelles et par le dialogue
social cette réforme est donc une
promesse à celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles de partir en
meilleure santé et nous voulons ajouter
à ces progrès sur la prise en compte de
l'usure de la prévention de l'usure
d'autres progrès notamment pour ce qui
concerne les petites pensions ainsi
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République nous revaloriserons 100
euros la retraite minimale de nos
compatriotes qui ont eu une carrière
complète au niveau du SMIC pour les
retraités de demain comme ceux
d'aujourd'hui
comme l'a dit le président de la
République depuis sa campagne et comme
je dis depuis le début cette mesure
concerne les carrières complètement
cotisées complètes à taux plein et
j'insiste sur ce point car il s'agit non
seulement d'une mesure forte pour
valoriser le travail mais aussi d'une
défense même de la nature de notre
système la valorisation du travail d'une
part qui ne doit pas se confondre avec
une politique de minima sociaux car
comme j'explique aussi à ceux qui
soulève cette question et qui
comprennent l'argument on ne peut pas
imaginer un système de retraite qui
distribuerait des pensions très
supérieures au salaire perçus pendant la
carrière et par ailleurs la défense de
la nature de notre système car ça serait
entretenir c'est important pardon
d'entretenir une scène différence entre
ce qui relève de l'assurance
contributive et du minimum de pension la
retraite est une assurance le minimum
vieillesse est un minimum social ce sont
deux instruments différents pour deux
objectifs distincts avec cette
revalorisation environ un million 800
000 des retraités actuels bénéficieront
d'une revalorisation du SMIC et pour la
moitié d'entre eux c'est à dire 900 000
cette revalorisation sera comprise entre
70 et pour les futurs retraités il y en
a 800 000 par an ce sont 200 000
retraités qui bénéficieront d'une
pension meilleure grâce à ce système de
pension minimale que sans la réforme
beaucoup l'avaient dit depuis 20 ans
lorsque le principe des 85 % du SMIC qui
a été inscrit dans la loi mais aucune
majorité aucun gouvernement de l'avait
fait personne n'avait prévu de système
d'indexation c'est ce à quoi nous
voulons apporter une réponse enfin cette
réforme est une réforme d'équité et j'en
viens à la question des régimes spéciaux
ceci ont leur histoire ils avaient leur
raison d'être mais pour la plupart
d'entre eux ne se justifient plus mettre
un terme à ces différences dans notre
système à hérité au fil du temps c'est
aussi avoir le courage que peu ont eu
avant s'agit d'effacer des différences
devenus incompréhensibles et faire
preuve de responsabilité personne ne
comprend plus pourquoi des agents de
conduite partent en moyenne avec un peu
plus de 56 ans en région parisienne
alors que c'est 62 ans dans d'autres
régions
nous devons dans cette entreprise de
fermeture des régimes spéciaux en
matière d'assurance vieillesse
naturellement accompagner financièrement
les régimes fermés progressivement et ce
à l'occasion des taxes financiers
l'automne 2023 et je dis très clairement
nous assurons la soutabilité des caisses
de retraite comme nous l'avons fait pour
la SNCF ainsi les nouveaux employés des
entreprises concernées seront affiliées
au régime général de l'assurance
vieillesse à partir du 1er septembre
2023 et dans le même temps les salariés
actuels continueront à bénéficier du
régime spécial en matière d'assurance
vieillesse mais chaque entreprise devra
négocier une période de convergence à
l'issue de laquelle l'âge spécifique
d'ouverture des droits les âges
spécifiques de retour des droits seront
relevés eux aussi de deux ans c'est un
point qui est important que nous voulons
souligner devant vous
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les principales
caractéristiques du texte que je vous
présente place au débat désormais place
au débat au Sénat puisque l'examen
l'Assemblée nationale aura évidemment
permis d'entendre de nouvelles demandes
mais n'aura pas permis de les discuter
pour autant je pense aux mesures pour
les pompiers volontaires je pense aux
enseignants aux apprentis à la situation
de Mayotte ou encore aux possibilités de
rachat de trimestre de stage ou d'études
ce sera l'occasion pour le gouvernement
de soutenir les amendements allant ce
sens et nous en avons aussi déposé
quelques-uns nous devons aussi aller
plus loin et ceux dans la continuité des
discussions que vous avez eu en
commission des affaires sociales et vous
savez nous l'avons dit avec la première
ministre notre volonté d'ouvrir un débat
sur les droits familiaux
c'est un sujet complexe car sensible
appuyez sur des inégalités entre les
statuts qui portent sur un système
pensez initialement pour compenser des
trimestres non cotisés alors même que la
progression du taux d'emploi des femmes
a changé la nature de ces trimestres qui
parfois viennent s'ajouter à ce cotiser
sur la même période nous devons veiller
à ce que notre système de retraite soit
donc fidèle à son époque notamment pour
les maires de famille et il apparaît que
le sujet n'est plus dans un certain
nombre de cas tant les interruptions de
carrière qu'elles subissent comme cela
souvent été comme ça il y a encore
parfois mais plutôt l'accès à la
promotion et l'égalité professionnelle
les conclusions de ce débat sur les
droits familiaux à la fois en termes de
maternité d'éducation des enfants de
pensions de réversion trouveront leur
place dans le cas du PLFSS pour 2024
mais cela ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'avancer et d'apporter de première
réponse je pense à deux sujets en
particulier le premier qui doit nous
permettre d'aller plus loin dans la
compensation en matière de valorisation
des pensions des écarts de salaires dont
une large partie est due aux
interruptions c'est tout le sens du
dispositif de surcote à partir de 63 ans
que votre commission des affaires
sociales a adoptée que nous regardons
avec beaucoup d'intérêt car il répond à
un certain nombre de priorité même si
vous savez je l'ai dit notre attachement
à l'équilibre financier du système le
second le second point de progrès
concerne une initiative du président
Bruno Retailleau concernant la création
d'un dispositif d'un dispositif
spécifique de pension de réversion pour
les orphelins et en particulier pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
connaissant cette situation d'être des
orphelins c'est un dispositif que nous
soutiendrons pour conclure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs voilà donc la
réforme que nous vous proposons voilà
comment elle s'inscrit dans notre projet
politique vous savez où nous voulons
aller vous savez comment nous voulons y
aller et avec cette réforme je crois que
nous prenons nos responsabilités pour
nous et pour les autres je compte bien
évidemment sur les débats du Sénat pour
l'améliorer pour l'enrichir et vous
trouverez avec le gouvernement une
oreille toujours attentif à l'ensemble
de nos échanges merci de votre attention
donc si monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
de donner la parole au ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics monsieur
Gabriel Attal
la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur pour la branche vieillesse
madame la rapporteur pour avis mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs nous voilà
mon collègue ministre du Travail et
moi-même devant le Sénat et devant les
sénateurs pour présenter le projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale qui réforme nos
retraites à l'orée de ces débats je
voudrais vous dire que nous venons
devant vous avec un objectif simple
construire un compromis clair pour la
retraite des Français
je le répète l'objectif du gouvernement
et de la première ministre c'est
qualissus de nos discussions nous
puissions trouver un compromis pour
payer les retraites des Français sans
impôts en plus ni retraite en moins
alors je le disais nous voilà devant
vous cet après-midi et c'est j'allais
dire le cycle naturel des lois
financières après l'Assemblée nationale
vient le temps du Sénat
et je veux vous dire
je sais qu'ici par de là les divergences
politiques on s'écoute je sais qu'ici
par de la les oppositions de fond on
débat je sais qu'ici par de la les
parcours de chacun on se respecte je
sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il n'y a
que la République
et donc je serai tenté d'espérer
qu'après le vacarme et l'obstruction des
extrêmes s'ouvrent à cet instant le
temps de la sagesse et de la raison
car je souhaite poser une question et
une seule
des senteurs de débat à l'Assemblée en
commission et dans l'hémicycle soit
davantage de temps que pour les réformes
précédentes qu'en est-il sorti de bon
pour les Français du point de vue de
ceux-là même qui ça rejoint le monopole
de leur défense et qui ont tout fait
pour retarder les débats au fond chacun
apportera la réponse qu'il souhaite même
si je crois que les Français se sont
malheureusement fait leur avis et ne
nous ont pas attendu pour cela mais si
je pose cette question Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs ce n'est pas uniquement pour
dénoncer une nouvelle fois ce qui a pu
se passer si je pose cette question
c'est parce que c'est la seule qui
vaille d'être posée
et parce qu'elle résume à elle seule au
fond notre seul boussole celle qui doit
nous réunir l'intérêt général et celui
des Français et pour moi l'intérêt
général l'intérêt des Français il tient
en quatre points clairs d'abord pouvoir
payer sereinement les retraites de
bientôt 20 millions de retraités en
France ensuite ne pas faire perdre 1
euro de pouvoir d'achat aux Français et
donc exclure toute hausse d'impôts ou
toute baisse des pensions
troisième point équilibrer notre système
de retraite en travaillant donc
globalement un peu plus longtemps et
enfin prendre en compte la situation de
chacun pour que la réforme soit
équilibrée sur le plan budgétaire je
l'ai dit mais répartissent aussi
équitablement l'effort demandé aux
Français
voilà l'approche cohérente qui est la
nôtre et que nous soumettons à votre
examen voilà le cadre qui est le nôtre
et dont nous ne dérogerons pas mais au
sein duquel nous sommes ouverts au
compromis voilà ce qui nous semble être
des conditions raisonnables pour œuvrer
ensemble au service de l'intérêt général
et on l'espèce l'intérêt général cela
veut dire permettre à chaque Français le
temps venu de pouvoir compter
sereinement sur la retraite à laquelle
il a droit ni plus ni moins voilà ce qui
est en jeu préserver nos retraites non
pas par dogme ou par réflexe mais par
bon sens une vie de travail à la fin on
doit en voir les fruits et le fruit
d'une ville de d'une ville de travail
pour l'immense majorité des Français
c'est leur pension de retraite qui leur
permet de financer leur mode de vie
auquel ils n'ont aucune envie de
renoncer au fond c'est cela la classe
moyenne tous les Français qui n'ont que
leur travail pour vivre cette classe
moyenne qui a trop souvent le sentiment
de travailler pour d'autres qui eux font
le choix de ne pas travailler
si on ajoute à cela le fait de
travailler dur pour une retraite qui en
plus diminuerait alors ces Français
perdront définitivement foi en l'action
publique alors c'est pour eux que nous
agissons c'est pour eux que nous sommes
engagés dans cette bataille c'est pour
eux que nous vous présentons ce texte et
c'est pour eux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que je souhaite lancer un
appel loin des polémiques les polémiques
j'adresse un appel engageons-nous dans
ce débat sans faux-semblant et sans
posture politique un appel au compromis
entre la majorité sénatorial qui incarne
la volonté d'une réforme et la majorité
présidentielle qui porte la
responsabilité de la réforme un appel à
la cohérence la majorité sénatoriale a
tant voulu cette réforme et la voté de
nombreuses fois un appel à la
responsabilité augmenter les impôts pour
financer les retraites ce n'est pas la
bonne solution car à la fin il y en a
toujours un qui paye et celui-ci
s'appelle le contribuable
j'adresse donc cet appel au Sénat
discutons amendons des bâtons mais à la
fin votons ce texte votons-le car
garantir aux Français que leur retraite
seront payées n'est ni de droite ni du
centre ni de gauche c'est tout
simplement
œuvré pour l'intérêt général
cet appel n'est ni idéaliste ni
déconnecté des réalités politiques à
l'oeuvre au Parlement car en effet la
progression des débats dans le pays a
permis de trouver des points de
convergence qui rendent possible ce
compromis et je souhaite les partager
brièvement avec vous
premier point de convergence politique
qui me semble intéressant de noter plus
personne ne remet en question le
problème de financement de nos retraites
et s'il est un progrès permis par le
débat à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
d'avoir vu la partie gauche de
l'hémistique la nupesse reconnaître
enfin qu'il y a un problème de
financement pour notre système de
retraite cela a été dit par plusieurs
députés de laupette les faits sont là et
les faits sont têtus en 2002 notre
sécurité sociale devait payer la
retraite de 12 millions de retraités en
2030 elle devra payer la retraite de 20
millions de retraités c'est un quasi
doublement en une génération quel pays
pourrait absorber ce choc sans rien
faire aucun et d'ailleurs tous les pays
européens ou presque ont réformé leur
retraite c'est un premier point d'accord
je crois qui me paraît essentiel et je
tiens à cet égard à saluer la qualité
des travaux conduits par Catherine
Deroche et Elisabeth Doisneau René Paul
Savary et Sylvie Vermeillet dans cette
assemblée il témoigne d'une volonté
sincère
monter les problèmes et vous nous
trouverez toujours à vos côtés pour cela
ensuite le contexte social du pays nous
oblige tous collectivement notre
avertissement est clair enlever un euro
de pouvoir d'achat aux Français qui
travaillent ou retraités seraient d'une
injustice presque cynique nous nous y
opposerons de toutes nos forces comme
nous l'avons fait à l'Assemblée
nationale où les propositions en matière
de taxes d'impôts de cotisation ont été
nombreuses on nous a proposé de taxer
les heures supplémentaires alors même
qu'un ouvrier sur deux dans notre pays
fait des heures supplémentaires on nous
a proposé de taxer les petites
successions dans notre pays 80% des
successions sont aujourd'hui exonérées
d'impôts les amendements venus de la
nupaisse nous proposaient de taxer
toutes les successions dès le premier
euro y compris les petites successions à
30000 40000 euros de Français qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie dont le travail
a été taxé toute leur vie et qui aura
été à nouveau taxé au moment de la
succession on nous a proposé d'augmenter
les charges pour les petits artisans les
petits commerçants les petits chefs
d'entreprise 700 euros de plus pour un
salarié au Smic de charge c'est ce qui
était proposé à l'Assemblée nationale
cela voudrait dire que pour un boulanger
qui emploie trois salariés au SMIC il
aurait dû en licencier un pour payer les
charges des deux autres qui étaient
proposées dans les amendements c'est
exactement les propositions qui nous ont
été faites mais je vois qu'elles ont
aussi leur défenseur ici notre
conviction notre conviction c'est que
c'est le travail qui crée la richesse
pas les nouveaux impôts enfin
[Applaudissements]
notre système actuel est injuste et il
faut le corriger pour les travailleurs
qui ont des métiers pénibles et qui
arrivent cassés à la retraite pour les
femmes dans les spécificités de carrière
en lien notamment avec la maternité et
l'éducation des enfants mais également
avec des inégalités de rémunération ne
sont pas assez prises en compte au sein
même du système de retraite pour les
petites retraites qui sont trop basses
et que nous voulons revaloriser voilà en
toute transparence les points d'accord
qui sont je crois largement partagés sur
les bancs et qui rendent possible la
perspective d'un compromis en tout cas
je l'espère nous y sommes pour notre
part tout à fait prêt notre volonté est
réelle elle est sincère elle est entière
mais je suis lucide si l'Assemblée
nationale a été la chambre des
divergences brutales je ne crois pas que
le Sénat sera pour autant celle des
convergences miraculeuses car un
compromis se construit à certaines
conditions la discussion dans laquelle
nous nous engageons la capacité à faire
évoluer notre projet nous la démontrons
mais le compromis se construit aussi par
la cohérence que les Français attendent
de nous tous je rappelle que si les
parlementaires qui soutiennent depuis
des années une réforme des retraites par
le recul progressif de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite répondent à l'appel
que nous lançons alors votez une réforme
serait non seulement possible mais ce
serait même logique en matière de
retraite la majorité sénatoriale a en
effet incontestablement le mérite de la
constance et je ne doute pas qu'elle
aura aussi celui de la cohérence
puisqu'elle vote chaque année en PLFSS
des mesures visant à assurer l'équilibre
de la branche vieillesse le projet du
gouvernement est celui que cette
majorité sénatoriale défend de longue
date sont donc proches je pense
notamment au report de l'âge légal de à
64 ans à l'accélération de l'allongement
de la durée et d'assurance requises pour
obtenir le taux plein autour de mesures
contenues dans l'article 7 de ce PLF RSS
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer cet esprit
de responsabilité dans un jeu politique
ou malheureusement de trop nombreux
responsables choisissent parfois
d'ignorer le danger qui pèse sur nos
finances publiques en bref je crois un
compromis possible au Sénat j'y crois et
je l'appelle de mes vœux car ce serait
vrai démocratiquement pour l'intérêt
général je le dis la force du compromis
il vaut toujours mieux que le fait
accompli l'intérêt général je l'ai dit
c'est de payer sereinement les pensions
de bientôt 20 millions de retraités et
pour cela l'équilibre financier est
indispensable et donc il n'est pas
négociable le menacé n'est pas une
option je dis bien indispensable car ce
n'est pas une variable d'ajustement de
la réforme l'équilibre financier n'est
pas secondaire c'est le moteur de cette
réforme puisqu'il s'agit de dire que
nous voulons pouvoir continuer à payer
chaque mois les pensions de bientôt 20
millions de retraités dans notre pays
parlons donc équilibre financier
quelques instants mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ma responsabilité de
ministre des comptes publics c'est de
dire la vérité sur les chiffres et donc
sur le potentiel impact budgétaire de
mesure votée par le Parlement le texte
qui vous a été transmis venant de
l'Assemblée nationale au sens textuel du
terme est à l'équilibre
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
discutées et votées en commission qui
coûte évidemment pour notre système de
retraite je sais que nous recherchons
tous l'équilibre du système et nous
souhaitons pas alourdir davantage son
déficit nous devrons donc pouvoir
discuter de façon approfondie et sereine
au cours de nos débats je pense d'abord
à l'amendement permettant aux assurés
ayant obtenu au moins un trimestre de
majoration durée d'assurance au titre de
la maternité de l'adoption ou de
l'éducation des enfants et justifiant
d'une carrière complète à 63 ans de
s'ouvrir des droits assurcotte sans
devoir attendre l'âge de 64 ans nous
avons nous aurons évidemment ce débat
mais la première ministre a rappelé
notre ouverture vis-à-vis de mesure de
bonification pour les femmes et qui
contribuent à gommer les écarts dans le
niveau des pensions les évaluations sont
encore en train d'être affinés mais le
coût d'une telle mesure est évidemment
très important
s'agissant de la proposition de
maintenir à 60 ans l'âge minimum de
départ en retraite anticipée pour
incapacité permanente elle représente
combinée aux ajustements permettant à
davantage d'assurer d'être éligible à ce
dispositif présenté en texte initial un
surcoût de plus de 250 millions d'euros
à horizon 2030 dont 100 millions d'euros
pour le système de retraite je pense
aussi à l'amendement prévoyant le
maintien de l'âge d'éligibilité à la
retraite progressive à 60 ans au lieu de
son report à 62 ans qui coûte un peu
plus de 100 millions d'euros en 2030
s'agissant des mesures visant à
favoriser le recrutement des seniors je
sais que la commission des affaires
sociales a proposé la création d'un
contrat de fin de carrière ouvert aux
salariés d'au moins 60 ans ce contrat a
duré indéterminé serait exonéré de
cotisation famille par ailleurs le
dispositif prévoit la possibilité pour
l'employeur de mettre à la retraite le
salarié si ce dernier remplit les
conditions pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein
je vois bien l'idée qui est de inciter
les employeurs à recruter des seniors et
à les maintenir dans l'entreprise
jusqu'à ce que ces derniers puissent
Lider leur pensions là encore si je
comprends l'intention des rapporteurs je
souhaite alerter sur le coup
considérable d'une telle mesure qui
pourrait avoisiner les 800 millions
d'euros selon une première estimation
provisoire mais nous aurons l'occasion
dans des battre il y a par ailleurs un
risque d'effet de seuil si j'additionne
les coûts de chacune de ces mesures en
retenant en retenant que celles dont les
conséquences financières sont les plus
importantes l'équilibre financier de
notre système à horizon 2030 s'éloigne
indubitablement je veux le dire
clairement nous souhaitons pouvoir
respecter cet équilibre
soyons clairs parler de dépenses
supplémentaires n'a jamais été un tabou
mais si nous perdons de vue l'équilibre
financier du régime de retraite une
réforme serait non seulement vaine mais
contre-productive l'équilibre financier
n'est évidemment pas une fin en soi mais
il n'est pas pour autant accessoire
c'est une condition indispensable à ce
que nous voulons faire permettre une vie
de travail donne droit à une retraite
décente enfin puisque j'ai vu aussi dans
vos amendements des propositions en ce
sens je souhaite dès le début de nos
débats vous rendre compte des progrès
que nous accomplissons en matière de
lutte contre la fraude grâce à la mesure
que vous avez adopté en loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 les caisses d'assurance vieillesse
ne pourront plus verser la SPA à compter
de juillet prochain sur des comptes
bancaires étrangers c'est une
disposition que j'avais proposé à
l'Assemblée nationale qui devait entrer
en vigueur au 1er janvier 2024 à la
suite d'un amendement sénatorial nous
l'avons avancé au 1er juillet 2023 c'est
même caisse de sécurité sociale auront
accès enfin aux fichiers FICOBA des
bancaire pour lutter non seulement
contre la fraude à la résidence mais
aussi contre les fraudes à l'usurpation
d'identité j'ai eu l'occasion il y a
quelques jours de communiquer sur le
bilan des fraudes en 2022 nous avons
notamment des menthlés un réseau de
front de fraude horrible lituanien pour
les caisses d'allocations familiales
évidemment nous devons mieux et nous
devons renforcer le contrôle de
l'identité concernant les pensions
versées à l'étranger qui concernent un
million 100000 retraités dont 510 000 en
Europe et 440 000 dans les pays du
Maghreb nous avons également renforcé
nos contrôles nous prévoyons également
de déployer dès les prochains mois des
outils biométriques pour permettre aux
assurés volontaires de procéder au
contrôle d'existence un décret en ce
sens est en cours d'examen par la CNIL
et sera publié au cours des prochaines
semaines soyez assurés que compte tenu
de l'ampleur du déficit pour nos
retraites nous prenons toutes les
mesures de lutte contre la fraude pour
assurer le paiement ou juste droit et ne
pas ajouter au déficit structurel un
déficit imputable au fraudeur
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs quelques-uns des débats que
nous devrons avoir je sais que nous
serons à la hauteur de ce qu'attendre
nos compatriotes et de l'idée qu'ils se
font du débat parlementaire j'essaierai
pour ma part de faire preuve d'écoute et
d'ouverture pour construire avec vous un
système de retraite plus juste et plus
soutenable en introduction de ma prise
de parole je vous lançais un appel un
appel pour agir afin de payer nos
retraites un appel pour échanger et
s'entendre un appel pour un compromis
politique au service des Français mais
s'il est un appel que nous devons
entendre c'est celui des Français qui
dans les débats qu'ils ont vu ce sont
parfois demandés si au fond cela valait
la peine d'avoir des débats en ayant
trop souvent et si souvent le sentiment
y compris par ceux qui prétendent les
défendre et défendre ceux qui s'opposent
à cette réforme en ayant le sentiment de
n'être ni entendu ni défendu à nous de
leur prouver le contraire discutons et
avançons pour eux je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
Madame Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse
madame la rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues comme vous le savez depuis
2020 la commission des affaires sociales
a souvent réclamé au gouvernement qu'il
déposent un projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
afin que le Parlement puisse se
prononcer en temps utile sur les
bouleversements que cette crise a
entraîné sur les comptes sociaux trois
années de suite les prévisions et
objectifs de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale ont été rendus caduques
en cours d'exercice aussi bien en
recette qu'en dépense pourtant nous
n'avons pas été entendus et c'est en ce
début d'année 2023 que nous sommes
saisis d'un collectif social afin de
porter la réforme des retraites
alors même que les prévisions de la
dernière loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale n'ont pas été modifiées
en profondeur
je sais que c'est apparent paradoxe
motive une exception d'y recevabilité
dont nous débattrons tout à l'heure
j'indique tout de suite qu'à mes yeux un
tel véhicule législatif peut contenir de
tels dispositions la commission des
affaires sociales aurait d'ailleurs
mauvaise grâce à prétendre le contraire
puisqu'elle propose une telle réforme
depuis des années lors de l'examen du
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale de l'automne et sur le fond peu
de mesure pourrait tenir pourrait avoir
un impact sur les comptes de la Sécurité
sociale supérieure à celui d'une réforme
paramétrique des retraites
qu'un texte budgétaire soit le cadre
dans lequel le Parlement débat de la
pérennité financière de notre système de
retraite ne me choque donc pas au
contraire
il n'empêche que la plupart des mesures
que nous allons débattre auront un
impact financier à terme et que la
rectification des comptes de l'année
2023 n'est que mineur
en quelques mots le gouvernement n'a pas
fait évoluer les prévisions
macroéconomiques sur lesquelles il s'est
appuyé cet automne
il ne fait donc que tirer les
conséquences pour la seule année 2023 de
la réforme des retraites proposées par
le présente
celle-ci sont faibles et font apparaître
une légère dégradation du solde de la
branche vieillesse de 0,4 milliards
d'euros et celle-ci est due d'une part à
l'augmentation des dépenses à hauteur de
600 millions d'euros en raison notamment
de la majoration des minimas de pension
et d'autre part en sens inverse à une
économie de 200 millions d'euros grâce à
la première application du relèvement
des bornes d'âge à compter du 1er
septembre
au total le déficit consolidé des robes
et du FSV seraient dégradées de ce
montant passant de 7,1 à 7,5 milliards
d'euros
j'ajouterai simplement que le
gouvernement a déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale un amendement qui n'a pas été
examiné visant à augmenter l'ONDAM 2023
de 750 millions d'euros
en prenant en compte ce requalibrage la
dégradation du solde pourrait donc
dépasser un milliard d'euros par rapport
à la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
les débats sur l'article 15 si comme je
l'espère nous parvenons jusque là vous
permettront monsieur le ministre
d'expliquer pourquoi c'est ton dame 2023
doit être revalorisée dès à présent
alors qu'en novembre le gouvernement
soutenait contre la vie du Sénat qu'il
était parfaitement calibré
mais bien entendu le cadrage financier
le plus important intervient à terme
puisque l'objet même de ce texte est
d'organiser le retour à l'équilibre
financier de notre système de retraite à
l'horizon de 2030 dans un contexte
démographique délicat
à titre personnel je souscris à cet
objectif qui me semble cohérent avec les
positions que notre commission et
au-delà le Sénat ont défendu depuis
longtemps je relève qu'au fil de ses
amis le message du gouvernement avarié
bien davantage puisqu'il s'agissait une
année de refonder le système sans
objectif financier puis de refonder le
système en l'amortissant d'un âge pivot
puis de le réformer de façon
paramétrique afin de financer toutes
sortes de dépenses publiques et
finalement comme le Sénat de présenter
une réforme paramétrique pour équilibrer
le seul système de retraite dès lors il
est difficile de reprocher à nos
concitoyens d'avoir du mal à suivre la
pédagogie puisque le mot est à la mode
n'est de la répétition et non des
changements des changements de pied
pour en revenir au chiffre je les
reprends en quelques mots
les projections de l'année 2030 font
apparaître un déficit du système pris
dans son ensemble de quelques 13,5
milliards d'euros en l'absence de
réformes
il s'agit bien d'un chiffre annuel
dont le cumul creuserait une dette
susceptible de remettre en cause la
pérennité du système par répartition
créée à la Libération c'est à dire le
principe de solidarité entre les
générations qui fait que chaque
génération d'actifs finance par ses
cotisations les retraites de ces aînés
en comptant sur le fait que les
générations suivantes feront de même
face à ce trou de 13,5 milliards le
relèvement de l'âge légal et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
devrait rapporter
17,7 milliards d'euros en 2030 ce qui se
traduirait donc par un excédent
théorique de 4,2 milliards à cette
échéance
néanmoins le présent projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
contient diverses mesures dites
d'accompagnement
pour un total de 5,9 milliards d'euros
le trou donc de 1,7 milliards qui en
résultent a été comblé dans le projet
initial par deux mesures d'ailleurs
d'ordre réglementaire d'une part
l'augmentation de 0,12 points des
cotisations patronales vieillesse qui se
récompensés par la baisse du concurrence
des cotisations ATMP et d'autre part
l'augmentation de 1 point des
cotisations patronales de la cnr-a-cl
c'est donc d'un projet tout juste à
l'équilibre en 2030 par ailleurs fondé
sur des hypothèses qui les permit de
juger optimiste que l'Assemblée
nationale a été saisie le 23 janvier
comme vous le savez les débats n'ont pas
permis au députés d'aller au-delà de
l'examen de l'article de terre et seule
une mesure adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale aura un impact financier
positif significatif
l'harmonisation à 30% du taux de la
contribution assise sur les indemnités
de mise à la retraite d'un salarié à
l'initiative de l'employeur et de celle
versée à l'occasion d'une rupture
conventionnelle c'est donc le l'article
2 bis dont le rendement en 2030 est
estimé à 300 millions d'euros
cependant nous le savons aussi le
gouvernement a déposé des amendements à
l'Assemblée nationale qui n'ont pas pu
être examinés mais qui aurait eu un coup
de l'ordre de 850 millions d'euros s'ils
avaient été adoptés
cette présentation quelque peu aride
mais chers collègues vise à montrer que
même si le Sénat devra naturellement
avoir ses propres marqueurs nous ne
disposerons que de fort peu de marge de
manœuvre pour adopter des mesures
généreuses en recette comme en dépense
les quelques marges existantes ont déjà
été utilisées il ne serait pas
responsable de notre part de voter une
réforme qui suscite tant des mois dans
le pays si nous ne rétablissons pas
véritablement la trajectoire budgétaire
de notre système de retraite
la vraie générosité la vraie générosité
pour les générations futures consiste à
leur léguer un système de retraite
financièrement solide et dans lequel
elles peuvent avoir confiance
je conquerai en disant quelques mots des
articles que j'ai pu particulièrement
instruire en dehors des articles
récapitulatifs l'article premier
concerne la fermeture de plusieurs
régimes spéciaux selon la clause dite du
grand-père concrètement les nouveaux
personnels embauchés à partir du 1er
septembre 2023 cotiserait désormais au
régime général et non plus dans le
régime spécial cette mesure concernerait
les régimes suivants les industries
électriques et gazières la Régie
autonome des transports parisiens
l'éclair est employé de notaire la
Banque de France et les membres du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental même si ces listes peut
sembler présenter un certain aléas les
régimes retenus se caractérisent par un
déséquilibre financier compensé soit par
une subvention d'équilibre de l'État ou
de l'employeur dans le cas de la Banque
de France soit par une taxe spécifique
la Commission proposera donc au Sénat de
s'en tenir à l'équilibre ainsi défini au
bénéfice de l'adoption d'un amendement
de coordination
l'article premier bis c'est introduit
demande de rapport que je vous
proposerai de supprimer par ailleurs
l'article 3 qui prévoit l'abandon du
projet de transfert aux urssafs de
l'activité du recouvrement de l'agir
Carco et de la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation constitue un motif de
satisfaction pour notre commission enfin
c'est dans l'annexe A que figure le
principe de l'augmentation des
cotisations patronales pour la cnr-a-cl
je vous proposerai au nom de la
commission un amendement introduisant
dans la loi le principe de compensation
intégrale par l'État dès 2023 pour
conclure je m'appuierais sur les propos
de l'abbé Pierre qui disait la
responsabilité de chacun implique deux
actes vouloir savoir et
oser dire notre responsabilité ici au
Sénat repose il me semble sur ces deux
volontés complémentaires comprendre et
débattre je ne doute pas de chacune et
de chacun d'entre vous chers collègues
notre haute assemblée sera se montrer à
la hauteur de ses enjeux je vous
remercie
en général
la parole est à notre collègue René Paul
Savary rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse de la commission des affaires
sociales
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général madame la
rapporteur pour sur pour avis de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues la voilà la voilà enfin cette
réforme c'est très forme attendue si
nécessaire pressante si urgente mais si
longtemps repoussé la voilà enfin
reprise par le gouvernement cette
proposition sénatoriale renouvelée année
après année voter revotez contre la vie
de ce gouvernement
alors pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a-t-il donc pas jugé bon de se rallier
dès 2018 au recommandations du Sénat la
pente serait moins raide le déficit
moins abyssal que de temps perdu que de
temps perdu néanmoins
[Applaudissements]
néanmoins les faits sont là
messieurs les ministres il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
les mesures de redressement des comptes
de la branche vieillesse sont plus que
jamais impératifs madame la rapporteur
général c'est la raison pour laquelle la
Commission approuve les dispositions
d'âge de l'article 7
face à l'accélération de l'allongement
de la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein 43 ans voté par la gauche de
cette émission
cet article 7 reprend le relèvement de
l'âge à 64 ans proposé par la droite de
cette hémicycle
sachez sachez que nous serons quand même
toujours attentifs au rendement des
mesures en ce qui concerne l'article 8
comme je le soulignais en novembre
dernier pour la quatrième fois mes chers
collègues il est nécessaire que ces
mesures ne pénalisent pas les
travailleurs les plus fragiles que
soient prises en compte les spécificités
de carrière différentes aussi aussi la
commission vous propose d'améliorer
l'article 8 qui aménage les différents
dispositifs de retraite
anticipées de façon à accorder une
surcote de 5% aux assurés ayant obtenu
au moins un trimestre de majoration au
titre de la maternité de l'adoption ou
de l'éducation et arriver à une carrière
complète pour qu'à 64 ans c'est
bénéficiaires puissent disposer d'une
surcote
cette surcote est quand même un élément
tout à fait déterminant qui permet
d'améliorer les pensions des mers de
famille et de réduire les quarts de
pension entre les hommes et les femmes
il s'agira pour la nation de compenser
de compenser les difficultés
professionnelles
rencontrées par ces femmes du fait de
leur charge de famille il s'agira de
réduire l'écart de pension entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est de la
natalité que dépend l'équilibre
financier d'un système par répartition
néfaste
[Applaudissements]
face à cet effort collectif il n'est pas
envisageable de demander à nos
concitoyens de travailler plus sans
lutter contre ceux qui ne respectent pas
la générosité de notre modèle social
nous exigeons plus de fermeté de la part
du gouvernement qu'au minimum soit
appliquer dès le premier septembre 2023
monsieur le ministre les dispositions
que nous avons votées déjà en 2020 elle
permet de recourir à la biométrie pour
le contrôle de l'existence des
bénéficiaires de pension de retraités
français résidant à l'étranger
article 9 allonger la durée du travail
implique en nous d'améliorer la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle et
de garantir une juste compensation des
effets de la pénibilité à cet égard les
assouplissements du dispositif de
retraite en anticipé pour incapacité
permanente proposée à cet article 9
associé un recul de l'âge de départ à 62
ans nous semble insuffisants la
Commission propose donc de maintenir cet
âge de départ à 60 ans s'agissant des
victimes de maladies professionnelles ou
ayant connu un certain nombre d'années
préposition assez facteurs de pénibilité
s'agissant du compte
professionnel de prévention le C2P les
améliorations proposées qu'il s'agisse
de son déplafonnement ou de la création
d'une possibilité d'utilisation dans le
cadre d'un projet de reconversion
professionnelle nous semble elles aller
dans le bon sens pour renforcer la
prévention par rapport à la réparation
de même les facteurs de risque
ergonomique il représente une cause
majeure de maladies professionnelles il
paraît pertinent que ces facteurs
fassent l'objet de mesures spécifiques
telles la création du fonds
d'investissement la Commission propose
cependant d'y intégrer les agents
chimiques qui ont été exclues du C2P en
article 10 il est également nécessaire
de mobiliser la solidarité nationale
pour soutenir le revenu des retraités
frappés par la précarité frappé par
l'inflation après plusieurs années de
soude sous indexation des pensions par
le gouvernement cet article 10 permettra
de revaloriser les minimas de pension
des assurés des régimes alignés et du
régime des salariés agricoles liquidant
leur pension à compter du premier
septembre prochain à hauteur de 100
euros pour une carrière complète
conduisait au niveau du SMIC de façon à
porter leur pension plus globale à 85 %
du SMIC net carrière complète
cotisations à niveau du SMIC que les
choses soient claires quand on
retraitait actuel une majoration de
pensions pouvant atteindre elle aussi
100 euros maxi mum sera versé aux
assurés bénéficiant du taux plein et
justifiant d'au moins 120 trimestres
cotisés c'est ce que nous avions réclamé
c'est ce que nous avons obtenu dans la
même logique la Commission proposera
notamment d'ouvrir la majoration de
pensions des parents d'au moins trois
enfants et 10% pour trois enfants de
l'ouvrir aux professionnels libéraux
sans oublier monsieur le ministre les
avocats
article 11 c'est la prise en compte de
certains stages d'insertion dans la vie
professionnelle dont les travaux
d'utilité collectives les prendre en
compte comme période assimilée à des
durées d'assurance c'est une juste
reconnaissante article 12 c'est la
création d'une assurance vieillesse des
aidant là aussi c'est une juste
reconnaissance envers celles et ceux qui
mettent leur carrière professionnelle
entre parenthèses on profite d'un proche
plus vulnérable article 13
une réforme des retraites qui allonge la
durée du travail ne peut être envisagée
sans favoriser l'emploi des seniors
ce texte est insuffisamment imaginatif
il
uttait de bon temps me semble-t-il de
débattre d'une loi travail prenant en
compte l'employabilité des seniors avant
de leur rendement des plus
nous remettons les choses dans le bon
sens
nous souhaitons engager dès à présent
une campagne de mobilisation
un seigneur une solution
qu'elle est sur celle que nous avons
connue
un jeune une solution
[Musique]
le premier mesure
permettront de favoriser leur
recrutement leur maintien en emploi et
leur transition vers la retraite c'est
ce que nous avons proposé et la
commission réhausse à 300 salariés le
seuil des entreprises concernées par la
publication du fameux index senior le
seuil de 50 salariés n'est pas adapté
monsieur le ministre vous en conviendrez
300 c'est le seuil des entreprises qui
doivent aborder le thème de l'emploi des
seniors lorsqu'elle négocie sur la
gestion des emplois et des parcours
professionnels si ce dispositif
limite constitutionnelle dans le PLFSS
donne quelques informations sur la
situation de l'emploi des seniors à
vouloir avouons-le il est bien
insuffisant et aussi pour favoriser le
recrutement des seniors au chômage nous
proposons du concret un contrat de fin
de carrière ex onéré de cotisation
familiale réservée au plus de 60 ans qui
poursuivent leurs activités jusqu'à la
liquidation de leur trop-plein de leur
taux plein et éventuellement jusqu'à
l'âge d'annulation de la décote c'est un
contrat important entre le Seigneur le
Seigneur et son employé
afin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour en faire un instrument véritable
incitatif nous proposons de la mettre
des 60 ans et enfin le cumul emploi
retraite sera enfin créateur de Troie ce
que nous réclamons depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour conclure pour
conclure bien que tardif il y a un con
complet bien qu'un suffisant ce texte
doit être soutenu par notre assemblée il
y va de la sauvegarde de notre système
de répartition il en va de la garantie
pour les générations futures de
bénéficier d'une pension décente au
terme d'une vie de travail pour autant
pour autant nous réservons notre soutien
à l'adoption des amendements de justice
sociale que nous proposons nous vous
savons de bonne volonté monsieur le
ministre à vous de nous en donner
maintenant les preuves oui chers
collègues comme d'autres pays autour de
nous qui eux ont déjà pris leur
responsabilité la France vieillit les
naissances ne comblent plus notre
législité croissante nous devons avoir
le courage de réagir non nous ne voulons
pas que nos enfants travaillent plus de
45 ans non nous ne voulons pas que nos
enfants travaillent après 65 ans à nous
de prendre nos responsabilités dans la
sérénité et le respect merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
Madame la rapporteur pour lui de la
commission des finances madame Sylvie
vermeiller vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue
[Applaudissements]
de la commission des affaires sociales
madame monsieur les rapporteur chers
collègues la commission des finances a
souhaité se saisir pour ravi sur
l'ensemble du plfssr au regard de ses
effets certains sur les finances
publiques
notre système de retraites repose sur le
principe de répartition selon lequel les
cotisations des actifs financent les
pensions des retraités soient 345,1
milliard en 2021 dans le scénario retenu
par le gouvernement et jugé optimiste
par la commission des finances avec une
croissance de 1% et un taux de chômage à
quatre et demi pour cent le déficit du
système atteindrait 13,5 milliards
d'euros fin 2030 et 150 milliards en
cumulent pour les dix années à venir la
stabilisation relative des dépenses ne
compensera pas la baisse des ressources
qui provient de la réduction du nombre
de cotisants de la diminution de
l'emploi public donc des cotisations et
de la réduction des transferts en
provenance des branches familles et
chômage en dépense le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites souligne que
les effets de la hausse du nombre de
pensionnés qui seront 23 millions en
2027 contre 19 aujourd'hui seront
partiellement atténués par la
stabilisation voir la baisse du niveau
des retraites rapportées au PIB
les dépenses progresseront néanmoins de
1,8% par an en volume sur le quinquennat
progression incompatible avec l'objectif
du gouvernement de réduction du déficit
public à l'horizon 2027
la réforme est centrée sur une
majoration de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits de 62 à 64 ans et l'accélération
de la durée de cotisation portée à 43
annuités des 2027 le gouvernement il
carte l’hypothèse d'une hausse de
cotisation qui réduirait le pouvoir
d'achat de 442 euros annuels par
cotisant en 2030 ou la diminution des
pensions qui seraient de 719 euros
annuels par retraité en 2030 pour
compenser le déficit
la progression de l'emploi des seniors
constitue un enjeu majeur puisque bien
qu'en est hausse depuis 2003 celui-ci
reste inférieur à la moyenne européenne
de
59,6%. une attention sur mesure devra
être portée au 55 64 ans car la réforme
de 2010 avait induit une progression du
chômage pour ces classes d'âge
le montant des réserves placé par les
régimes de retraite atteignez fin 2021
180,4 milliards d'euros dont 86,5
milliards d'euros à l'agir Carco qui va
pouvoir réfléchir à l'utilisation de ces
excédents confortés par la réforme la
perspective de recettes supplémentaire
pour le système des retraites mais
également pour les autres branches de la
sécurité sociale et le budget de l'État
doit nous inciter à réviser le devenir
du Fonds de réserve des retraites
admirablement gérées depuis 2001
afin de nous prémunir d'autres aléas
démographiques n'est-il pas
indispensable de fléchir des recettes
supplémentaires liées à la réforme vers
ce fond qui sécuriserait notre système
par répartition le projet de loi
initiale propose plusieurs mesures
d'accompagnement estimer à 5,9 milliards
d'euros en 2030 année prévu pour
l'équilibre du système mais ce retour à
l'équilibre est fragilisé par les
amendements du Gouvernement déposés en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
estimée à 800 millions à l'horizon 2030
vigilance sur ce point la réforme
prévoit également qu'à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 les régimes des retraites
des industries électriques et gazières
de la RATP de la Banque de France
d'éclairs et employés de notaire et des
élus du Conseil économique social et
environnemental n'aphilie plus de
nouveaux cotisants ces régimes sont
actuellement équilibrés soit au moyen
d'une taxe spéciale soit au moyen d'une
subvention d'équilibre versée par l'État
soit structurellement déficitaire le
montant des cotisations ne couvrant pas
celui des pensions
la fermeture de ces régimes entraînera
mécaniquement une attrition du nombre de
cotisants pour les caisses concernées je
m'étonne que les conséquences
financières ne soient pas d'ores et déjà
prévues notamment le reversement par la
CNAV et l'agirco des cotisants des
cotisations des nouveaux affiliés à
l'instar de ce qui fonctionne pour la
SNCF le relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits de deux ans concernent
également tous les agents de la fonction
publique il ne devrait avoir que peu
d'effets car l'âge de départ est déjà de
63 ans et 8 mois pour laisser dentaires
et 60 ans pour les actifs le solde
technique du compte d'affectation
spéciale pension pourrait être de 0,7
milliards d'euros en 2027 puis 1,1
milliard d'euros en 2030 de nouveau je
préconise une immobilisation de ces
excédents au sein du Fonds de réserve
des retraites afin de garantir l'avenir
des retraites publics au-delà de ces
remarques la commission des finances du
Sénat estime que ce projet de loi va
dans le sens d'un rééquilibrage du
système des retraites et que cet
objectif doit être soutenu je vous
remercie merci madame le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant passer à la
discussion de la motion pendant à
opposer l'exception d'y recevabilité
motion distribution numéro
172 et je vais donner immédiatement la
parole à madame la Présidente pour la
motion
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres où il n'y a que des Messieurs
mes chers collègues
tout être humain qui en raison de son
âge son état physique ou mental de sa
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence la lecture de ce
11e alinéa du Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 sonne pour nous tous
à l'heure de légiférer sur une énième
réforme de réduction du droit à une
retraite digne comme un rappel aux
valeurs fondamentales de notre
République
issue de notre histoire le préambule de
1946 fait partie intégrante de notre
bloc de constitutionnalité avec la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 ainsi que bien entendu
la Constitution de 1958 il reprend de
nombreux points du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance qui a permis
la naissance de la sécurité sociale et
sous la direction du ministre communiste
Ambroise Croizat de la création du
régime de retraite par répartition qui
perdure aujourd'hui encore
malgré les coups de boutoir des
partisans dogmatiques de la loi du
marché
cette réforme des retraites ou plutôt
cette destruction programmée de la
solidarité que porte la répartition
qu'Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement
tentent d'imposer à notre peuple et
profondément injuste elle est injuste
moralement alors que sur fond d'une
inflation galopante nos concitoyens se
remettent à peine d'une crise sanitaire
violente alors que notre peuple plonge
progressivement dans une précarité dans
le travail mais aussi dans la vie
quotidienne du logement à l'accès aux
soins alors que les uns et les autres
sont frappés d'horreur par la guerre qui
tue à nos portes vous ne trouvez rien de
mieux monsieur monsieur les ministres
mais aussi Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle et sénatorial que de
demander à nos concitoyens de travailler
plus longtemps quelle violence quelle
violence faite à ses salariés souvent
usée pas seulement du fait de métier
jugé pénible qui devront travailler plus
y compris après des carrières bien
longues quelle violence quelle violence
faite aux qui du fait de leur parcours
professionnel heurté ou d'une plus
grande exposition au chômage partiel
devront travailler plus longtemps
d'emblée je dénonce je dénonce les
propositions que je juge pour ma part
insultante pour toutes les femmes de ce
pays émanant du président Retailleau et
du groupe les républicains sous prétexte
de vous préoccuper de la cause des
femmes vous les enfermez à quelques
jours du 8 mars dans un rôle de mère de
plus grandes familles possibles en
instaurant une prime à la maternité
préoccupez-vous plutôt
d'instaurer l'égalité salariale entre
les deux sexes cela assurera 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires de cotisations
sociales pour œuvrer contre tout nouveau
déficit à venir quelle violence quelle
violence pour les jeunes lycéens
étudiants et je ne travailleur qui
aujourd'hui ce sont à juste titre
condamnés à travailler jusqu'à un âge
avancé beaucoup estimant qu'ils n'auront
jamais de retraites il est de bon temps
de se moquer de ces jeunes qui
s'inquiètent de leur vieillesse mais
mesurez-vous l'angoisse de la précarité
de la guerre de notre planète qui
s'abîme à un rythme fou votre projet
messieurs les ministres face à l'état de
notre société du monde relève de la
provocation il n'y a pas de
justification financière comme le corps
nous l'a démontré vous n'explorez aucun
financement alternatif ce qui n'est pas
étonnant car forcément c'est désagréable
pour le patronat et pour les plus riches
et ce n'est pas étonnant car vous êtes
dans autre monde dans votre bulle celle
des comptables de Bruxelles et de Bercy
aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude populaire se transforme en
colère des millions de citoyens et de
citoyens sont descendus dans les rues
des petites moyennes et grandes villes
l'unité syndicale vous a surpris mais
elle est solide elle tient et elle
construit méthodiquement la levée de
boucliers du 7 mars et des jours qui
suivront tous les actifs ou presque
retoquent votre réforme une majorité des
électeurs LR et centricité opposent et
cela vous devriez l'entendre mais
monsieur le Président du Sénat et
Monsieur messieurs retaillot et Monsieur
Marseille l'opinion publique ne recule
pas non elle exige le retrait de ce
projet mais plutôt que d'entendre la
raison comme l'on fait certains de vos
prédécesseurs
vous vous entêtez sans téter c'est
mettre en danger la cohésion sociale ces
fracturé c'est jeter le trouble les
seules responsables de la situation
actuelle du blocage annoncé c'est le
gouvernement c'est Monsieur Macron et
demain ce sera peut-être vous mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
j'évoquais d'entrer le préambule de 46
toute cette première partie de mon
propos le confirme vous violez la
Constitution et vous faites planer une
menace contre le régime même de retraite
en prenant la capitalisation qui est
contraire à l'idée fondamentale selon
laquelle c'est la nation qui assure les
retraites et non pas les marchés
financiers
malgré tout cela
malgré tout cela si si monsieur le
ministre nous savons un peu nous savons
un peu malgré tout cela
Emmanuel Macron persiste et veut une
adoption rapide de ce projet portant
réforme des retraites il a inscrit cette
dernière donc dans un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale réservée comme son nom l'indique
a des textes purement financiers
l'avantage donc c'est la limitation du
temps de débat 50 jours en tout 20 jours
pour l'assemblée qu'un jour pour le
Sénat un texte non voté par une
assemblée et donc transmis à l'autre
assemblée et même en cas de non votes de
la seconde une CMP composée de 14
parlementaires et convoqué et peut
valider le texte l'amender et le
réécrire et en cas d'échec de la CMP le
gouvernement peut légiférer par
ordonnance ainsi un projet d'une
importance politique et sociale
considérable peut-être un jour promulgué
sans avoir été examiné jusqu'à son terme
par une des deux assemblées voir les
deux évidemment pour le gouvernement et
maintenant la majorité sénatoriale il
existe une solution
ne débattons pas ou à peine monsieur le
Président du Sénat mes chers collègues
comment avez-vous pu accepter de
délibérer d'un texte qui n'a pas été
soumis au vote de l'Assemblée nationale
je le rappelle les députés sont élus au
suffrage universel direct
l'accepter
l'accepter participe l'accepter
participe au coup de force engagé par le
président de la République contre les
institutions pour imposer cette réforme
massivement rejetée tout n'est pas
permis et cette tentative de case contre
le Parlement et peut-être le pari de
trop engagé par Monsieur Macron la seule
affirmation d'une légitimité liée à
l'affirmation durant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et bancale
chacun sait que le Président de la
République a été élu pour faire barrage
à Marine Le Pen et certainement pas pour
appliquer le recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite
la méthode profondément
anti-démocratique utilisée par le
gouvernement qui contraint le débat
parlementaire n'est pas conforme à la
Constitution Dominique Rousseau
professeur émérite de droit
constitutionnels le confirme je le cite
l'article 47 peut être utilisé pour une
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale les délais sont compressifs car
le budget bien évidemment doit être
adopté avant le 31 décembre or là il n'y
a aucune obligation que la réforme soit
votée en mars plutôt qu'en juin ou plus
tard fin de citation selon monsieur
Rousseau les sages pourraient censurer
pour détournement de procédures et je le
cite à nouveau mon analyse c'est qu'il y
a un risque sérieux
d'anticonstitutionnalité car
l'utilisation du 47 ans dans ce cas
porte atteinte à la sincérité des débats
fin de citation sincérité le mot et
lâcher quelle sincérité en effet
les deux chambres n'examine pas le texte
dans son ensemble Benjamin Morel pour sa
part rappelle que la décision du 3
juillet 86 a autorisé l'application du
47 ans à un pellet SS rectificatif mais
à condition de concerner des mesures je
cite d'ordre financier nécessaire pour
assurer la continuité de la vie normale
nationale votre texte menace-t-il la
continuité non ce n'est pas le cas
monsieur le Président nous sommes
aujourd'hui au Sénat et certaines choses
doivent être dites clairement avant
d'entamer l'examen du texte vu le cadre
qui est imposé par le gouvernement par
le gouvernement que d'aucun estime
contraire à la Constitution je redis
avec la plus grande solennité que nous
ne comprendrons pas et que nous
n'accepterons pas que le Sénat avec sa
majorité
usent de procédure visant à accélérer le
débat à l'abroger à le tuer nous
n'accepterons pas que le droit
constitutionnel la liberté de parole
tout autant constitutionnelle doit être
mise en cause soit mise en cause
monsieur le Président allez-vous
aujourd'hui accompagner le gouvernement
et Monsieur Macron dans un coup de force
contre le Parlement qui si le texte
venait à être adopté par la seule CMP
voire pire par des ordonnances inusitées
sans habilitation ni ratification
relèverait d'un coup d'État feutré
contre les institutions de la République
ce texte donc et contraire à la
Constitution car il s'attaque à des
principes de solidarité au cœur de notre
République il est contraire à la
Constitution car il manipule la
Constitution pour contraindre le
Parlement le soumettre ne laissons pas
mes chers collègues au Conseil
constitutionnel le soin de censurer ce
projet de loi signifiions clairement
quelle que soit nos engagements
politiques que le Parlement doit être
respecté pour que la démocratie
le soit
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
la présidente Catherine de roche
contre la motion
je m'exprime contre la motion du
recevabilité et ensuite il y aura la vie
de la commission alors j'ai bien entendu
tout ce qu'a dit la présidente assassine
bon l'impact des retraites sur le
finance publique et indéniable et
puisque c'est même l'un des premiers
postes de nos dépenses publiques et
comme j'aurai l'occasion de le rappeler
en discussion générale cette réforme est
bien une réforme budgétaire dont
l'objectif est de garantir la
soutenabilité notre système de retraite
et assurer ainsi sa pérennité elle a
donc par conséquence toute sa place en
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale j'entends aussi l'argument selon
lequel cette procédure ne laisserait pas
le temps nécessaire au débat je voudrais
s'il y aller que nous avons ouvert avec
le président Larcher plus de 100 heures
de débats alors que nous passons en
général 30 heures à examiner le PLFSS
qui concerne toutes les branches
l'ensemble des recettes et des dépenses
de la sécurité sociale
je rappelle que chaque année depuis 2019
à l'initiative de rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour
l'assurance vieillesse le Sénat a
examiné cette réforme et a pu en
débattre alors le Conseil
constitutionnel sera certainement saisi
en effet il se conformément à sa mission
j'entends bien la présidente assassy qui
voudrait qu'on anticipe ce que pourrait
être une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel nous ne sommes pas sur
cette ligne et j'invite donc le Sénat à
se prononcer contre cette motion
merci merci madame la Présidente je vais
demander l'avis de la commission madame
la rapporteur général
les auteurs de
te la constitutionnalité de ce PLFR SS
d'une part sur le fond ce projet de loi
remettrait en cause le droit à la
retraite et d'autre part sur la forme à
tel texte ne pourrait pas être le
vecteur d'une réforme des retraites je
crois m'être exprimé tout à l'heure à la
tribune sur le premier motif cette
réforme ne remet pas en cause le droit à
la retraite ni le fonctionnement de la
retraite par répartition au contraire le
redressement financier du système de
retraite a précisément pour objet d'en
assurer la pérennité pour les futurs
générations
et il en va de soi qu'au regard de
l'évolution de l'espérance de vie et je
pense qu'on aura tous les éléments au
cours de nos débats sur l'évolution de
l'espérance de vie il y a d'ailleurs eu
dernièrement des éléments qui ont été
portés à notre connaissance par
l'adresse qui indique que l'espérance de
vie sans incapacité à 65 ans est
supérieur à la moyenne européenne en
France en bonne santé sans incapacité
c'est ce que je dis sans incapacité
et donc le décalage progressif de l'âge
de départ ne prive pas nos concitoyens
du droit à bénéficier d'une retraite sur
le second motif la loi organique définit
les dispositions pouvant figurer dans un
plfsr RS et de nombreuses dispositions
de ce texte entre clairement dans ce
cadre
j'ajoute que même si les conséquences
financières de ce texte sur l'année 2023
sont modeste peu auront des faits en
fait je l'ai dit tout à l'heure à terme
sur les finances sociales reconnaissons
que de nombreux projets de loi de
finance rectificative ont porté des
mesures beaucoup moins substantielles
pour les finances publiques sans jamais
avoir été censuré
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons même si
le Conseil constitutionnel aura et ça a
été dit par la présidente de la
commission c'est certain à se prononcer
sur la place dans ce texte de chacun de
ces articles je donne un avis
défavorable à cette exception d'y
recevabilité
merci je voudrais voir la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente vous avez évoqué trois sujets
plusieurs sujets pardon notamment des
sujets de fonds le débat sur les
articles et sur les amendements nous
permettra très certainement d'y revenir
si tenter que la motion n'était pas
adoptée donc nous aurons j'espère en
tout cas l'occasion de vous convaincre
que cette réforme est à la fois juste
qu'elle porte des progrès qu'elle est
nécessaire je voudrais simplement
revenir sur trois points d'abord la
question de la recevabilité que vous
avez souligné et madame le rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales comme madame la Présidente en
soulignait à quel point les dispositions
que nous présentons ont un impact en des
conséquences sur les comptes sociaux
pour l'année 2023 ce qui justifie le
fait d'avoir recours à un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour l'année 2023 vous
avez ensuite madame la Présidente
considérait que la mise en œuvre de
l'article 47 tir1 pouvait poser une
difficulté je voudrais rappeler deux
choses la première c'est que si nous
sommes dans le cas de l'article 47-1 ça
n'est pas une décision du gouvernement
l'article 47 terrain s'applique à
l'ensemble des lois de finances et la
rest organique que votre assemblée a
adopté comme l'Assemblée nationale dit
que lorsque les lois de finances
rectificatives pour la sécurité sociale
comme pour l'État relève de la catégorie
des lois de finances et donc Stones sous
le coup de l'article 47-1 cet article
47-1 fixe un certain délai il ne prévoit
ni dérogation ni possibilité d'aller
au-delà et donc nous l'appliquons de
manière stricte mais cela a été rappelé
aussi cette application de l'article 47
terrain le respect de l'article 47-1
plus exactement permet au Parlement
d'avoir un délai d'examen de cette
réforme plus long que le délai
parlementaire consacré aux réforme des
retraites précédentes et enfin Madame la
Présidente vous avez considéré qu'il
n'était pas opportun d'examiner un texte
qui n'aurait pas été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale les différentes
dispositions que j'ai rappelé permettent
cet examen et organise un tel examen et
je voudrais simplement revenir d'un mot
sur les raisons qui ont amené à
l'Assemblée nationale à ne pas pouvoir
examiner totalement le texte à ne pas
pouvoir voter cette raison ne tient un
seul tient un seul mot l'obstruction
l'obstruction avec 20000 amendements qui
ont été déposés et des séries
d'amendements identiques imaginez madame
la Présidente et je sais que ça
n'arrivera pas ici mais imaginez madame
la Présidente que
le dernier jour du débat le dernier jour
du débat il y avait 68 séries
d'amendements identiques déposés par le
groupe de la France insoumise avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons mais
vous êtes leurs alliés mais avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons écouté
patiemment 68 intervenants différents du
groupe de la France insoumise avant même
de pouvoir donner un avis et alors même
que l'amendement ne concernait pas le
fond du texte c'est la description de ce
que j'ai appelé l'obstruction et ce qui
explique la situation que nous
connaissons pour toutes ces raisons bien
évidemment la vie est défavorable
merci
avant de consulter cela je vais demander
si à des explications de vote j'ai vu le
président de canner
chez le Président Monsieur les ministres
vous avez choisi le détourner l'objectif
pire peut-être l'esprit du 47,1 de la
Constitution pour museler le Parlement
ce n'est même plus à ce niveau-là de
l'obstruction je qualifierais cela de
piraterie parlementaire pour ne pas dire
de déni de démocratie le 12 mars à
minuit le coup près va tomber
pour la toute première fois depuis
l'introduction en 96 de ses lois de
financement au sein de notre
Constitution elles sont utilisées pour
mettre en place une réforme de grande
ampleur de notre système de retraite
c'est la première fois en procédant de
la sorte vous portez atteinte à la
crédibilité de notre Parlement à
l'équilibre de nos institutions et au
respect de la Constitution ces lois
financières ont pour objet le déterminer
les conditions générales de l'équilibre
financier de la sécurité sociale selon
les termes même de la Constitution et
vous n'ignorez pas que la procédure tout
à fait des rogatoire prévu pour leur
adoption poursuit un seul et unique
objectif garantir l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi de financement pour l'année à
venir avant le premier jour de l'année
civile concernée
cette procédure n'a jamais eu ne devrait
jamais avoir provocation de permettre
d'introduire insidieusement au terme
d'un examen accéléré tronqué
parfaitement inadapté aux enjeux de
véritables réformes sociales de fonds
relevant par principe du domaine de la
loi ordinaire par ailleurs en utilisant
cette procédure vous prenez le risque
que le Conseil constitutionnel censure
un minimum cela a été dit par notre
collègue assassin les cavaliers sociaux
qu'elle contient car ils n'ont aucun
effet suffisamment direct sur les
recettes ou les dépenses de la sécurité
sociale exemple typique l'index seniors
vous faites cela pour deux raisons
simples vous n'avez pas de majorité
maîtrisé au Parlement pour faire cette
réforme premièrement deuxièmement la
seule majorité que vous avez messieurs
les ministres elle est contre vous
contre cette réforme c'est celle des
Français
l'inconstitutionnalité est donc
manifeste pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain votera la motion présentée
par Madame Assesse
que le président compte
oui merci merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais d'abord rappeler à Monsieur les
messieurs les ministres ici on est au
Sénat et qu'on n'est pas là pour faire
le match retour ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale on est au Sénat on
va repartir sur des bases saines et je
pense que il faut arrêter
et si vous souhaitez que que le débat se
passe bien je pense qu'il faut arrêter
avec ces provocations voilà je pense que
ça c'est des choses qu'il fallait
peut-être peut-être appeler sur la
proposition du groupe CRCE je pense que
le groupe a tout à fait raison de
dénoncer ce corsetage et d'ailleurs je
constate que c'est quelque chose qui a
été signalé par un certain nombre d'élus
de la majorité
sénatorial qui dénonçait effectivement
ce corps se tâche ce choix du
gouvernement de limiter de limiter le
débat et je rappelle également
qu'Elisabeth borne nous avait promis un
temps un texte dédié elle nous avait dit
que on aurait un test dédié qui
évidemment
ne le passerai pas par ce projet de loi
de finances de sécurité sociale
rectificatif bah on voit on voit le
résultat mais alors pourquoi pourquoi
cette urgence pourquoi ce passage en
force pourquoi ce festival des mensonges
pourquoi cette contrainte du débarque
parlementaire en fait tout simplement
pourquoi refuser le débat pourquoi parce
que vous ne voulez tout simplement pas
qu'on parle du fond vous ne voulez pas
parler de votre projet dans le fond les
raisons réelles de ce projet destruction
des services publics destruction de vos
de nos acquis sociaux toujours moins
pour nos communs toujours moins et
toujours plus plutôt pour le pour le
privé c'est ça votre projet c'est le
projet de la de la finance c'est les
projets d'une d'une retraite uniquement
gérée par le privé et puis pour les
autres pour le reste pour les petites
gens et ben il y aura les miettes voilà
votre votre projet mais évidemment vous
ne voulez pas qu'on en parle et bien on
aura et nous on souhaite avoir ce temps
du débat le temps qu'il faudra et il y a
une responsabilité ici qui sera la resp
onsabilité du gouvernement qui a décidé
de limiter ce débat
absolument brûlin pour le groupe
communiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues oui
l'utilisation du 47-1 pour débattre de
ce projet de loi et contraire à la
Constitution et ceux qui semblent
vouloir le dénier font en quelque sorte
l'aveu qu'ils sont les côtes et les
coproducteurs de cette manipulation la
contrainte du temps d'examen des projets
de loi de finances et de financement de
la sécurité sociale ça a été rappelé ne
se justifie que par l'urgence de
respecter des délais et en particulier
celui du 31 décembre afin de ne pas
mettre notre pays en banqueroute ce que
chacun peut comprendre mais tout a
commencé par le rapport du corps montre
qu'il n'y a aucune urgence alleziférer
sur les retraites l'urgence c'est votre
obsession à empêcher que le débat et la
colère qui se développe dans notre pays
vous submerge vous êtes ainsi prêt à
accepter que ce projet de loi si
important pour l'ensemble
de notre peuple soit promulgué sans
avoir été soumis au vote de l'Assemblée
nationale et monsieur le ministre
vous avez de vous-même tout fait pour
que l'Assemblée nationale ne puisse pas
aller au bout de l'examen du texte la
presse la presse durant ces 10 derniers
jours s'en est fait à de nombreuses
reprises l'écho monsieur le ministre
êtes-vous prêt à soumettre à notre
assemblée séance tenantes l'analyse du
Conseil d'État nous obligerait vous à
nous déplacer dans les prochaines heures
à votre ministère pour obtenir des
documents qui selon les échos mettent en
cause la constitutionnalité de votre
texte en matière de cavalier socio en
particulier cela a été rappelé par
Eliane assassy difficile en effet de
commencer nos travaux sans avoir
communication de ces documents monsieur
le ministre nous le redisons on ne joue
pas avec la démocratie on détourne pas
la procédure constitutionnelle on ne
s'appuie pas sur des contre-vérités
voire sur des mensonges comme vous
l'avez fait sur les 1200 euros
en déclarant dans un premier temps que
tout le monde tous les retraités
seraient concernés pour déclarer
piteusement il y a 48 heures que seuls
10 à 20 000 personnes le seraient
finalement je crois que le Sénat
sonorerait d'adopter notre émotion car
il en va de la démocratie je vous
remercie
pas d'autres demandes
je vais maintenant consulter le Sénat
sur la motion pendant aux élection dire
recevabilité au cas où cette motion soit
adoptée il y aurait
Roger du texte en discussion en
application de l'article 59 le scrutin
public ordinaire et de droit il doit
être ouvert il est ouvert
plus personnellement à voter
le scrutin est clos
d'exprimer 344 pour 93 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons passer à la motion tendance
à opposer la question préalable
madame ponce monsieur
élément du groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires ont déposé une
motion je donne la parole à notre
collègue Daniel broyer pour la motion
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs le rapporteur chers collègues
ils vont nous prendre deux nos deux plus
belles années de retraite me disait une
ATSEM de la ville d'Arcueil la semaine
dernière
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire demande par cette question
préalable de rejeter ce texte de loi et
de renvoyer le gouvernement à la
nécessité de reprendre le dialogue avec
les organisations syndicales ne vous en
déplaisent chers collègues ce serait un
message fort adressé à nos concitoyens
massivement opposés à cette réforme un
témoignage de notre écoute de leurs
aspirations et de leurs colères en
repoussant de deux ans l'âge d'ouverture
des droits à la retraite l'objet de ce
texte né en effet ni plus ni moins que
de faire peser l'équilibre du système de
retraite sur le dos des travailleurs
plutôt que sur le capital cette réforme
annonçait initialement comme une réforme
de justice mal mènera en fait nos
concitoyens et d'abord et principalement
les femmes
et bien sûr celles et ceux aussi qui
souffrent au travail celles et ceux dont
le corps et l'outil celles et ceux dont
les gestes répétitifs abîment les
épaules les dos mais aussi celles et
ceux qui vivent dans la tension
permanente du résultat sans plus
reconnaître toujours le sens de leur
travail les Françaises et les Français
nous parlent de leur vie et le
gouvernement répond
compatibilité comptabilité au fond cette
réforme comptable et financière était
déjà annoncée dans cette hémicycle par
Bruno Le Maire à l'occasion de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques non
pour équilibrer le régime des retraites
le système actuel n'est pas en danger
les dépenses ne dérapent pas et des
recettes sont possibles à condition de
l'examiner mais bien pour faire baisser
les dépenses publiques et respecter les
objectifs du pack de stabilité et de
croissance ce qui dérape c'est la dette
publique et elle dérape parce que vous
multipliez les baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises du CAC 40 dont les
bénéfices battent pourtant tous les
records avec
59,8 milliards de dividendes versées la
France détient le record d'Europe la
seule suppression de la CVE représente
quasiment la totalité des économies
visées par cette réforme économique que
vous faites vous payer cash par les
salariés en prenant deux ans de leur vie
cette vision comptable dans un petit
texte rectificatif fait l'impasse sur la
question essentielle celle du partage de
la richesse produite et de
l'accumulation de la richesse pour
quelques-uns
elle fait aussi l'impasse sur l'immense
apport non monétaireisé des jeunes
retraités à la société dans les
associations la garde des petits-enfants
des conseils municipaux l'aide aux
parents en fin de vie et d'entendre
autre chose par cette question préalable
nous nous opposons un projet de loi qui
contrairement aux annonces de l'exécutif
ne permettra ni d'équilibrer
financièrement le système ni de garantir
une retraite minimum à 1200 euros
cela avait suscité de l'espoir 1200
euros pour tous on ne peut pas vivre
dignement avec moi voilà un débat pour
une République Solidaire nous ne
refusons pas le débat nous revendiquons
un débat parlementaire sur une réforme
du travail et des retraites ouvrons un
débat sur le travail sur les questions
de sens sur l'équilibre entre travail et
vie personnelle comme le font plusieurs
pays d'Europe en expérimentant à grande
échelle la semaine de quatre jours
ouvrons ce débat sur la possibilité pour
les salariés d'être associés au choix
stratégiques des entreprises sur la
façon de conserver l'expertise des
seniors dans l'entreprise plutôt que de
les mettre au chômage et ouvrons même le
débat sur cette volonté folle de vouloir
toujours produire plus et consommer plus
lorsque la planète nous dit que ce
productivisme nous conduit dans des
impasses dangereuses et lorsque le
dérèglement climatique bouleverse même
des conditions d'exercice du travail
ouvrons ces débats avec les partenaires
sociaux et même plus largement avec nos
concitoyens ils ont des idées et même
des propositions nous appelons ces
débats de nos vœux un simple texte
rectificatif du budget de la sécurité
sociale ne permet pas ces débats
monsieur les ministres votre réforme
malmène la démocratie d'abord la
démocratie sociale aucune réforme
monsieur le ministre aucune ne s'est
jamais faite contre l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales ce simple fait
disqualifie le texte la démocratie
contre l'immense majorité des Français
la démocratie contre les partenaires
sociaux ce n'est déjà plus la démocratie
et c'est un choix très dangereux lorsque
le rassemblement national est aux portes
du pouvoir
monsieur le ministre vous malmenez aussi
la démocratie parlementaire tout d'abord
par le choix d'un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale un projet rectificatif est fait
pour rectifier qu'allez-vous rectifier
avec l'index senior d'un point de vue
financier rien qu'allez-vous rectifier
avec la suppression des régimes spéciaux
en 2023 rien non plus puisque la clause
du grand-père maintient heureusement les
régimes spéciaux salariés qui en
bénéficient déjà au-delà du fond de
cette réforme le véhicule législatif que
vous utilisez est problématique depuis
la création des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale c'est la première
fois qu'une telle loi sert de support
législatives pour une réforme des
retraites les lois de 2003 de 2010 et de
2014 était toutes des lois ordinaires et
non des lois rectificatives de
financement de la sécurité sociale rien
ne justifie ce modus opérandit et le
recours à ses contournements
parlementaires en venir les débats dans
des hémicycles il est urgent de sortir
de ce climat détestable qui affaiblit la
démocratie représentative l'usage de
l’artic 47.1 a grave cette situation
encore ce temps le temps des débats
depuis la constitution de ce
gouvernement aucune loi financière n'a
échappé à l'application du 49-3 le
Parlement est déjà affaibli dans son
pouvoir d'initiative et dans son pouvoir
d'amendement contraint par des
irrecevabilités financières et
matérielles je voudrais rappeler les
mots simples de l'article 24 de la
Constitution le Parlement vote la loi
nous appelons la présidence à conserver
sa vigilance dans la défense de la
plénitude et de la qualité du travail
parlementaire nous nous inquiétons
d'ailleurs aussi du danger de transférer
par ces procédures accélérées
l'arbitrage de nos débats parlementaires
au Conseil constitutionnel qui fait
aujourd'hui quasiment office de
troisième chambre
bien sûr malgré ses véhicules
législatives contestables vous trouverez
une majorité dans notre chambre haute
l'appui de la droite vous semble promis
puisque vous faites une réforme de
droite c'est d'ailleurs quasiment celle
présentée ici même par notre collègue
Savary voilà trois mois et les années
précédentes et que vous aviez alors
qualifié de prématuré que la majorité
c'est notoriale depuis des années
utilise le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale et pas un projet
rectificatif d'ailleurs comme vous le
faites pour avancer ces propositions
d'allongement de la durée du travail et
compréhensible et même si nous le
combattons au fond ici les débats sont
foutrées mais les propositions sont
socialement très dures mais que le
gouvernement qui a la maîtrise de
l'ordre du jour du Parlement refuse la
présentation d'un texte de loi ordinaire
corps ce temps et limitant les
possibilités du débat n'est pas
acceptable pour quiconque défend un
véritable parlementarisme
le Conseil d'État et le président du
Conseil constitutionnel ont alerté le
gouvernement les articles non financiers
relatifs à l'index des seniors ou à la
modification des critères de pénibilité
devraient être supprimés pour raison
d'inconstitutionnalités vous n'avez
d'ailleurs vous avez d'ailleurs choisi
de ne pas rendre public cet avis du
Conseil d'État en aggravant les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité de plusieurs
articles ce texte se verrait amputé des
rares mesures d'atténuation de la
brutalité de la réforme renforçant
encore son déséquilibre en défaveur du
monde du travail et portant atteinte à
la sincérité des débats notre
interpellation s'adresse donc également
à la majorité sénatoriale pour rappeler
le nécessaire respect du pluralisme
garant de la qualité de nos travaux et
des débats de notre assemblée nous
devrions partager ici l'exigence d'un
véritable texte dédié aux évolutions du
travail et à la gestion des retraites et
non le passage en force par l'usage d'un
simple texte rect négatif messieurs les
ministres pour éviter le blocage du pays
il existe un moyen simple c'est de
bloquer cette réforme injuste
injustifiée et mal présenté chers
collègues en votant cette question
préalable nous redonnerons du temps au
débat avec les partenaires sociaux
l'histoire du travail toute l'histoire
du travail c'est une histoire de
conquête successives de gain de
productivité mais essentiellement au
service de l'amélioration des conditions
de vie et de la diminution du temps de
travail à la libération du temps pour
les humains cette loi fait l'inverse
entendons ce que disent des millions de
manifestants et l'immense majorité du
pays répondons à l'inquiétude des gens
qui refusent cette réforme et redoutent
cette idée de se faire voler oui chers
collègues les deux plus belles années de
leur vie à la retraite
mon pays c'est la vie combien de temps
encore à vivre des années des jours des
heures combien quand j'y pense mon cœur
bat si fort chanter Reggiani combien
sont-elles combien sont-ils aujourd'hui
à se poser avec votre réforme cette
question de combien de temps comme il le
dit dans cette chanson il le restera
pour rien pour courir pour pleurer
parler danser boire et voir et croire
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner maintenant la parole
contre la motion à madame la présidente
Catherine de roche merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues l'objet d'une question
préalable est décidé qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de débattre c'est au contraire le
rôle du Parlement et des parlementaires
en particulier du Sénat des sénatrices
et des sénateurs que de débattre et de
se prononcer pour un projet de réforme
important pour notre pays nos
concitoyens madame la Présidente assassy
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le mode
élection des députés et l'importance en
effet qu'il débattent et qu'il se
prononce nous les sénateurs nous avons
la même valeur alors et c'est la force
du
bicabérichme important dans les grandes
démocraties et nous envit beaucoup de
citoyens même s'ils n'ont pas le droit
de le dire de pays totalitaires au parti
unique c'est la mission la démocratie
représentative que d'assurer la
pluralité des bas selon des règles
claires respectueuses du rôle et des
positions de chacun
ce serait nous dérober que de refuser
d'assumer cette mission les auteurs de
la motion considèrent je le cite il
paraît inutile de procéder à tout
délibérations de fonds je pense au
contraire que ces délibérations utiles
et qu'elle est nécessaire je note
demeurant que plus de 4700 amendements
ont été déposés par les différents
groupes ce qui me paraît à tester d'une
préférence partagée pour la tenue d'une
libération j'invite donc le Sénat
examiner ce texte en se prenant sans
contre la motion pendant à opposer la
question préalable
merci
quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez monsieur le sénateur brolier et
vous m'avez interpellé
nous sommes confrontés nous aussi à
parler avec celles et ceux qui sont
concernés et dites-le à votre
aide-soignante si elle prend deux ans
supplémentaires ou votre ATSEM si elle
prend deux ans supplémentaires c'est
déjà par l'application de la réforme
Touraine qui a allongé la durée et fait
que elle sera contrainte de travailler
43 ans mais rassurer là qu'avec le
dégage de l'âge elle aura pas deux ans
de plus elle peut avoir quelques mois
mais ça lui garantira une meilleure
recette deuxièmement vous proposez de
taxer de façon supplémentaire vous savez
il faut être face à la réalité le
système par répartition c'est après le
principe de cotisation c'est pas un
principe de paiement par l'impôt c'est
la différence qui a entre le système
biarmark
et le bvidien et en conséquence quand
vous avez
une longévité qui accroît une natalité
qui baisse y arrive à un moment vous
pouvez taxer tout ce que vous voulez
c'est essayer de combler un puissant
fond c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut prendre des mesures paramétriques
et troisièmement vous avez dit que le
débat était tronqué contre compte tenu
d'un nombre d'heures limitées plus de
100 heures mes chers collègues trois
fois un PLFSS a été rappelé par
Catherine Desroches alors c'est pas
assez pour discuter de 4800 amendements
et si vous voulez qu'on discute
effectivement jusqu'au bout n'hésitez
pas retirer ceux qui sont redondants
merci donc avis défavorable de la
commission
[Applaudissements]
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président la vie du
gouvernement est évidemment défavorable
nous considérons qu'il y a à la fois une
urgence nécessité et un besoin de
d'examiner cette réforme des retraites
et ainsi de garantir préserver le
système par répartition vous avez évoqué
monsieur sénateur l'accès à un certain
d'informations et mon devoir de vous
préciser que en matière de l'autre
financement de la sécurité sociale comme
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale il n'y a pas d'avis du
Conseil d'État il y a une note de
synthèse remis par celui-ci au satariat
général du gouvernement et un certain
nombre de parlementaires de par les
fonctions qu'ils occupent on la
possibilité si le désir de solliciter la
consultation ce document cela a été fait
à l'occasion du débat l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de sujets qui relève des
questions de revolvabilité et les
éléments apportés par madame le
rapporteur général en réponse à la
présentation serait redondant si je les
répétais mais ce sont les mêmes pour
justifier d'un avis tout aussi
défavorable enfin je partage les
éléments exposés par madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pour justifier d'un avis
défavorable à la motion rejet préalable
que vous évoquez vous avez conclu
monsieur le sénateur en citant Reggiani
il chantait aussi il suffirait de
presque rien effectivement il suffirait
de presque rien pour que nous puissions
rentrer dans le débat simplement le
rejet de la motion
merci l'explication de vote madame Lubin
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai qu'habituellement au groupe
socialiste et apparenté nous aimons
débattre ce que nous allons faire
d'ailleurs donc nous appelons au débat
mais il s'avère que cette fois-ci le
débat est tronqué le débat est tronqué
parce que nous allons aborder une des
périodes quand même les plus importantes
de la vie d'un salarié celle à laquelle
pendant laquelle il aspire à se reposer
un petit peu celle de la retraite or là
nous n'allons pas parler retraites nous
allons parler chiffres d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre du Travail vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez dit
nous aurions dû parler du travail de la
vie mais nous n'allons surtout pas en
parler donc dans ces conditions non nous
n'avons pas envie de parler retraite
vous faites porter les efforts
uniquement sur les salariés et vous ne
remettez absolument pas en cause votre
politique fiscale vous protéger toujours
les mêmes et vous soumettez toujours les
mêmes vous refusez d'examiner des
solutions de financement parce que mon
cher collègue René Paul Savary il faudra
se poser la question un jour on pourra
pas toujours faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps et moi je vous le demande
et je vais vous le demander souvent
pendant ce départ jusqu'à quand jusqu'à
quel âge pensez-vous notamment que les
salariés de première ligne pourront
travailler vous contraignez toujours
ceux qui travaillent depuis longtemps
vous exercez qui exercent les métiers
les plus difficiles et les moins bien
rémunérés en clair vous ne nous donnez
pas le choix parce que débattre c'est
choisir
or là projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale rectificative c'est
rajouter des années au travail
c'est ne pas changer le mode de
financement étape est toujours sur les
mêmes et c'est faire travailler toujours
les mêmes nous n'avons pas de choix donc
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
débattre correctement et nous voterons
cette question préalable
monsieur gay pour le groupe communiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
les ministres nous sommes d'accord avec
vous nous aussi nous voulons un débat
mais pour faire un débat il faut être
deux nous avons donc des questions et
nous espérons obtenir quelques réponses
par exemple qui gagnera les 1200 euros
tout le monde comme vous l'avez fait
croire au début ou seulement 20 000
personnes comme la démontré le député
Guedj à l'Assemblée nationale en quoi un
index pour l'emploi des seniors
sera-t-il plus utile quand on voit le
résultat aujourd'hui de l'index sur
l'égalité salariale femme homme comment
vous croire quand vous dites la main sur
le cœur vouloir défendre la retraite par
répartition alors que le même casting
ministériel nous disait en 2019 qu'il
fallait absolument la capitalisation et
la retraite par point qui croire encore
quand vous parlez de justice sociale et
que vous vous apprêtez à voler les deux
plus belles années de vie aux
travailleurs et travailleurs utiles et
essentiels
usé par une ville labeur et si nous
avons des questions monsieur les
ministres nous aurons aussi des
propositions vous cherchez des milliards
nous aurons des propositions la
véritable l'égalité salariale fameum
c'est de suite 6 milliards de
cotisations un million de travailleurs
et travailleur supplémentaires en emploi
c'est 10 milliards de cotisations ou
reprenons la main sur une seule partie
des 162 milliards d'aide direct et
indirectes que vous donnez chaque année
au capital sans contrepartie d'emplois
de salaire ou de formation alors
messieurs les ministres vous voulez un
débat nous sommes prêts utiles combatif
et déterminé pour faire échec à votre
compte projet de réforme 64 ans on est
ni juste socialement ni efficace
financièrement et nous sommes prêts
déterminés bienvenue au Sénat et bon
débat
merci
d'autres pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je l'envoie pas
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la mesure
tendance à poser la question préalable
en application de l'artiste 59 du
règlement le scripta public ordinaire et
de droit
le scrutin va être ouvert dans quelques
instants il est
le temps est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin avec l'eau
tu as du scrutin 345
exprimer 344 pour 93 contre 251 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté
j'informe le Sénat en application de
l'article 11 de la Constitution et de
l'article 67 de notre règlement j'ai
reçu de Monsieur Patrick kaner président
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains de Madame Éliane Sassi
président du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste de
monsieur Guillaume Gontard président du
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
une motion qui tend à proposer au
président de la République de soumettre
au référendum le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
le projet de loi de financement rectif
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 en
application de l'article 67 alinéa de
notre règlement cette notion doit être
signée par au moins 30 sénateurs dont la
présence est constatée par appel nominal
il va donc être procédé immédiatement à
l'appel nominal des signataires je
demande aux huissiers de procéder à
l'appel nominal
Monsieur Patrick Kanner
madame Eliane assassin
monsieur Guillaume Gontard
madame Monique Lubin
madame Cathy
Madame Raymonde pensée
David a souligne
Monsieur Joël Bigot
Monsieur
Eric Bocquet Monsieur Daniel Breuillet
madame Isabelle briquet
madame Céline Brulin monsieur Yann
chanterelle madame Laurence Cohen
Monsieur Jérôme Durin monsieur Rémi
Féraud
Madame Corinne Ferret monsieur Jean-Luc
Fichet
madame Michel gréaum madame Marie-Pierre
de la Gontrie monsieur Gérard Laennec
Monsieur Pierre Laurent
madame Annie le héros
madame Marie-Noëlle Lindeman monsieur
Victorin Lurel madame Monique DeMarco
Monsieur Pierre Ouzoulias
monsieur Paul Toussaint Paris dit
madame Emilienne Poumirol
monsieur Claude Raynal
monsieur Jean-Claude Tissot
monsieur Michael Valley monsieur André
Vallini
madame Sabine
et donc donner monsieur
[Applaudissements]
cette potion sera envoyé à la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
Présidente la discussion de cette potion
aura lieu conformément à l'article 67 du
règlement dès la première séance
publique suivant sur des possibles 67
alinéa 2
d'accord avec la Commission et le
gouvernement nous fixons l'examen au
vendredi 3 mars à 9h30
pas d'observation il en est ainsi décidé
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
nous allons poursuivre notre discussion
générale et je vais donner la parole à
Madame
Raymonde poncemonge pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
la discussion générale est organisée je
le rappelle sur une heure
et les inscriptions de parole doivent
être faites avant 20h
ce jeudi 2 mars
vous avez bien noté discussion générale
sur une heure et inscriptions de parole
avant 20h ce jeudi 2 mars
maintenant nous entamons la discussion
générale Madame Raymonde c'est bon
alors que le sens de l'histoire avait
conduit à la retraite à 60 ans les
contrôles réformes se succèdent réforme
pesant essentiellement sur le monde du
travail parce que si la richesse
progresse sont partagées inégales et la
super concentration des richesses aussi
pourtant rien dans la situation
financière du système de retraite ne
justifie cette réforme brutale car le
léger déficit prévisionnel opportunément
dramatisée provient d'une insuffisance
de recettes et non des dépenses dont la
trajectoire est maîtrisée selon le corps
des recettes qui proviennent de moins en
moins des employeurs le gouvernement
amplifiant la politique d'exonération
des cotisations sociales largement
contestées pour ses effets sur l'emploi
qui coûte au budget de l'État
l'équivalent de 7 fois le déficit du
système des retraites exonération de
moins en moins compensées par l'État
c'est ainsi plus de 2 milliards non
compensés en manquement des obligations
de la loi Veil et sans compter la non
compensation des exonérations des primes
pour le partage de la valeur alors que
notre amendement pour la rétablir avait
été adopté par notre chambre et retoquer
en CMP parallèlement le gouvernement
poursuit sa course folle au baisse
d'impôts qui alarme jusqu'au gouverneur
de la Banque de France les recettes
manquent parce que le gouvernement étant
les dispositifs d'exemption d'assiettes
de cotisations sociales et refuse
toujours d'aligner les prélèvements sur
les revenus financiers à hauteur des
revenus du travail quant à la
multiplication d'éléments de
rémunération des socialisée pour les
travailleurs leur a-t-on dit que cela se
paye par le recul de leurs droits et de
l'âge de la retraite pour les employeurs
par contre c'est tout bénéfice le
déficit se creuse aussi par la politique
d'austérité dans la fonction publique où
la baisse des effectifs le gel du point
d'indice passait et programmé signifie
une réforme des retraites à bas bruit
car si aucun autre chose de la masse
salariale des fonctionnaires n'étaient
organisés le déficit serait diminué de 3
milliards à l'horizon 2030 non
nécessaire à la survie du système de
retraite ou d'autres solutions existent
cette réforme est indispensable par
contre au respect de la trajectoire des
dépenses publiques à 0,6 % en volume à
l'horizon 2027 que vous avez inscrite
dans le programme de stabilité envoyé à
Bruxelles alors que les retraites
progressent de 1,8%. car pour poursuivre
la baisse des impôts de production comme
la suppression de la CVAE qui prive les
comptes publics de l'équivalent du
déficit retraite les dépenses publiques
dont la retraite qui empêche d'un quart
joue ainsi les variables d'ajustement
voilà la vraie nécessité de votre
réforme une réforme qui ne demande
aucune contribution aux employeurs
pourtant premier responsable du faible
taux d'emploi des seniors mais sert la
poursuite des aides massives qui leur
sont versées et les baisses d'impôts de
cotisations dont ils bénéficient c'est
pour poursuivre cette politique qu'en
même temps que le passage à 62 ans en
2010 le fond de réserve des retraites
qui devait permettre de passer la bosse
démographique a été asséché et détourné
injuste c'est cette réforme aura un coup
social inédit comme la réforme
précédente elle va allonger le sas de
précarité de pauvreté des femmes des
ouvriers et employés massivement et
employés massivement exclus de l'emploi
après 60 ans comme des 30% de français
les plus pauvres qui attendront deux ans
de plus le passage à la retraite qui
pour eux marque une amélioration de leur
niveau de vie à 61 ans moins
d'enseignants sur deux est un emploi et
seulement 28% des ouvriers le chômage
s'est aggravé pour ces seniors suite à
la précédente réforme est près d'un
million ils sont depuis plus d'un an
avec très peu de chances d'en sortir
pour toutes ces personnes les catégories
plus populaire ni en emploi ni en
retraite comme pour plus du tiers des
femmes la réforme se traduira par une
plus longue période au minima sociaux en
longue maladie au chômage voire sans
aucune ressource alors que les femmes
partaient déjà 7 mois plus tard que les
hommes en courant derrière le taux plein
le recul de l'âge en substituant une
partie de la mobilisation des trimestres
enfants en trimestre travaillé allongera
davantage leur durée que les hommes
après avoir perdu un an et neuf mois
avec la réforme de 2010 les femmes de la
génération 80 devront travailler huit
mois de plus pour tous ceux aux portes
de la retraite sur lesquels le
gouvernement réalise les économies à
court terme nécessaire à son objectif de
respect du déficit à 3% en 2027 cette
réforme n'est que brutalité les
travailleurs verront une nouvelle
diminution de leur durée de vie à la
retraite car l'espérance de vie n'est
plus tirée essentiellement que par la
baisse de la mortalité des plus de 70
ans de sorte que les réformes
successives dans celle de 2010 on
consommait plus que les gains
d'espérance de vie oui l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé augmente mais l'écart
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé entre
un ouvrier et un cadre reste lui de 10
ans avec votre effort le risque d'une
durée de retraite de moins de 10 ans
concernera plus de 40% des hommes les
plus modestes les rares mesures
d'atténuation de la brutalité de cette
réforme du changeront rien tant pour
ceux coincés dans le sas de précarité
que pour ceux qui sont confrontés aux
inégalités de santé au travail et un
travail qui s'intensifie selon la d'Arès
depuis 1984 tous les indicateurs de
pénibilité tous les indicateurs de
contraintes sur les rythmes de travail
ont été plusieurs fois multipliés la
question première centrale reste celle
du travail du travail concret de
l'urgence de changer le travail et de
l'urgence d'en réduire la durée face à
l'intensification du travail autre phase
du travailler plus d'ailleurs qui porte
le productivisme au cœur même du travail
votre réforme par la langue de la
finance quand il faudrait parler du
travail de ces conditions de son sens et
de la vie en travail à la place vous
multipliez des mensonges de la
revalorisation du micro dont une infime
minorité des nouveaux comme des anciens
retraités touchera les fameux 100 euros
pour faire oublier que ces contre deux
ans de travail en plus quand même et que
les femmes qui ne répondent pas aux
conditions et en seront donc exclues
sont sur représentés c'est pourquoi vous
créez les super carrières longues pour
mieux masquer le recul de deux ans de la
quasi majorité des départs anticipés
désormais donc il y a 62 ans alors que
60 ans était la contrepartie de la
réforme de 2010 quand tout le monde
passait à 62 et que dire de
l'occultation des externalités négatives
alors que l'OFCE dans un horizon de 10
ans
montre que ce report de l'âge provoquera
un chômage et baisse les salaires en
définitive cette réforme est une loi
contre le monde du travail c'est une loi
de classe qui touchera le pouvoir de
vivre des actifs mais surtout des
catégories populaires les Français l'ont
bien compris et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle est si un peu plus l'air
et français ont bien compris que ceux
qui se jouait était leur pouvoir sur
leur temps et comme disait André Gorce à
travers le pouvoir sur le temps c'est le
pouvoir tout court qui est en jeu le
temps que cette réforme leur vole c'est
le temps libéré de la subordination et
de la nécessité un temps sans incapacité
que votre réforme veut livrer à une
croissance sans fin qui ignorent les
limites de la planète le dérèglement
climatique et l'effondrement du vivant
avec cette réforme le gouvernement
poursuit son obsession du travail plus
alors qu'il ne faut pas tant augmenter
le PIB que mieux le partager et de
subvertir par d'autres indicateurs de
prospérité comme l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé si comme disait Ambroise
Croizat la retraite ne doit plus être
l'antichambre de la mort mais une
nouvelle étape de la vie elle doit être
aussi une nouvelle étape dans notre
rapport au monde dans un siècle convoqué
par la question écologique cette loi du
passé est une loi d'une violence sociale
inouïe qui va les deux meilleures années
de retraite pour en faire les plus dures
au travail et c'est une loi qui barre la
bifurcation écologique une loi qui casse
le modèle social en prétendant
scéniquement le défendre pour toutes ces
raisons les écologistes s'opposent
radicalement à cette réforme et se
mobiliseront jusqu'au retrait
la parole au président François Patriat
pour le rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole monsieur le président
monsieur les ministres
mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
à grande cause grande controverse
depuis des mois les retraites occupent
l'actualité sociale politique de notre
pays
le mot retraite est partout ils veulent
de tweet en tweet de manifestations en
émission de motion en émotion
la retraite est à la charnière de la vie
privée dont elle ouvre une partie du
projet personnel de chacun et de la vie
publique ont-elles exprime le temps
solidaire la retraite mobilise la
question du vivre ensemble et de
l'acceptation des contraintes
collectives en même temps qu'elle
interroge sur le sens du travail si
toute l'ambition des acides du travail à
l'ouverture desquels monsieur le
ministre vous avez insisté sur deux
motivations essentielles et
complémentaires pour pouvoir mieux vivre
de son travail et pouvoir mieux vivre au
travail en somme redonner tout son sens
à la valeur travail car malheureusement
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens la
conciliation entre le travail et
l'épanouissement personnel n'est pas
toujours au rendez-vous et nous le
savons la retraite est souvent vécue
comme une délivrance leur donnant enfin
un droit à la liberté au bien-être et à
la réalisation de soi alors comment
effectivement nous ira-t-on accepter de
repousser ce privilège là
comment sortir de la dimension totémique
dans laquelle baigne désormais ce débat
une démocratie comme un autre est
capable d'en débattre sereinement même
d'un sujet si clivant et si passionnant
si fondamentalement français nous le
devons se débat aux Français car l'enjeu
est considérable sauvegarder notre
système de retraite pour dégénération
future et faire durer faire perdurer le
pacte le solidarité ou en sommes-nous
9 jours de débat à l'Assemblée nationale
sont parvenir à l'article 3 des
stratégies d'obstruction et de blocage
20 000 amendements déposés désinfectifs
des violences verbales des menaces et
tout cela en fin de compte tout à
l'heure vous allez regretter que le
texte n'est pas été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale il a pas été voté parce que
les parlementaires n'ont pas voulu le
voter et Monsieur Mélenchon lui-même à
travers un tweet a bien demandé au Sénat
aux députés de ne pas voter ce texte
donc ils auraient pu le voter ils n'ont
pas le voulu le voter aujourd'hui ne
veulent pas vous dire qu'ils n'ont pas
vu le voter ici ici revenons au Sénat
revenons au Sénat les
4227 amendement déposé sont-ils les
premiers d'une obstruction au Sénat moi
je me le demande avec 69 avant mes chers
collègues
identiques des trois groupes de la
gauche visant à supprimer l'article
militaire je m'inquiète un peu le
comique de répétition est ses limites
rassurez-vous nous sommes rassurez-vous
69 similaires 69 amendements similaire
le psitasisme ça existe rassurez-moi
rassurez-vous nous sommes tous ici pour
débattre pour réaliser ce qui n'a pas
réussi l'assemblée et se prononcer sur
ce texte après le spectacle désolant du
dernier semaines il appartient au Sénat
d'ouvrir le débat et de le faire avec
exemplarité ce sera difficile parce que
c'est exigeant politiquement tranché
mais respectueux je sais les oppositions
résolues mais j'espère pouvoir compter
sur l'esprit de responsabilité chacun
pour débattre avec sérénité le Sénat
doit montrer que le Parlement est un
espace de dialogue débattre pour
éclairer une délibération et pour voter
notre conviction est que sans cette
réforme et sans consentir à de nouveaux
efforts il n'y aura pas d'avenir
pleinement assuré pour notre système de
retraite ceux qui préfère flatter
l'opinion en ayant la nécessité de cette
réforme condamne notre système par
répartition quels alternatives leurs
collègues une baisse des pensions
impensable une hausse de cotisation
intenable notre choix nous l'avons fait
c'est la valeur travail le texte qui
nous est présenté aujourd'hui permet un
retour à l'équilibre en 2030 pour y
parvenir un effort de deux années
supplémentaires et demander aux Français
répartis de manière justes en tenant
compte de la situation de locaux citoyen
ils plus vulnérable de ceux et ceux qui
ont commencé plus tôt de la pénibilité
des Carnières hachés des pistes
d'amélioration sont encore possibles
notre groupe porte plusieurs en
plusieurs noms au nom de la justice
sociale je pense au rachat du trimestre
pour les stages et les études je pense
aussi à leur valorisation des pensions
de retraite et de l'ASPA à Mayotte je
tiens à saluer ici le travail décisif de
l'océateur Maroilles notamment tram
Italie ici sur ce sujet je crois
profondément que ce texte peut impulser
nouvelle dynamique le point de départ
d'une réflexion plus large sur le
travail pour laquelle nous serons
pleinement investis mais aujourd'hui et
au sein d'un ESC ales ici échangeons
bien sûr des bâtons mais surtout en fin
du compte votons je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président donner la parole
de notre collègue Monique Lubin pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur
chers collègues il est difficile
d'ouvrir ce débat sans évoquer en
préambule un élément structurant de la
réforme que vous défendez la méthode que
vous avez choisi pour la construire et
l'imposer elle trahit certainement vos
convictions profondes ainsi que vos
objectifs et priorités nous n'en avons
que trop conscience et c'est pour cela
qu'elle nous heurte si profondément ou
de la même de la manière dont elle vous
a conduit à construire votre projet de
réforme des retraites et à en dénaturer
l'objet
vous n'aurez eu que faire du dialogue
social conviant les syndicats à des
réunions mais ignorant les
revendications qu'ils portent au nom des
travailleurs vous aurez piétiné le
Parlement choisissant pour cette réforme
le véhicule du projet de loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale rectification
il vous ouvre une porte de sortie bien
peu respectueuse du débat démocratique
que serait à énième 49-3 avec le choix
d'activer l'article et 47 1 de la
Constitution vous aurez achevé de faire
la démonstration au pays entier de votre
volonté de Nasser les parlementaires et
de les rendre inaudibles la très
mauvaise qualité de l'étude d'impact
accompagnant le présent texte signalé
par le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui s'est reconnu
incapable avec les maigres éléments que
vous lui fournissez d'évaluer votre
réforme en témoignent également la faute
serait pour nous de vous laisser faire
par ailleurs vous portez atteinte à la
parole publique avec des chiffres faux
et des éléments de langage sophistiqués
destiné à perdre votre auditoire cela
témoigne d'un manque préoccupant de
sincérité vous avez illustré cette
insincérité avec le psychodrame des 1200
euros de pension minimale il a fallu
qu'un économiste Michael Zemmour perce
le barrage de vos éléments de langage
pour dévoiler sur une radio publique à
une heure de grandes d'écoute le biais
que vous utilisez pour affirmer que
votre réforme porterait la pension
minimale à 1200 euros même se
dévoilement tonitruant ne vous a pas
convaincu de cesser les infox il a fallu
qu'un député socialiste fasse valoir ses
prérogatives de vice-président de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle de
la sécurité sociale à l'Assemblée au
siège de la sécurité sociale pour
obtenir les authentiques évaluations
chiffrées des effets de la réforme des
retraites
nous savons donc maintenant que ce ne
sont pas 40 000 personnes chaque année
qui passeront le cap des 85 % du SMIC et
que seul 20 000 retraités au mieux
franchiront le seuil des 1200 euros
pourtant annoncer
je me permets maintenant de vous
suggérer de prendre le temps d'un peu de
pédagogie auprès du président de la
République puisqu'il a très
explicitement démontré qu'il ne saisit
pas le fonctionnement du minimum
contributif si le président de la
République veut cette réforme des
retraites mais qu'il ne la comprend pas
il se trouve que nous avec les Français
nous la comprenons mais nous n'en
voulons pas en voici quelques raisons
l'exhaustivité est anticipe impossible
avant toute chose l'état des lieux de
notre système de retraite sur lequel il
a pu sa réforme n'est pas ce qu'en dit
le gouvernement le rapport du corps de
2022 déjà abondamment cité montre que
notre système des retraites est
stabilisé les résultats de ce rapport ne
valident pas le bien fondé des discours
qui mettent en avant l'idée d'une
dynamique non contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite l'arrivée des babyboomers en
retraite est déjà pour l'essentiel
assorti amortie et si nous devons encore
tenir jusqu'en 2035 nous avons déjà fait
le plus dur notamment grâce aux de
productivité ce qui nous préoccupe avant
tout aujourd'hui c'est que les études
prévoient une baisse du niveau de vie
relative des retraités dans les
décennies à venir et si la trajectoire
des dépenses ne dérape ne dérape pas
nous avons ici un problème de recettes
qui pourrait se traduire par un déficit
entre 10 et 13 milliards d'euros d'ici à
2030 tout état de cause le système des
retraites versant plus de 300 milliards
de pensions par an ce déficit ne met pas
en péril immédiat ce pendent notre
protection sociale il n'en reste pas
moins que nous devons travailler à
consolider le système de retraite par
répartition auxquelles nous tenons
absolument le projet de loi repoussant
l'âge de la retraite de deux ans pour
tout le monde serait injuste pour de
nombreuses catégories de salariés cette
mesure pèserait moins sur la carrière
des cadres ils ont rarement commencé à
travailler avant 22 ans les 43 ans de
cotisations exigées à partir de la
génération 73 les amènent d'ores et déjà
à 65 ans quant à ceux qui auront
commencé à travailler entre 2018 et 20
ans l'âge où l'on peut bénéficier des
carrières longues étant également
repoussé de 60 à 62 ans ils ne pourront
valider leur retraite à 62 ans qu'à
condition d'afficher une carrière
complète or c'est dans ces catégories
que l'on trouve les employés les
ouvriers les aidants dont l'espérance de
vie et de 7 ans inférieur à celle des
cadres et c'est aussi dans cette
catégorie que se trouve ceux de la
première ligne à qui le gouvernement
prétendait offrir reconnaissance et
juste rétribution au pic de la crise
sanitaire la justice est encore plus
flagrante sachant que les carrières
longues perdent une part importante de
leur surcote dans le passage d'un
système à l'autre les carrières courtes
des CSP plus qui sont souvent bien plus
rémunératrices et moins usante ne
connaissent que de faible décote pour un
départ à la retraite à 64 ans
pour les seniors qui ne sont ni en
employés en retraite le recul de l'âge
de départ équivautera par ailleurs au
rallongement de leur période de
précarité cela touche actuellement
environ un tiers des personnes
retraitées nées en 1950 37% des femmes
et 28% des hommes qui n'étaient plus un
emploi l'année précédant leur retraite
et ce n'est pas un index qui pourrait
changer cela en l'absence non démenti de
politique volontariste en matière
d'emploi des seniors concernant les
femmes nous savons tous que cette
réforme fait perdre le bénéfice des
trimestres maternités pour la plupart
des mères en le montant des
pensions accentue les décote et limitent
les surcotes votre réforme affaiblit
considérablement un dispositif de
compensation des inégalités femmes
hommes s'agissant des femmes d'ailleurs
les dernières études démontrent que sur
les 18 milliards d'euros d'économies que
vous attendez de cette réforme 11
milliards seront payés par les femmes
si le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite prévu par cette réforme est
inacceptable les mesures qu'il
accompagne sont plus ne sont pas non
plus satisfaisantes l'enjeu des régimes
spéciaux d'abord il n'y a ni besoin ni
urgence à les supprimer de la sorte nous
retrouvons ici les vieilles lunes de la
droite que vous reprenez à votre compte
monsieur Duce certains régimes auxquels
vous voulez mettre fin sont d'ailleurs
des régimes autonomes qui ne demandent
rien à l'état et la suppression du
régime spécial de la RATP c'est un
contrat que nous allons rompre mais nous
y reviendrons plus tard la suppression
de ces régimes est une pure diversion
politique
la question de la pénibilité et de
l'espérance de vie au travail n'est pas
moins traitée de manière problématique
ici en 2017 et par ordonnance l'exécutif
a supprimé le compte personnel de
pénibilité au profit du compte personnel
de prévention
à cette occasion il a supprimé la notion
de pénibilité au travail il n'est donc
plus question d'une gestion par
l'employeur de cette pénibilité elle
n'est pas réintroduite ici le fond
d'investissement proposé par le présent
de texte mentionne par ailleurs certains
des critères de pénibilité supprimés en
2017 mais pas tous et notamment pas les
agents chimiques dangereux concernant
les carrières longues ainsi que l'enjeu
de la pénibilité au travail ou la
question des inaptitudes au travail le
gouvernement prétendonner de nouvelles
tâches aux médecins pour faire exister
ces dispositifs
nous nous interrogeons donc alors que la
France est en train de devenir un
gigantesque désert médical l'exécutif
aurait-il sous le coude des praticiens
mobilisables pour ces nouvelles tâches
après avoir mené de nombreuses auditions
sur le présent de texte et entendu
toutes les parties prenantes il nous
paraît évident que cette réforme n'est
pas une réforme des retraites c'est bien
plutôt une réforme qui concerne les
finances de l'État puisqu'elle doit
faire baisser les déficits dans le cadre
d'une politique du gouvernement qui aura
eu pour constante de baisser les impôts
de production de favoriser les plus
riches et de désocialiser les salaires
après le quoi qu'il en coûte payé par la
protection sociale nous voici face au
système des retraites sacrifiés sur
l'Hôtel du déficit de l'État
ce n'est pas un hasard si cette réforme
brutale fait peser les forces sur les
travailleurs et seulement sur eux c'est
aussi une réforme témoin qui doit servir
de gage à nos partenaires au sein de
l'Union européenne puisque le
gouvernement a jugé pertinent de
l'inclure dans son programme de
stabilité qu'il a transmis au Parlement
européen puis à la Commission
faute d'être capable de proposer un
véritable projet en matière du finance
publique dans un texte de projet de loi
d'orientation des finances 2023 2027
susceptible d'être amendée puis adopté
le gouvernement procède par coup de
force successifs il se ménage un chemin
budgétaire à coup de coupe dans notre
protection sociale
mais cette réforme est aussi une réforme
masquée du marché du travail nous y
reviendrons dans les débats
dans une réforme des retraites la
question des recettes ne devrait pas
être un tabou des solutions financières
non douloureuses sont identifiables nous
signalons par exemple l'intérêt de
revenir sur les exonérations de
cotisations employeurs inutiles et
coûteuses auxquelles a procédé ce
gouvernement le total de ces
exonérations est en effet de 80
milliards d'euros par an une réforme des
retraites est par ailleurs inconcevable
si elle n'est pas précédée par exemple
d'une politique volontariste en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors de luttes contre
les inégalités de salaires femmes hommes
ou indépendamment d'une conversion
nationale sur les salaires que nous
d'une convention nationale sur les
salaires que nous appelons de nos vœux
le gouvernement devrait avoir le courage
de renoncer à son bricolage
contre-productif pour travailler en
profondeur avec les partenaires sociaux
et les parlementaires sur ce que nous
voulons comme modèle de société comme
partage des richesses comme modèle
social et comme progresse au ciel
je vais donner merci cher collègue je
vais donner la parole à notre collègue
Cathy à Boursault Boli pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour 2023 est un
véhicule législatif inadapté à son objet
qui consiste à faire travailler deux
années supplémentaires l'ensemble des
Français le scénario de cette réforme
est celui d'un mauvais film il commence
mal et finira très mal pour le pays
quant aux acteurs que vous avez recrutés
il manque de crédibilité c'est votre cas
monsieur le Président Retailleau vous
qui déclariez le 23 juillet dernier que
les républicains auraient une attitude
sans complaisance avec le macronisme nid
dogmatisme c'est aussi votre cas chers
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale qui
travaillait main dans la main avec le
gouvernement pour faire adopter en
commission mixte paritaire un texte
qu'une majorité écrasante de nos
concitoyens refusent après avoir défendu
leur des élections présidentielles de
2017 et de 2022 l'allongement de l'âge
légal départ en retraite à 65 ans pour
toutes et tous vous vous alignez
aujourd'hui sur le pouvoir en défendant
l'abaissement de l'âge légal de la
retraite à 64 ans et soi-disant mesure
pour les carrières longues monsieur le
ministre les vrais acteurs les bons
acteurs sont dans la rue à l'appel de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
c'est avec eux qu'il faut réécrire le
scénario concernant le gouvernement les
cafouillages se sont multipliés ces
dernières semaines au point que même le
président de la République s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis au salon de
l'agriculture sur la pension minimale à
1200 euros le 10 janvier dernier lors de
la présentation de la réforme des
retraites la première ministre avait
annoncé je la cite les petites retraites
auront droit à un relèvement de pension
à 1200 euros le gouvernement utilisé
répéter cet argument dans tous les
médias tentant aussi de faire passer
pour un social ce projet qui est injuste
et inutile soyons clairs depuis le début
votre mauvais projet n'est fait que
d'approximation et de mensonges il ne
s'agit pas d'une revalorisation de 1200
euros mais de 1100 euros net toutes les
petites retraites ne seront pas
concernées puisque la revalorisation ne
concernera que les carrières complètes
en réalité même pour les carrières
complètes ce ne sera pas 1100 euros mais
une augmentation de 100 euros et encore
pas pour tout le monde enfin monsieur le
ministre du Travail vous avez été obligé
de reconnaître que cette revalorisation
ne concerne que une dizaine de milliers
de personnes par an après avoir fait
croire qu'elle en concernerait des
centaines de milliers voire tous et
toutes
au bout du compte il s'agit pour vous de
faire travailler les gens deux ans de
plus en étendant à tous la durée de
cotisation à 43 à nuités pour tous en
contrepartie vous n'avez rien d'autre à
nous proposer que 75 euros en plus par
mois pour 10000 personnes il faut que
vous retiriez ce projet
inutile
inefficace et d'une grande violence
sociale par contre il faut faire une
toute autre réforme des retraites c'est
ce que demande l'immense majorité des
Français selon les communistes Michael
Zemmour il suffirait d'augmenter de 28
euros la cotisation patronale pour que
les recettes de notre système de
retraite retrouve l'équilibre dans les
années à venir mais vous préférez taper
sur les travailleurs en les faisant
travailler davantage malgré la fatigue
et la pénibilité de leur métier pour
vous deux en supplémentaires ce n'est
rien mais une majorité de salariés n'est
plus en état de travailler à 60 ans
l'augmentation des cadences le mal-être
au l'épuisement physique avec beaucoup
de profession nécessite de réduire l'âge
de départ en retraite et pas de
l'augmenter votre réforme de fait va
priver les salariés de deux années de
vie en bonne santé en retraite à
profiter de leur petit enfant de leurs
amis d'un engagement dans le secteur
associatif culturel ou sportif les
nantines sont pas les bénéficiaires des
régimes spéciaux que vous voulez
supprimer les régimes spéciaux des
électriciens et des gaziers de la RATP
sont le fruit de conquête sociale pour
mieux prendre en compte la pénibilité
des métiers pour nous ce sont des
régimes pionniers qu'il faudrait étendre
à chaque profession et convention
collective pour permettre à l'ensemble
des travailleurs une meilleure prise en
considération de la réalité de leurs
conditions au travail ceux qui vont
payer le plus cher ce sont les gens
modestes ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt ceux qui ont des
carrières hachées souvent des femmes
[Musique]
financer notre système de retraite à la
hauteur des enjeux du 21e siècle nous
proposons de mettre la contribution les
revenus financiers du capital les
milliards de dividendes d'augmenter la
CSG sur le capital nous proposons de
supprimer les dispositifs d'exonération
de cotisation sociale patronales qui en
plus le budget de la Sécurité sociale de
75 milliards d'euros sans effet sur
l'emploi et qui bénéficie surtout au
plus grandes entreprises nous proposons
conditionner les aides publiques à
l'absence de délocalisation des emplois
à l'augmentation des salaires et
garantir l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes de l'argent il en
existe si on décide d'aller le chercher
de s'en servir pour mener une réforme
des retraites de progrès juste en
rétablissant l'âge légal de départ en
retraite à 60 ans après 47 ans et demi
d’années de garantir une pension
minimale au niveau du SMIC pour une
carrière complète et à 85% du SMIC pour
une carrière incomplète de calculer les
pensions sur les 10 meilleurs années
nous proposons également d'augmenter les
salaires pour que les salariés puissent
faire face à l'inflation et aussi
accroître les ressources du système de
retraite nous proposons de mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité en fixant des
listes de métiers et de postes ouvrant
droit au dispositif de votre départ
anticipé mais aussi en réformant
complètement le compte pénibilité
combien de salariés du bâtiment Magnan
décharge travaillant au marteau-piqueur
combien de travailleurs de
l'agroalimentaire travaillant de nuit
dans le froid d'ouvriers de fonderie
dans la chaleur et postée d'aide à
domicile et j'en passe se retrouvent
sans aucun point après des années de
travail sur leur camp pénibilité nous
proposons de mieux prendre en compte la
situation des familles
monoparentales nous proposons de réviser
le tableau des maladies professionnelles
et de restaurer les CHSCT dans les
entreprises je m'arrête là mais la liste
des propositions n'est pas exhaustive
nous mènerons avec mon groupe une
bataille parlementaire contre votre
texte et défendront chacun
de nos amendements pour faire des
contre-propositions à vos mauvais coups
l'examen du texte au Sénat pour vous ne
sera pas un long fleuve tranquille vous
devrez compter sur nous pour vous
rappeler que comme
66% des Français et des millions de
manifestants le 7 mars nous sommes
opposés à votre réforme vous devrez
compter sur l'ensemble
sénatrice et des sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain citoyens et
écologistes pour s'opposer avec force et
détermination à votre réforme
impopulaire refusé par 9 salariés sur 10
celle-ci est injuste et elle sera
inefficace en démocratie il faut écouter
la voix du peuple qui s'exprime avec
force je vous invite à écouter le peuple
qui sera dans la rue le 7 mars avec les
salariés le 8 mars avec les femmes et le
9 mars avec les jeunes
merci
de me donner la parole
au président
Hervé Marseille pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
la parole monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président messieurs les ministres
madame la Présidente de la Commission
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur
en ouvrant l'examen de ce texte je
voulais vous dire d'abord qu'ici vous
n'avez rien à craindre monsieur le
ministre du soft et qu'ensuite nous
avons une seule intention c'est de
débattre et de faire aboutir nos débats
car le débat paradoxal allemand n'a pas
encore eu lieu voilà plus d'un mois
qu'on ne parle que de cette réforme de
retraite plus d'un mois qu'elle est
commentée à de nauséames sur les réseaux
sociaux plus d'un mois
quel est contestée mais elle n'a pas
encore été vraiment débattue par ceux à
qui l'incombent pourtant
constitutionnellement de le faire à
savoir les représentants de la nation
je ne vais pas revenir sur le spectacle
donné par l'Assemblée nationale mais ne
soyons pas étonnés à la suite de ces
palinodiques que le niveau d'abstention
augmente et que nous observions une
progression inexorable des extrêmes elle
est malheureusement prévisible le Sénat
a aujourd'hui l'opportunité de réhausser
l'image du parlementarisme compter sur
nous pour la saisir et s'il fallait
trouver des raisons de défendre le BIC
amérisme certains députés viennent de
nous l'offrir sur un plateau le refus
d'obstacle d'élus pourtant investi par
le suffrage universel et organisant
scientifiquement l'effacement de leur
propre assemblée démontre par l'absurbe
la nécessité d'une deuxième chambre
apaisée
je me permettrai
[Applaudissements]
de commencer par rappeler une évidence
les mécanismes que nous devons assumer
aujourd'hui relèvent d'un choix
collectif quasi unanime et presque
enthousiaste fait à la Libération en
madame la Présidente assassinat rappelé
notamment par Ambroise Croizat pour
offrir une digne fin de vie à nos vieux
salariés de l'époque nous avons opté
pour un dispositif consistant à ce que
les cotisations des actifs financent en
temps réel les pensions des retraités
cela avait l'avantage d'être
opérationnel immédiatement nous aurions
pu choisir une autre formule d'autres
formes de solidarité cela n'a pas été
fait la conséquence de ce choix que nous
sommes devenus dépendants d'effondements
d'un système par répartition c'est à
dire dépendant de réalité démographique
en 1945 à cette égard c'était si vous me
le permettez un exercice qui n'était pas
trop compliqué avec une retraite à 65
ans et une espérance de vie de moins de
10 ans pour les retraités c'était un
rapport de quatre actifs pour retraités
autant dire que la solidarité
intergénérationnelle était plus facile à
assumer ce qui n'enlève rien à l'avancée
sociale que cela fut à l'époque au fil
du temps le contexte démographique a
totalement changé la natalité s'est
dégradée l'espérance de vie a
considérablement augmenté de plus l'âge
de départ en retraite a été abaissé si
bien que le ratio actif retraité a
changé de nature il était de 4 pour 1 il
est de 1,6 pour un aujourd'hui depuis 30
ans les réformes se succèdent pour
accommoder cette évolution démographique
1995 2003
2010-2014 et heureusement que ces
réformes ont été effectuées sinon ou en
serions-nous aujourd'hui probablement
pour solde de tout compte puisque le
ratio est annoncé à un pour 4 pour 1 en
2050 dans ces conditions défendre la
pérennité du régime par répartition
c'est accepté d'en faire évoluer ces
paramètres nous ne souhaitons pas nous
considérons qu'il est inenvisageable de
baisser les pensions des retraités bien
sûr nous ne souhaitons pas augmenter le
coût du travail qui est le plus grand
ennemi d'un objectif de par conséquent
il ne reste que deux leviers
mobilisables soit la natalité soit la
durée de cotisation
ce raisonnement par élimination explique
pourquoi nous soutiendrons le report de
deux anges de deux ans de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à la retraite et
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine
nous aussi nous avons des propositions
pour les recettes et elles sont assez
proches de celles que j'ai entendues
tout à l'heure nous ne faisons pas oui
oui
c'est Jean-Marie vanderenberg qui a
déposé l'amendement nous ne le faisons
pas de bonnes grâces mais c'est parce
que c'est la moins mauvaise des options
raison pour laquelle la majorité
sénatoriale l'adopte en PLFSS depuis des
années nous nous félicitons que le
gouvernement s'en soit inspiré il est
dommage qu'on est attendu monsieur le
ministre je vous reconnais une forme de
volontarisme en nous présentant un texte
de retour à l'équilibre fondé sur des
prévisions de chômage assez optimistes
nous nous interrogerons d'ailleurs sur
le réalisme de cette trajectoire
financière
que le taux de chômage à 4,5% est encore
loin d'être atteint pour autant au titre
de la solidarité avec les générations
montantes et pour éviter de leur laisser
une montagne de dette nous assumons la
dimension financière de la réforme pour
qu'elle conserve un sens une pertinence
elle doit assurer un sol de durablement
équilibré nous ferons ainsi preuve de
vigilance dans les mesures que nous
examinerons nous soutiendrons évidemment
les mesures proposées par nos
rapporteurs dont je salue
l'investissement et le travail au-delà
notre groupe proposa d'autres
amendements sur le plan des recettes le
report de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
va induire un sur plus de recettes de
CSG nous portons l'idée comme la
rappeler Sylvie vermeiller tout à
l'heure de l'attribuer au fond de
réserve pour les retraites nous
souhaitons également favoriser l'emploi
des seniors en complément du dispositif
index senior et du CDI fin de carrière
proposée par la Commission nous
présentons une exonération de charges
sur les salaires de tous les essayer de
plus de 57 ans en miroir en cas de
licenciement l'employeur devra
naturellement payer l'équivalent des
charges exonérées par ailleurs dans
notre volonté de lutter contre les
violences intrafamiliales nous
proposerons que les parents condamnés
pour violence ou maltraitance de leurs
enfants soient privés des bonifications
qui leur sont liées de la même manière
lorsque le parent est condamné pour
abandon de famille ou non versement
d'une pension au profit d'un enfant
mineur la même sanction tombée dans un
autre registre au titre de la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités nous proposerons d'indexer les
pensions sur l'inflation prévisionnelle
plutôt que sur l'inflation constater
l'année précédente dans un contexte de
forte inflation cette mesure évitera le
décrochage des pensions enfin nous
souhaitons améliorer les droits à la
retraite des élus des petites communes
souvent ils réduisent leur activité
personnelle pour exercer leur fonction
de ce fait beaucoup perdent des droits
et nous souhaitons leur permettre
d'arriver à à taux plein pour notre
groupe il semble indispensable de
rappeler que cette réforme n'est pas une
fin en soi la bouffée d'oxygène que nous
nous donnons jusqu'en 2030 doit nous
permettre d'ouvrir dans une certaine
sérénité un débat plus large sur
l'avenir du système de retraite la
réforme systémique d'inspiration
centriste par point doit être remis sur
le métier elle est en soi extrêmement
complexe dès lors qu'il faut assurer une
phase de transition si elle devait être
débattue à nouveau dans l'avenir elle ne
devrait surtout pas être associés à des
mesures paramétriques qui rendraient le
projet incompréhensible par ailleurs
envisager une part de retraite par
capitalisation pour le privé à l'image
de ce qui existe déjà dans la fonction
publique doit pouvoir être étudié sans
crispation de principes notre groupe est
prêt à participer à de tels travaux on y
associant l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires et pour terminer j'aurai
un regret et une proposition un regret
c'est qu'on n'est pas ouvert le débat
sur la dépendance projet longtemps
annoncé toujours
qui me semble prolongée le débat sur les
retraites enfin et on me rapprochant de
ce que disait tout à l'heure notre
collègue broyé il paraît indispensable
d'ouvrir une conférence sociale pour
l'avenir pour évaluer les suites de la
société post covid en effet nous avons
examiné le commencement examiner les
retraites nous avons vu l'indemnisation
du chômage nous annonce une loi travail
monsieur le ministre Attal vous avez
lancé
des expérimentations dans votre
ministère sur la journée de quatre jours
on parle du pouvoir d'achat je pense
qu'il serait opportun de travailler avec
les syndicats à une conférence sociale
pour réfléchir aujourd'hui au temps de
travail à la société poscovid voilà ce
que nous souhaitons grouper espérons que
nos débats soient utiles
monsieur le président
donner la parole à notre collègue Esther
Benbassa pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
paroles
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur et mesdames les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
cela a été déjà dit mais je le redis la
pédagogie c'est la répétition
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est en
France de 64 ans pour les femmes et de
62 ans pour les hommes en repoussant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans est-ce donc ce message que vous
envoyez vous partirez quand vous ne
serez plus en assez bonne santé pour
travailler
avec cette réforme vous dessinez un
projet de société déshumanisant vous
rêvez d'une société qui travaille
toujours plus pour produire toujours
plus vous êtes dans la rentabilité la
compétitivité au lieu d'être dans la
solidarité la coopération et enfin la
vie simplement et loin de sauver la
retraite par répartition vous la
fragilisez et vous ouvrez la voix à la
retraite par capitalisation après tout
dites-vous que ce sont deux années dans
une vie
mais deux années c'est 730 jours de trop
pour un homme ou une femme ayant entendu
sa retraite comme une délivrance après
des décennies de dure labeur bien sûr
quand on travaille par passion et par
conviction sans s'épuiser à la tâche on
ne compte pas son temps voilà sans doute
pourquoi nous sommes si nombreux dans
cette émission avoir dépassé les 64 ans
n'est-ce pas
ne peut-on admettre que quand on
travaille pas nécessité et dans l'effort
permanent on voit la retraite comme une
libération et le commencement d'une vie
nouvelle encore faut-il que cette
seconde vie on puisse l'amener dignement
le 10 janvier dernier madame la Première
ministre disait je cite une vie de
travail doit garantir une retraite digne
et ce gouvernement devait une réforme
revalorisant la pension des salariés au
SMIC jusqu'à 1200 euros brut s'ils ont
cotisé toute leur vie avez-vous
conscience qu'avec l'inflation actuelle
1200 euros ne permettront jamais à
quiconque de vivre mais au mieux de
survivre savez-vous seulement combien
pourront en bénéficier monsieur le
ministre du Travail donne chaque jour
des chiffres différents dès lors qu'il
faudra justifier d'une carrière complète
cotisée à temps plein au SMIC les femmes
comme toujours seront la première léser
elle représente 80% des salariés à temps
partiel et pour la plupart suspendre un
temps leur carrière en raison de leur
maternité leur salaire est en outre en
moyenne inférieure de 22 à 28% à celui
de l'homme elle ne cotise donc pas de la
même façon pour certains atteindre le
bon nombre d'annuités requis reviendrai
à partir à l'âge de 67 ans de quoi se
moque-t-on vous comptez sur la droite
sénatoriale pour vous accorder une
légitimité par le menteur je déplore
pour ma part qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
poursuit des débats ni de vote à
l'Assemblée nationale vous en êtes en
partie responsable en ayant tout recours
à l'article 47-1 de la Constitution
sachez en tout cas qu'une opposition de
gauche est bien présente dans nos rangs
au Sénat moins bruyante
est présente oui et prête à débattre
jusqu'au bout les amendements de mes
collègues de droite pour corriger vos
textes notamment en proposant une
surcote de 5% pour les maires de famille
qui auraient une carrière complète ou la
création d'un CDI Seigneur visant avant
à favoriser leur emploi et à le
valoriser ne suffiront pas à rendre
acceptable cette réforme
une réforme que 69% des Français
rejettent sans appel selon un dernier
sondage il faut ces petits arrangements
à la marge ne démontrent qu'une chose
droite et macronie avance main dans la
main il est grand temps d'écouter la
colère sociale qui gronde nous avons été
des millions de citoyens et de
citoyennes dans toute la France a
manifesté contre ce texte le 19 et le 31
janvier le 7 le 11 et le 16 février le 7
mars il est elle diront de nouveau non
dans la rue à votre projet de société
nombre d'entre nous parlementaires nous
serons à leurs côtés dans la rue et
aussi au Sénat pour débattre des
retraites merci
la parole et maintenant notre collègue
Henri Cabanel pour le Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs madame la Présidente de la
Commission
était-il urgent de faire cette réforme
des retraites
alors que la rue se chauffe alors que
les sondages marquent l'opposition des
Français pour ce texte
alors que l'inflation la guerre à
l'Ukraine la crise de l'énergie la crise
économique crée un climat anxiogène
après une crise sanitaire mondiale
faut-il en rajouter si je suis le
premier à dire dans mes interventions
qu'il faut prévoir long terme et qu'en
France nous souffrons d'une absence de
culture d'anticipation est-il
raisonnable de faire de la faire passer
un force et c'est pas jouer avec le feu
je redoute ces conséquences politiques
car la colère entraîne souvent des votes
extrême si le risque que vous prenez
il y a encore une fois un problème de
méthode car chaque président de la
République Monsieur Sarkozy Monsieur
Hollande est désormais monsieur Macron
ont réformé notre système en peu de
temps
ne peut-il pas y avoir des prévisions à
long terme qui généreraient une réforme
à long terme également car les Français
ne comprennent plus
pendant les enjeux
sécuriser le système de retraite
l'équilibre financier de notre système
de retraite et surtout un enjeu pour le
régime de base de la sécurité sociale
depuis la loi organique du 14 Mac mars
2022 relative aux lois de finale de la
sécurité sociale chaque PLFSS contient
un article liminaire sur l'état des
prévisions de dépenses de recettes et de
soldes des administrations de sécurité
sociale pour l'exercice en cours et pour
les années à venir
tout le monde s'accorde à reconnaître
qu'il n'est pas équilibré le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites chaque année
prévoit l'évolution du déficit entre 12
et 14% à l'horizon 2070 il faut donc
entrevoir des sources de financement
votre option est d'augmenter l'âge de
départ la France affichant un l'un des
âges les plus bas en Europe mais toutes
les solutions ont-elles été envisagées
étudiées quelle évaluation
trouver le régime le plus efficient les
pensions sont financiers directement par
les cotisations des actifs c'est le
principe de notre système à répartition
cela nous impose d'anticiper mais là
encore avons nous poser toutes les
possibilités qui pourraient solutionner
ces enjeux
le président Macron a imaginé lors du
quinqui n'a précédent une autre réforme
pour remplacer les 42 régimes de
retraite existants avec un système
unique à point cela soulevé à l'époque
une forte mobilisation sociale mais pas
plus que celle d'aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire a effacé d'un revers de manche
cette option qui pourtant proposé le
même calcul pour tous même question
quelle évaluation quel bilan quel
scénario de solutions différentes c'est
pourquoi je salue l'introduction à
l'Assemblée nationale de l'article
premier bis qui demande un rapport sur
la possibilité les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite c'est un
converger les différents régimes et
intégrant les paramètres de la réforme
prévue dans la présente loi
le groupe RDSE appelle depuis longtemps
de ses vœux une réforme systémique qui
pourrait aboutir à la mise en place d'un
tel système
rien ni les enjeux ni les solutions n'a
été véritablement expliqué aux Français
ce manque de sensibilisation laisse la
place à toutes les suppositions à tous
les fantasmes mais surtout à toutes les
oppositions
cela génère une fine et un climat de
défiance nous sommes en plein dedans car
les Français se sont pris en pleine
figure une réforme qui leur paraît non
justifiée et surtout injuste car non
adapté aux carrières découpées des
femmes à celles des seniors aux métiers
pénibles et enfin aux carrières longues
pour générer la lésion vous le savez il
faut donner les clés de la compréhension
prenons les 43 ans de cotisation
peu de sang peu de Français savent que
cela déjà a été voté votez en 2014 sous
la présidence Monsieur François Hollande
cette loi est entrée en vigueur en 2020
la durée du cotisation pour obtenir une
retraite à taux plein devait augmenter
d'un trimestre tous les trois ans de
façon progressive en fonction des
générations
l'objectif étant d'atteindre 172
trimestres en 2035 soit 43 années de
cotisation pour les Français nés en 1973
votre gouvernement a donc prévu une
anticipation de la loi Touraine dès 2027
ce seul changement n'aurait pas dû
enflammer la sphère politique qui avait
raison et conscience a toujours pris ses
responsabilités
certaines parlementaires qui s'acharnent
d'une même voix à critiquer à invectiver
voire à vociférer on oubliés de dire et
de redire que les 43 ans ont été votés
par la loi Touraine et de fait et de
fuite on a déjà reculé l'âge de départ
pour avoir un taux plein
il focalise la colère alors même que
cela a été acté il ne devrait pas y
avoir de débats à mon avis sur ce sujet
ils sont gravés dans le marbre de la loi
je pense que donc je pense donc vous
avez commis une erreur de communication
par ce texte car au-delà de l'erreur du
timing il y a un manque évident de
préparation de sensibilisation et
d'explication
une telle réforme sans l'accord d'aucun
candidat d'aucun syndicat pardon est
déjà un échec
il rejette toute recule de l'âge légal
qui va pénaliser les plus modestes un
premier lieu les Français ayant des
carrières longues puisque certains vont
devoir travailler plus de 43 ans ce qui
n'est pas équitable avec un recul
progressif de l'âge légal à 64 ans cette
injustice concerne potentiellement
toutes les personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 21 ans sont donc des
carrières longues qui posent problème
avec l'obligation de 5 trimestres avec
une organisation par tranche d'âge avant
16 ans avant 18 ans avant 20 ans qu'il
était cumuler plus de 43 ans s'ils n'ont
pas les 5 trimestres demandés
alors que très souvent ce sont celles
qui ont assumé les travaux les plus
pénibles même si nous ne sommes pas dupe
et qu'il s'agit avant tout d'un problème
financier et de solidarité du système je
salue par contre votre souhait
d'enquêter une autre pour les moins de
21 ans
quand elle a surcote de à 60 c'est temps
vous avez dit que c'est pour soutenir
les femmes mais quelle évaluation de
cette proposition combien de femmes vont
en bénéficier heureusement votre
gouvernement vient d'annoncer une
nouvelle mesure des signes à favoriser
la situation des femmes notamment via
des bonifications nous l'étudierons avec
grand intérêt
concernant la pénibilité le report de la
jelégal de départ à 64 ans d'ici 2030 va
automatiquement reculer l'âge de départ
possible en cas de pénibilité il faut
donc préciser les critères et surtout
favoriser des retraites anticipées et
nos débats vont nous l'espérons faire
avancer le texte car l'article 9 n'a pas
pu être examiné à l'Assemblée nationale
l'enjeu est primordial
concernant les seniors l'article 2 a mis
en place l'index et créer un objectif
d'amélioration de leur embauche et du
maintien de leur emploi
soutient l'idée d'un bonus valus qui
aurait de vrais effets de simulation de
l'emploi des seniors et poserait de
véritables objectifs car run index
impénalité ne servira à rien mais je
connais votre volonté de faire des
propositions concrètes à ce sujet
les critères de qualité de vie au
travail sont des indicateurs fiables par
exemple de taux d'arrêt de la maladie le
tourneur mais ils ne sont efficients que
s'ils sont accompagnés de contrôle et de
mesures coercitives
mon groupe le RSE est très attaché à la
valeur travail et le bien-être au
travail doit donc être au centre dans
nos débats car il n'y a pas de volonté
de s'arrêter tôt lorsque les paramètres
sont réunis pour une qualité de vie
professionnelle c'est pourquoi la visite
médicale le bilan du jour au travail est
primordial l'équilibre de notre système
passe par une solution de maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors il faut donc lutter
contre les abus de rupture
conventionnelle de plus il faut
absolument faire évoluer les mesures de
retraite progressive pensez au bien-être
du futur retraité tout autant qu'à la
nécessité de transmission pour les
nouveaux recrutés je salue l'ouverture
de ce système à la fonction publique
c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé un amendement
pour que des refus des entreprises soit
motivées il faut les inciter à accepter
cette progressivité dans l'arrêt à
l'emploi
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez compris
pénibilité carrière longue retraite des
femmes et des seniors nous semble des
sujets très importants et les sénateurs
de mon groupe vous proposeront des
amendements en ce sens
enfin je veux faire un aparté qui
n'engage strictement que moi
je suis choqué que nous amorçons ce
débat des retraites qui évoquent la
suppression des régimes spéciaux sans
remettre en question notre propre
système celui des sénateurs
on me répond à juste titre que nous
avons un système autonome et que nous
finançons nous-mêmes notre régime certes
mais à partir de budget public et donc
de deniers publics puisqu'elle est
financée à la fois par notre cotisation
soit avis contraire notre indemnité et
bien financée par les deniers publics
par une cotisation employeur du Sénat et
par un prélèvement sur les actifs
financiers dont dispose le signe le
Sénat la stimulationale aligne aligné
son régime à celui de la fonction
publique depuis 2008 pourquoi pas nous
en me répondra que les députés n'avaient
pas le même système c'est vrai mais
quand on veut on peut après 6 ans de
mandat nous bénéficions d'une pension
qui n'a pas été qui n'a pas
la très grande majorité que n'ont pas la
trigan de majorité des Français en une
carrière totale
vous trouvez ça peut-être normal moi je
trouve ça choquant je salue votre
volonté monsieur le Président ce matin
encore sur une chaîne publique d'avoir
indiqué qu'il faudrait réformer notre
système rapidement évidemment je suis
pour une réforme qui va s'appliquer
rapidement sinon de prévoir pour les
autres c'est toujours trop facile
messieurs les ministres beaucoup de
points restent à éclaircir
vous le savez l'ADN du groupe RDC c'est
de débattre nous souhaitons donc aller
au bout de ce projet de loi dans un
climat apaisé mais je n'en doute point
pour construire un texte qui répondra
aux enjeux mais également aux
interrogations des Français tous les
regards sont portés vers le Sénat qui ne
font encore endossera une mission de
sagesse et de raison pour faire évoluer
ce texte nous n'avons pas choisi cette
réforme notre responsabilité en tant que
par leur Inter et de débattre quelle que
soit nos convictions au RDSE nous
assumerons son examen avait conscience
je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la présidente
Catherine de roche vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur
les mini madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur pour avis mes chers collègues
notre pays évolue se transforme il
vieillit nous sommes loin d'en avoir
tiré toutes les conséquences sur un
système social construit pour répondre
aux besoins d'une société totalement
différente mais dans les représentations
nous marquent d'une empreinte durable si
nous nous référons au préambule de la
constitution du 24 octobre 1946
tout être humain qui en raison de son
âge de son état physique ou mental de la
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence la France alors
à 40 millions d'habitants les plus de 65
ans sont moins de 5 millions et
représentent 11% de la population
leur espérance de vie à cet âge est de
12 ans pour les hommes et de 16 ans pour
les femmes les retraités y sont pauvres
beaucoup plus pauvres que l'ensemble de
la population avec un taux de pauvreté
qui dépasse les 35% de ce point de vue
même si la pauvreté de certains
retraités en particulier aux âges élevés
restent une réalité le système de
retraite a permis de la réduire dans des
proportions considérables avec 8,6% le
taux pauvreté de plus de 65 ans et
inférieur au 14% de l'ensemble de la
population
la photographie d'aujourd'hui est donc
très différente en 2018 la France
comptait 65 millions d'habitants et plus
de 13 millions de personnes de plus de
65 ans soit 20% de la population
l'espérance de vie à cet âge a fortement
progressé elle est de 19 ans pour les
hommes et de 23 ans pour les femmes
depuis le milieu du 20e siècle
l'espérance de vie a progressé de trois
mois par an en moyenne mieux encore
d'après des chiffres publiés récemment
l'espérance de vie sans incapacité à 65
ans a progressé de deux ans et 7 mois
depuis 2008 elle est de plus de 11 ans
pour les hommes et de plus de 12 ans
pour les femmes depuis sa création la
retraite a changé de nature et c'est
heureux une personne de 65 ans
aujourd'hui n'a que peu à voir avec ce
naïeul au même âge
la place dans les rangs de nos priorités
si les lois de programmation des
finances publiques n'étaient pas devenue
un exercice technocratique à usage
principalement externes elle pourrait
constituer le lien le lieu d'un
nécessaire débat sur nos priorités
d'actions publiques force est de
constater que la part des retraits dans
les dépenses publiques résultent plutôt
d'un choix implicite ni penser ni
articuler par rapport aux questions de
santé ou de vieillissement qui intéresse
pourtant au premier chef la même
population je ne parle même pas de la
justice de l'éducation de la défense
dont nous constatons chaque jour
l'ampleur des besoins alors oui les
légitimes d'interroger nos choix
collectifs en matière de retraite
lorsqu'elle est globalement prise plutôt
pour plus longtemps et dans des
conditions plus généreuses que dans
d'autres pays européens
oui il est légitime de s'interroger dans
le cadre d'un texte budgétaire car il
s'agit bien d'un enjeu de finances
publiques en jeu de finances publiques
qui ne sont ni un tabou ni un gros mot
aux demeurant la réforme des retraites
est devenue un rendez-vous régulier
notre pays semble devoir faire avec ses
épisodes traumatiques au fil desquels
selon un rythme régulier il se livre à
cet exercice singulier le déroulé
souvent le même concertation aux
positions manifestation puis adoption
non sans autant de recul qui sont
l'annonce d'une prochaine fois cela ne
serait pas si grave si à chaque fois
l'exercice ne contribuez pas à abîmer
encore plus notre tissu social il y a
trois ans le président de la République
a tenté de renouveler l'exercice avec
une réforme dite systémique table rase
de tous les régimes
hérités de l'histoire et place au jardin
la française du système universel une
belle construction intellectuelle
réalisée sans contrainte budgétaire et
donc sans cristalliser les habituels
opposition d'abord intéressé par le bel
édifice nous avons ensuite été inquiets
au fil des discussions mais aussi de
deux colloques organisées au Sénat notre
inquiétude a grandi l'âge pivot est venu
perturber un régime universel qu'il
était de moins en moins qui s'annonçait
remarquablement coûteux et cheminée sans
pilote vers la catastrophe de la réforme
systémique nous étions passés au risque
systémique que cela crée sanitaire a pu
nous épargner c'est donc un véritable
soulagement que nous avons noté le
renoncement à cette réforme toujours
présente sur le bureau du Sénat mais que
le gouvernement s'est bien gardé de
reprendre nous avions souligné que la
question du financement des retraites
demeurait pour des raisons qui sont
décidément têtus nous sommes attachés au
régime par répartition qui marque à la
fois la solidarité entre les générations
mais aussi une certaine garantie par
l'État de la pérennité du système pour
garantir sa pérennité son acceptation
par toutes les générations il faut
garantir son é de moyen terme nous avons
proposé des réponses qui s'appuyaient
sur un constat simple et un choix clair
nous ne trouvons pas crédible levier de
recettes supplémentaires notre pays
peine à descendre sous un taux de
prélèvement obligatoire de près de 45%.
nous concitoyens comme la montre le
épisode de gilets jaunes sont peu enclin
aller voir augmenter nous ne souhaitons
pas affecter le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités en cette période d'inflation
et après plusieurs années de sous
revalorisation reste donc le levier du
partage d'une partie de la prolongation
de l'espérance de vie pour créer de la
richesse et consolider le système de
retraite idéalement nous devrions
pouvoir construire un consensus sur des
ajustements périodiques et la forme
qu'ils doivent prendre je regrette que
l'âge de la retraite soit devenu une
sorte de totem qui occulte tout besoin
nouveau de notre système social la
retraite n'est pas la seule question
sociale des personnes âgées j'ai
tendance à penser que leurs premiers
sujets c'est la santé le vieillissement
se par une épidémie de maladies
chroniques affectent la qualité de vie
et appelle un effort massif en
prévention mais aussi en prise en charge
le vieillissement c'est aussi la
préservation de l'autonomie dans toutes
ces dimensions la perte d'autonomie ne
concerne pas toute une classe d'âge mais
c'est un risque qui s'assure et si nous
devions augmenter le prélèvements
obligatoires je les affecterai plus
volontiers à une assurance de ce type
nous ne sommes pas prêts à faire face à
ce risque majeur pour notre société tant
par ces implications pour nos
concitoyens que par ses effets
budgétaires un pays qui vieillit aussi
un pays qui tend négligé sa jeunesse et
la préparation de son avenir la retraite
ne saurait être la seule perspective que
le nôtre à ceux qui ont leur vie à
construire nous devons au plus jeune une
éducation de qualité qu'il est prépa à
la fois leur vie de citoyens et d'actifs
dans cette économie mondialisée nous
devons famille des conditions favorables
à leur épanouissement nous devons à nos
concitoyens des services publics
efficaces et de qualité qui sont aussi
une des compétences une des composantes
de notre compétitivité faisons donc le
choix de l'équilibre de nos comptes
sociaux pour préserver non seulement les
retraites mais aussi notre capacité à
investir pour construire l'avenir on
nous reproche d'être la génération qui a
gâché la planète ne soyons pas celles
qui aura laissé dépérir faute de réforme
et de courage un système social qui fait
notre fierté collective et sans doute
une part de notre identité je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire
la parole merci
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
le rapporteur général Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
il y a toujours eu en France deux
grandes familles politiques
les cigales
et les fourmis
les cigales promettent aux Français des
droits sans savoir si la nation pourra
les financer
les fourmis ne promettent rien que la
nation ne pourra financer
j'ai pas encore dit qui était Cigale et
qui était fourni
au début des années 80 la France des
cigales c'est offert accredit la
retraite à 60 ans
cette décision était un contresens
historique majeur
à l'époque déjà tout prouve qu'il faudra
travailler plus pour équilibrer notre
système de retraite
le taux de natalité avait déjà commencé
à s'effondrer le taux de mortalité
diminuait lentement la population vivait
donc plus longtemps et se renouvelait
déjà moins vite
l'espérance de vie continue d'être
progressé depuis le début des années 80
le temps passé à la retraite n'a donc
jamais cessé d'augmenter
parallèlement les Français entraient de
plus en plus tard sur le marché du
travail c'est aussi l'un des résultats
de l'obsession du bac pour tous et du
grement consciencieux de l'apprentissage
mécaniquement la proportion de retraité
par rapport aux actifs a donc augmenté
en 1960 on comptait quatre actifs sur un
retraité au début des années 80 on était
à moins de 3 pour 1 aujourd'hui il serai
au est à 1,7 actif pour un retraité en
2050 ce sera un virgule deux actifs pour
un retraité
il n'y a pas de politique qui vaillent
en dehors des réalités disaient le
général de Gaulle
la politique du président Mitterrand fut
exactement l'inverse
ignorer la réalité par calcul électoral
depuis tous les gorées armements ont dû
rattraper le coup
la droite la fait
en remontant l'âge légal de départ avec
la réforme verte en 2010
la gauche l'a fait en augmentant la
durée de cotisation avec la réforme
Touraine en 2014
on le voit le clivage politique entre
les cigales et les fourmis ne correspond
pas exactement au clivage gauche-droite
on trouve des fourmis à gauche
et on trouve des cigales à droite et à
l'extrême droite
elles sont même lésions rassemblement
national c'est un comble qui ne manque
pas de saveur les troupes de Madame Le
Pen militent aujourd'hui pour revenir à
l'ermitterrand
les fourmis elles ont compris que
l'équilibre financier de notre système
de retraite par répartition et gravement
compromis et qu'il faut agir pour le
sauver
mais sur ce point là encore mes chers
collègues il existe deux types de
fourmis
il y a les fourmis que je qualifierais
de fourmis rouges
les fourmis rouges pensent qu'il faut
taxer davantage pour équilibrer le
système
elles oublient au passage
mes chers fourmis que nous sommes déjà
médaillés au championnat du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires
et puis il y a les autres fourmis
celles qui considèrent que la solution
passe par une augmentation du temps de
travail
il semble qu'on en trouve plus à
l'étranger qu'en France
les Pays-Bas l'Italie l'Allemagne ou
l'Espagne ont déjà décidé de repousser
l'âge légal de départ à 67 ans
confronté au même tendance sociétale que
nous ces pays se sont simplement rendus
à l'évidence il faut travailler plus
pour équilibrer les comptes le report de
l'âge légal à 64 ans est une mesure
raisonnable je dirais même une mesure de
bon sens
nous l'avons d'ailleurs déjà voté ici
plusieurs fois mes chers collègues
nous n'ouvrirons pas le débat d'un
report au-delà 64 ans ce débat est
pourtant légitime nous devrions l'avoir
j'ai bien compris que le contexte
politique et social ne s'y prêtait guère
j'en profite d'ailleurs messieurs les
ministres pour saluer votre patience et
votre résistance vous avez survécu pas
ici à deux semaines de cacophonie de
vocifération à l'Assemblée nationale
bravo
certains jusqu'à maintenant s'interroger
sur l'utilité du Sénat
avec le cirque des insoumis et le
mutisme des le pénis beaucoup de
Français se demandent aujourd'hui à quoi
sert l'Assemblée nationale
j'espère donc et j'entends mes chers
collègues
que nous ne donnerons pas un tel
spectacle au Sénat du reste il n'est pas
possible de faire pire
notre groupe vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues soutiendra donc ce texte
sans ambiguïté
et nous serons forts de proposition pour
l'améliorer
merci mon chers collègues
la parole est à notre collègue
s'il vous plaît
à notre collègue Martin lévrier pour le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
et monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
rappeler a été initié sous présidence
socialiste ainsi une fois l'équilibre de
systèmes assurés cette réforme
ambitionne de le rendre plus juste il
importe donc au Sénat dont nous
connaissons tous l'esprit de
responsabilité au travers du PLFR SS de
permettre entre autres une meilleure
prise en compte des carrières hachées
notamment pour les aidants une meilleure
prise en compte des carrières longues
avec une adaptation du dispositif pour
les actifs ayant commencé à travailler
tôt une meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité permise par la négociation
avec les syndicats initiés il y a trois
mois par le gouvernement
l'accès aux comptes professionnels de
prévention sera élargi et un fonds
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle sera créée et
dotée de 1 milliard sur le quinquennat
les soignants des établissements
médicaux sociaux de la fonction publique
hospitalière et de la fonction publique
territoriale seront ainsi mieux protégés
dans l'exercice de métiers pénible ce
texte apporte par ailleurs des mesures
spécifiques au Seigneur à date seul
23000 salariés utilisent le dispositif
de retraite progressive il permet
pourtant une véritable transition entre
vie active et retraite en permettant un
salarié sur le point de partir de
réduire son temps de travail tout en
commençant à percevoir une partie de sa
pension de retraite la réforme entend ce
dispositif au libéraux et aux agents
publics par ailleurs le cumul emploi
retraite qui bénéficie aujourd'hui à 500
000 retraités sera
grand du créateur de droits
supplémentaires à la retraite enfin ce
texte apportera une meilleure protection
du pouvoir d'achat
1,8 millions de retraités pourrait si le
texte était voté bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de leur pension de base
de 600 euros par an en moyenne un futur
retraité sur 4 pourrait voir sa pension
augmentée dans moyenne 400 euros par an
mais au-delà de ses moyennes cette
réforme vise particulièrement à revenir
sur nombre de situations inégales je
pense que particulièrement aux retraites
agricoles et aux cas très précis des
agriculteurs qui conserveront leur taux
plein même pour un départ pour
inaptitude ou invalidité
c'est revalorisations votées dans les
textes précédents ne leur était pas
ouvertes cela sera chose faite mes chers
collègues vous le voyez c'est un texte
déjà très fourni qui nous est proposé
force de proposition lorsqu'il s'agit
d'améliorer le quotidien des Français
notre groupe déposera des amendements
parmi lesquels un amendement pour
permettre le rachat de ces trimestres de
stage à un tarif préférentiel jusqu'à un
âge défini par décret sans que celui-ci
ne puisse être inférieur à 25 ans un
amendement pour permettre le rachat de
ces trimestres d'études à tarif
préférentiel jusqu'à un âge défini par
décret sans que celui-ci ne puisse
inférieur à 30 ans un amendement
pourrait-on rendre la majoration de la
pension de 10% pour 3 enfants aux
professions libérales le professionnel
libéraux pardon mes chers collègues
notre démocratie parlementaire a été
profondément blessée par des débats
parasités et des comportements non
républicains voient révolutionnaires à
l'Assemblée nationale
les Français dans leur grande majorité
attendent de nous un tout autre
comportement un comportement responsable
de la part de ceux qui les représentent
au-delà de l'âge au Delage au-delà de
l'âge de départ à la retraite nous ne
pouvons faire l'impasse de tous les
autres sujets abordés dans ce texte
pénibilité précarité carrière arraché
égalité femme homme
l'examen au Sénat du PLFSS 2023 qui
comportait 112 articles a été battu
autour de 1142 amendements l'examen du
PLFR SS comporte plus de 2700
amendements pour 20 articles je ne veux
pas croire que cette comparaison donner
réponse
les Français attendent un débat de
controverse nous ne devons d'avoir le
courage d'étudier l'ensemble du PLFSS au
même titre que cette réforme est
courageuse dans un contexte difficile
pour tous faire fui du déficit à venir
c'est mettre à mal son existence et
l'idée même de ce qu'il représente notre
groupe sera attaché à examiner ce texte
dans son intégralité il y a le voter
pour l'avenir de notre système je vous
remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Bernard Chaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres madame la prévente madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la réalité de cette
réforme que vous nous soumettez c'est
que son inspiration purement financière
remporte de multiples conséquences
sociales que vous avez successivement
nier minimisé puis tenté de colmater
jusqu'à un texte qui est constellé de
rustine je voudrais que parler de la
réalité des fins de carrière que votre
réforme au fond détériore profondément
cette réalité ce sont des dispositifs de
prise en charge réduit de la pénibilité
c'est une adaptation insuffisante est
souvent inexistante d'ailleurs des
postes de travail ce sont des arrêts
maladie à répétition pour soutenir qu'un
cas les salariés à flot
comme l'avait justement révélé la
candidate des républicains à l'élection
présidentielle l'espérance de vie sans
incapacité en Suède et de près de 72 ans
l'âge de départ à la retraite oui et a
été repoussé à 65 ans et donc vous vous
voulez repousser l'âge légal à 64 ans en
France alors que l'espérance de vie
moyenne sans incapacité atteint
difficilement justement cet âge le
gradient social de cette espérance de
vie sont cinq capacités signe à lui seul
l'injustice de votre choix car c'est un
choix de rééquilibrer le régime des
retraites sans faire appel au plus
favoriser la réalité c'est que repousser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
revient à fabriquer de la maladie un
dégrader les fins de carrière
il est intéressant de regarder les
conséquences de la réforme de 2010 qui a
repoussé l'âge légal de départ de deux
ans à 62 ans elles sont parlantes en
2019 la Cour des comptes a relevé une
hausse de 800 millions d'euros du coût
annuel des arrêts maladie 6 ans après le
report de l'âge légal de départ à 62 ans
elle en a attribué une large part à ce
report le mois dernier l'étude du CNAM a
confirmé ce phénomène le report à 62 ans
a provoqué une augmentation
significative de la fréquence des arrêts
maladie
il faut donc prendre en charge la
pénibilité et adapter les postes or la
matière presque tout reste à faire vous
qui avez supprimé la prise en charge de
4 facteurs de pénibilité vous ne
réalisez les rétablissez même pas tous
par exemple au lieu de balayer la
question des agents chimiques dangereux
complexes il faudrait au contraire mener
un vrai travail sur les activités
responsables des missions d'aérosols
dangereux sur le fondement des
nombreuses bases de données qui existent
et il faut aller plus loin réserver les
postes les moins pénibles aux plus âgés
favoriser le recours effectif au C2P qui
n'est mobilisé que par 6 personnes et
l'Égypte sur 1000 et prévenir les
risques bref mener une politique de
prévention c'est un effort qui s'est
révélé payant dans les pays qui en est
ont déployé les moyens mais le virage de
la prévention de novembre dernier à
percuté le mur de Bercy et ce texte
n'est pas une loi de finance sociale
c'est une loi de Bercy les français eux
ils ont tout compris cette réforme
financière vous voulez l'imposer à leurs
dépens dans les petites villes sur tout
le territoire ce sont des visages qui
travaillent monsieur le ministre et
souvent pour peu de revenus qui se
révoltent ce ne sont pas des inactifs
non plus
ces personnes ces Français il est temps
de les écouter avant que le sourd
ressentiment qui traverse le pays ne
porte d'autres conséquences nous avons
élu un chef de l'État pour qu'il fasse
barrage à l'extrême droite nous ne
l'avons pas élu pour qu'ils défendent un
projet qui ajoute du carburant à son
moteur je vous remercie
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jean-Marie vanner pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
veut-on d'un doumensonge ou d'une amère
vérité
celle-ci malheureusement est claire le
système des retraites par répartition
est menacé
faut-il donc le réformer ben la réponse
de notre groupe
celle qui a rappelé le président
Marseille tout à l'heure
éclaire et sans ambiguïté c'est oui d'un
système conçu
à l'origine avec quatre cotisants pour
un retraité ce ratio tombent aujourd'hui
à 1,7 cotisants pour un retraité c'est
un déséquilibre évident incontestable et
qui s'accroît avec l'espérance de vie
d'aucun pensent que les hommes mentent
les chiffres un peu moins le corps
conseille d'orientation des retraites
c'est soudainement retrouvé sous les
feux de la rente des rapports en général
indigestes sont devenus malgré eux
livrent d'éveil pour pas dire de chevet
pour certains irresponsables politiques
car il s'agit bien d'irresponsabilités à
ne retenir du corps que le seul fait que
des dépenses soient sous contrôle
c'est négliger le sujet de la dette la
dette retraite est déjà très élevé 43
milliards portés par la Cadès c'est
négliger aussi que les déficits cumulés
selon le corps d'ailleurs
représenteront 150 milliards de dettes
nouvelles en 2030 alors fallait-il
réformer dès maintenant nous répondons
encore 800 hésiter en matière climatique
on parle volontiers d'urgence de ce que
nous laisserons à nos enfants et
petits-enfants il en est de même pour
les retraites et notamment pour les
jeunes qui croient de moins en moins
qu'ils en auront une
le Sénat dans sa sagesse d'ailleurs n'a
pas attendu l'agend d'un gouvernementale
pour réformer il adopte depuis plusieurs
années le recul progressif de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans avec l'accélération de
la loi Touraine bien plus juste car
recul brutal à 65 ans
la réforme proposée est-elle adaptée
notre réponse est encore affirmative si
l'on accepte comme postulat de ne pas
augmenter les cotisations retraite afin
de ne pas appeler
affaiblir pardon le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés pour lequel évidemment nous
sommes d'accord
mais en ce qui concerne la création
d'emplois j'en doute en effet admis
point de plus de cotisations employeur
représente 4 milliards et demi de
recettes en moyenne 225 euros par
salarié par an
c'est pour une entreprise de 100
salariés un peu moins qu'un poste de
travail
donc cette réforme est-elle
satisfaisante d'un point de vue
comptable oui d'un point de vue social
et politique on peut en débattre et
c'est bien cela d'ailleurs auquel nous
sommes conviés d'un point de vue social
les 17 milliards dégagés en 2030
permettront de financer 6 milliards de
mesure de solidarité et d'un point de
vue politique l'évidence c'est que les
Français n'admettent pas le recul de
l'âge à 64 ans considérant à juste titre
que seuls les salariés sont mis à
contribution une autre solution serait
évidemment d'augmenter la taxation du
capital est-ce que c'est envisageable et
bien c'est une question que je pose au
gouvernement et à ceux qui seraient
tentés de prendre tout le plat dans leur
assiette pour citer la des pierres
au nom de la solidarité nationale il ne
me paraît ni outrageant ni indécent que
les bénéficiaires d'un CAC 40 au plus
haut actuellement accepte une
augmentation de la CSG sur le capital
un point supplémentaire rapporterait un
milliard 5 alors abordons maintenant
quelques articles rapidement
saluons tout d'abord les propositions du
gouvernement pour tenter d'améliorer la
justice et l'équité du système
nous avons quelques questions parce que
certaines mesures pour certaines mesures
le diable on le sait se cache dans les
détails pour les petites retraites tout
le monde a retenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de retraite à moins de 1200 euros mais
peu on comprit que cela concernait que
les carrières complètes alors une
suggestion celle de l'unescas qui me
paraît intelligente et intelligible
pourquoi ne pas mettre un plancher à 75%
du SMIC soit 1000 euros pour les
carrières incomplètes
pour les carrières longues
le dispositif paraît serpenté de façon
erratique entre 43 et 44 ans de durée de
cotisation en fonction de l'entrée dans
la vie active il nous apparaît
nécessaire de lisser l'ensemble avec
donc des départs de 57 à 62 ans de quoi
ouvrir une fenêtre d'ailleurs de départ
de 57 à 64 ans chers aux économistes
Blanchard et Tyrol et beaucoup plus
jeune que juste qu'une borne unique de
départ à 64 ans
pour les seniors le gouvernement décide
de s'intéresser aux fins de carrière
mais je crains que l'index Seigneur
proposait une Swagger suffisant pour
répondre à l'intention qu'il manifeste
il nous semble que cette index doit être
accompagné d'une prime à l'embauche
sorte de un seigneur une solution et que
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs un CDI senior et
nous devrions pas faire l'économie d'un
bonus malus sur la base de cette index
pour favoriser le maintien des seniors
dans l'emploi
pour les droits familiaux nous
proposions donc avant la hache de
l'article 40 un départ anticipé à 62 ans
pour trois enfants et 63 ans pour deux
mais nous constatons aussi de fortes
disparité dans les droits familiaux la
réversion particulière ou 13 régimes
subsistent et qu'il sera nécessaire de
revoir dans la prochaine loi enfin
la pénibilité la Pénélope du travail que
l'on s'y arrête un petit peu plus nous y
sommes attentifs bien entendu nous
sommes attentifs à la réflexion aussi
sur le travail la nécessité de lui
donner plus de sens nous sommes aussi
tous aussi vigilants face à ceux qui
contesteraient la valeur du travail il
n'appartient pourtant pas à cette loi de
financement évidemment de la sécurité
sociale de traiter de ce sujet beaucoup
trop complexe où tous les points de vue
divers chevaux suivant évidemment le
point dont de duquel on se place du
point de vue de quel on se place alors
faisons venons-en à ce qui nous
préoccupe vraiment c'est à dire réparer
l'usure professionnelle la loi dans ce
domaine est généreuse elle prend en
compte les trois autres critères
d'ergonomiques qui donneront lieu à un
suivi médical c'est bien mais il nous
paraît nécessaire de compléter ce bilan
avec un bilan de compétences pour
envisager l'avenir sérieusement enfin un
mot pour conclure sur ce qui nous tient
à coeur à nous Centris le dialogue
social nous regrettons qu'il est tourné
court que certains partenaires sociaux
et responsables politiques et refusé
d'emblée le diagnostic du corps du corps
avant d'y consentir que d'autres est cru
que la désinformation est listerie
pouvait remplacer le débat aussi ce vrai
débat que chacun mérite et qui pourra je
l'espère se nouer ici au Sénat aucune
réponse n'est faite pour l'éternité
plusieurs dates jalonnent deux décennies
de réforme des retraites s'y ajoutera
sans aucun doute 2023 et peut-être aussi
2027 avec la réforme présidentielle pour
cela nous pensons qu'il est bon qui est
une clause de revoyure ou plutôt un
bilan d'étape produit par la Cour des
comptes afin d'assurer peut-être la
sérénité du débat qui suivra comme celui
qui je l'espère pourra se dérouler ici
demain dans cette assemblée merci
beaucoup merci
merci mon cher collègue
je vais donner dans la parole au
président Bruno Retailleau
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
de la commission madame monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues pour lever
tous suspense je voudrais dire que bien
sûr nous allons voter un texte qui sera
notre texte
c'est à dire que nous voterons la
réforme une réforme modifiée une réforme
que nous allons amender selon les
prescriptions
qu'il a fait avec pédagogie qui avec
humour du docteur sur le rapporteur René
Paul Savary
de quoi aurions-nous l'air mes chers
collègues si nous refusions de voter une
réforme que nous votons ici chaque année
depuis plusieurs années nous ne sommes
pas des girouettes notre boussole ce
n'est pas email Macron ça n'est pas le
gouvernement
c'est l'intérêt national c'est le seul
international et je crois que ce qui
abîme le plus la politique ce sont les
zigzags les revirements ce qui abime le
plus la politique ce sont les têtes à
eux et je pense que le Sénat Sonora de
travailler avec constance bien sûr et
cohérence nous en avons monsieur le
ministre Gabriel à tal je pense que la
politique pour ce qui me concerne et
j'en suis même intimement convaincu ce
qui l'honore c'est de pouvoir tenir un
discours de vérité la vérité mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui c'est de dire par
exemple
quand 2030 quand la réforme va
s'appliquer nous aurons en France le
régime le plus avantageux en matière
d'âge de départ à la retraite en Europe
nous aurons aussi le régime le plus
avantageux d'Europe notamment pour ce
qui concerne les carrières longues
c'est une vérité c'est un fait
incontestable la vérité est de
reconnaître que oui la réforme est une
réforme budgétaire elle est évidemment
budgétaire perdez-moi de vous dire
qu'elle est accessoirement budgétaire
oui elle est budgétaire parce que elle
doit faire face aux chiffres qui
viennent encore une fois d'être énoncé
ici 150 milliards de déficits cumulés
sur 10 ans et encore avec des hypothèses
macroéconomiques extrêmement favorable
un taux de chômage à 4,5% avec
toujours plus de pensionnés de retraités
toujours moins de cotisons comment est
fait-on face et il s'agit bien sûr de
sauver un régime auquel on tient tous
par-delà de dos divergence de nos
différences partizanes mais
vous leur nous demain garantir le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités
voulons-nous demain que nos jeunes on
leur impose de payer deux retraites la
note et puis la leur non il faut
réformer bien sûr et quand j'entends
dire que il faut pas regarder les
chiffres que sais-tu fétichisme
comptable mais derrière les chiffres
derrière les chiffres il y a l'argent
des Français derrière l'argent des
Français il y a la peine des Français
est-ce que ça ne vaut pas le coup qu'on
en prenne un peu soin mes chers
collègues alors si Monsieur les
ministres je l'ai souvent dit je l'ai
même répété parfois si le point de
départ de cette réforme ce sont des
déficits le point d'arrivée de la
réforme ça ne peut pas être non plus des
déficits il y a pire il y a bien pire
que de demander aux Français des efforts
c'est demander des efforts aux Français
pour rien quel serait le cas si en 2030
la réforme ne serait pas équilibrée et
nous allons proposer un certain nombre
de pistes notamment d'économie sur la
fraude certains en ont cités ici bien
sûr bien entendu sur la biométrie vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur ministre mais
aussi sur l'alignement notamment pour le
miniat social des conditions de
résidence pourquoi est-ce que il y a pas
les mêmes conditions de résidence quand
on verse le RSA ou quand on versa spa
évidemment et
nous amendements vont enrichir
raisonnablement avec un coût raisonnable
bien loin monsieur le ministre des 6
millions d'euros de mesure
d'accompagnement sans doute parfois
légitime ces milliards pardon bien sûr 6
milliards sur les 17,7 milliards que
prévoit comme marge financière la
réforme et ça pour nous c'est un point
quand je disais que c'était une réforme
budgétaire bien sûr mais qu'elle n'était
budgétaire qu'accessoirement c'est parce
que fondamentalement peut-être qu'on
sera d'accord non pas sur le sens mais
au moins sur ce que je vais dire c'est
que cette réforme porte en elle une
vision de la société un projet de
société
et que c'est une réforme globale
certains même avaient indiqué c'était la
mère de toutes les réformes c'est une
réforme globale parce que elle
récapitule de nombreuses enjeux au moins
3 pour moi et à mes yeux sont les trois
enjeux les plus importants premier enjeu
le modèle social avec un régime de
retraite par répartition
qui permet justement de donner du sens
au lien entre les générations qui permet
de donner du sens à ce que nous sommes
au fait que nous ne sommes pas
simplement un agrégat de communauté ou
d'individus mais que nous sommes une
nation un peuple dépendant les uns des
autres c'est ça la signification du
régime par répartition que nous voulons
sauver un régime
qu'on peut toujours tenter d'améliorer
mais qui est généreux cela a été dit
mais la proportion n'a pas été cité ici
je voudrais la cité
peu le site en général pourquoi en
France parmi les grands pays de la
France et le pays où la proportion de
pauvres âgées de plus de 65 ans et le
plus faible
2,5 x - par rapport à la moyenne des
pays européens c'est cela qu'on tente
aussi
de changer mais aussi de conserver de
préserver c'est ce qui est absolument
fondamental mais évidemment la
générosité va avec l'exigence exigence
de lutte contre les fautes exigence de
justice de justice vis-à-vis aussi des
régimes sociaux pourquoi est-ce que on
attend 43 ans pour les faire converger
est-ce que le sort d'une infirmière
est-ce que le sort d'une infirmière ne
mérite pas moins
que celui d'un conducteur de la retapé
ou de la SNCF nous déposerons bien sûr
un amendement c'est une question de
justice et croyez-moi ces populaires et
croyez moi c'est populaire
croyez-moi c'est populaire deuxième
enjeu la démographie parce que un
système
intergénérationnel c'est un système
démographique Auguste Comte un jour
avait dit très justement la démographie
c'est le destin oui c'est le destin d'un
régime par répartition son
renouvellement générationnel peut pas y
avoir de solidarité c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne voulons pas que cette
réforme se fasse sur le dos des femmes
des maires de famille qui ont eu des
enfants et qui ont travaillé et qui ont
eu des carrières complètes qui n'ont pas
souvent eu d'ailleurs le loisir de
s'arrêter longtemps qui ont dû bosser
parfois parce qu'elles élevaient seuls
des enfants parfois parce que leur mari
avait de petits salaires et qu'il
fallait aussi payer les tracts de la
famille et bien oui et bien oui nous
proposons avec courage et avec fier té
pour ces maires de famille une surcote
on leur doit bien mes chers amis on leur
doit bien
troisième enjeu troisième enjeu pour
parler d'un enjeu de société important
quelle société voulons-nous est-ce que
c'est la société
du droit à la paresse ou est-ce que
c'est la société du travail est-ce que
c'est la société de la décroissance du
déclassement collectif
ou la société de la pauvrissement
individuel la société de cette
appauvrissement ou cette société que
nous appelons nos vœux de la prospérité
pour tous pour chacun mais aussi de la
croissance c'est ce que nous voulons et
pourquoi donc le rapport des Français au
travail s'étend dégradé sans doute il y
a eu l'épidémie sans doute il y a eu la
covid mais je pense que la raison
fondamentale de la dégradation du
rapport des Français au travail c'est
qu'il y a trop de Français aujourd'hui
qui ne parviennent pas à vivre du fruit
de leur travail et ça c'est le produit
écoutez-moi vous n'aurez pas à faire un
ingrat et ça c'est le produit d'un
mensonge vieux de 40 ans
Dieu de 40 ans le boniment de sel et de
ceux qui nous ont vendus la retraite à
60 ans les semaines au 35 heures celles
et ceux qui ont dit aux Français qu'il
vivrait toujours mieux en travaillant
toujours moins
le résultat
le résultat nous le voyons la richesse
par habitant c'est-à-dire le niveau de
vie des Français à dégringolé au 26e
rang il est là le résultat et il est
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues tant de
sortir de ce mensonge de tenir un
discours de vérité aux Français ce qui
peut permettre demain d'améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat le niveau de vie c'est
la prospérité pour tous c'est le salaire
bien sûr mais c'est aussi la création de
richesse grâce au travail
d'où le recul des deux années pour l'âge
de départ à la retraite c'est
fondamental je sais que ce recul il est
exigeant je sais qu'il est un populaire
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que bien
sûr que c'est un levier budgétaire et
que c'est surtout un filet de sécurité
le ministre tu l'entendait tout à
l'heure parler de machines à la décote
bien sûr c'est un filet de sécurité
lâche de départ contre c'est des cotes
massives qui créeraient sinon des
travailleurs pauvres relisez
l'excellente simulation de la CNAV qui a
simulé ce que fait une réforme avec un
allongement de la Dar de la durée de
cotisation et une autre hypothèse avec
le recul de la borne d'âge mais surtout
et j'en viens la prospérité croyez-vous
que la France puisse s'en tirer en
travaillant toujours moins et bien le
recul de l'âge procure un autre avantage
c'est que nous allons automatiquement
mécaniquement augmenter le taux d'emploi
des seniors et donc mettre plus le
travail dans la machine économique
française voilà que nous pourrons
redistribuer voilà et ça c'est
fondamental aujourd'hui la croissance de
demain elle est opérée elle est obérée
par une productivité qui est tombée elle
est obérée par une durée du travail qui
est en berne elle est obérée par un taux
d'emploi qui est l'un des plus faibles
de tous les pays européens voilà et bien
entendu nous voulons améliorer les
conditions d'emploi des seniors et
Monsieur le Ministre la proposition que
a fait notre commission est une
proposition qui n'est pas un caprice
vraiment je vous demande d'y prendre
garde ça fait partie des points qui pour
nous sont essentiels l'index est une
statistique un contrat de fin de
carrière c'est bien autre chose c'est un
outil beaucoup plus opérant et pour
terminer
mes chers collègues nous aurons ici
chacun peut le dire avec ses mots mais
je pense qu'on peut se rejoindre quel
que soit nos appartenances partisanes
nos divergences politiques nous avons
ici un rôle important à jouer nous
sommes le Sénat nous sommes la Haute
Assemblée nous avons chacun d'entre nous
une responsabilité et je sais que et je
le sais par avance que le débat il sera
passionné mais il sera raisonné que le
débat il sera parfois rugueux évidemment
nous n'avons pas les mêmes convictions
d'ailleurs je suis assez heureux de voir
que ce débat ressuscite un peu le vieux
clivage droite-gauche ça n'est pas moi
qui ça n'est pas moi qui vais le
regretter vous le savez bien vous me
connaissez
mais ce que je veux dire ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que le Parlement c'est
la représentation la représentation des
Français c'est pas la guignolisation et
que la politique c'est pas la guerre
c'est pas l'institutionnalisation de la
violence dans un hémicycle la politique
c'est la démocratie la démocratie c'est
le moyen c'est cette invention la belle
invention qu'on trouvait le plus anciens
pour canaliser la violence justement
dans le débat et notamment dans l'espace
public voilà c'est nous qui avons cette
tâche mes chers collègues sénateurs ici
au Sénat de relever le défi d'un débat
respectueux mais d'un débat qui aille
jusqu'au vote parce qu'un homme dites
pas que un bon débat ce serait
simplement un débat calme et respectueux
non
le Parlement les parlementaires c'est
fait pour voter après un débat mais
c'est fait pour voter j'entends que vous
voulez voter l'article 7 ça signifie
monsieur le Président ça signifie donc
que le 8 le 9 le 10 les petites
retraites l'invalidité la question
notamment des travailleurs handicapés
toutes ces questions là ne mériteraient
pas un débat ne mériterait pas un vote
et bien si nous voulons aller au bout du
texte nous le devons pour les Français
et pour nous c'est un devoir
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
Chassain pour de gros les indépendants
République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
Messieurs le rappeur mes chers collègues
carrière longue emploi des seniors
retraite des femmes retraite progressive
avant d'en arriver à un projet de loi eu
lieu était heureux de commencer par une
loi de travail qui aurait permis de
traiter ces différents sujets avec les
partenaires sociaux pour autant ce
projet de loi là et nous devons en
débattre de façon sérieuse avec toute la
responsabilité qui nous incombe je
voudrais tout d'abord féliciter et
remercier Elisabeth Doisneau et René
Paul Savary pour leurs exposés
complémentaires et très complet ils ont
présenté des enjeux de la pérennisation
de notre système de santé mais aussi des
propositions claires et précises qui
permettent d'améliorer ce texte
le fait hélas ça a été dit par mon
collègue Emmanuel le nombre d'actifs
pour un retraité ne cesse de diminuer de
4 en 1970 il est passé à 1 à 2 en 2000
1,7 en 2020
17 millions de retraités en 2020 25 en
2050 le corps annonce un déficit de 14
milliards d'ici 2030 26 en 2040 par an
avec un chômage à 5% et optimiste
indiquant aussi une détérioration bien
sûr de notre système de retraite
et donc celle de la sécurité sociale
cela malgré les lois de 2004 2010 et
2014 sous la présidence de François
Hollande qui est allongé la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités votez selon la
loi Touraine je rappelle que ce projet
de loi accélère effectivement le
calendrier de cette mesure mais n'en
remet pas encore l'objectif si vous êtes
né en 71 travailler à partir de à 21 ans
et bien vous aurez votre retraite en
2035 pleine à 64 ans nous devons
permettre de sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition
issue du CNR en 1945 sans laisser une
désastreuse à nos enfants tout en
conservant le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités nous ont amélioré ce projet
valoriser davantage de la maternité des
femmes à ce titre j'ai proposé un
amendement nous avons le taux de seniors
au travail le plus bas d'Europe 36%
entre
30 et 64 ans se pencher de loin ne doit
pas les précariser il doit au contraire
retrouver un emploi une place peut-être
dans le tutorat la formation la retraite
progressive avec l'article 2 nous devons
faire de l'emploi des seniors une
priorité en améliore en sensiblement
l'index dans les entreprises avec une
politique volontariste en faveur de
recrutement et du maintien dans l'emploi
la proposition du rapporteur René Paul
Savary nous paraît avec une avec un
seigneur une solution nous paraît tout à
fait être en cohérence pour améliorer
sensiblement l'emploi des seniors
sur l'article 8 notamment les cartes les
carrières longues il est essentiel que
les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler à l'ancêtre 18 ou 20 ans
puisse partir après 43 ans l'article 9
peut également être amélioré afin de
mieux prendre en compte et valider
valoriser l'usure professionnelle avec
un suivi médical plus régulier et le
rétablissement de certains critères de
pénibilité dans le compte de prévention
en associant les partenaires sociaux
sur l'article 10 les aidants devraient
être aussi mieux pris en compte
revalorisation de certaines pensions les
plus faibles à 85% du SMIC constituent
constituerait un progrès toutefois
monsieur le ministre il faudra que nous
apportiez plus de précision est-ce que
les agriculteurs retraités les artisans
carrière complète auront bien 1200 euros
et ainsi que les autres retraités après
l'article 13 ce projet améliore
sensiblement le dispositif emploi
retraite votée en 2014 et permettra
désormais aux retraités qui reprennent
une nouvelle activité de nouveaux droits
c'était une carence qui a notamment
démotivée d'ailleurs beaucoup de
médecins retraités à effectuer des
remplacements il est toutefois
nécessaire d'ouvrir plus largement la
retraite progressive et assurer
pleinement les conditions de départ
anticiper des personnes handicapées
en conclusion il est regrettable que le
gouvernement n'est pas mobilisé en amont
les partenaires sociaux pour mettre en
place une loi travail sur la à mon avis
aurait été nécessaire bien sûr le
travail des rapporteurs et leur
connaissance du dossier ont permis
d'amander ce projet et d'apporter une
autre dimension à ce texte notamment sur
l'emploi des seniors la prévention de
l'usure les carrières des femmes nous
espérons que notre travail ici au Sénat
contribuera l'ammeration de ce texte et
apportera pour nos enfants pour les
futurs retraités un équilibre pérenne du
budget de retraite avec un pouvoir
d'achat conservé et par la même un
équilibre de la sécurité sociale colonne
vertébrale de notre démocratie je vous
remercie merci mon chers collègues la
parole est à notre collègue victoire
jasmin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
vous avez la parole ma chère collègues
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
le président rotario a évoqué la CNAV et
bien les données que je vais être
transmettre ici tiens compte également
de la j'espère que vous avez vu
évidemment de quoi je parle cette
réforme est juste injustifiée aura des
effets néfastubles des populations des
territoires d'outre-mer comment
expliquer qu'aucune étude préalable n'a
été menée pour prendre en compte la
réalité de ces territoires dans ce
projet de loi les conséquences de vos
choix seront irréversibles dans un
contexte de chômage des jeunes déflation
de vie chers et de démographie
déséquilibré par idéologie et en
s'appuyant lorsque les éléments d'un
langage effondré le gouvernement a
décidé d'imposer son projet machiavélite
en limitant à 10 jours le débat
parlementaire au Sénat c'est tout à fait
regrettable
une application différentielle de la
réforme et pourtant un impératif
indispensable quand on connaît la
précarité les conditions de vie des
retraités ultramarins et
particulièrement des femmes j'allais
évoqué d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
lors des questions au gouvernement ce
sera une véritable catastrophe humaine
sociale économique et systémique avec
des conséquences graves pour les futurs
retraités bien sûr mais aussi pour les
collectivités locales en Guadeloupe les
acteurs de terrain tels que les CCAS il
est à 15 général de sécurité sociale
servent aujourd'hui de rempart face aux
inégalités qui existent déjà et qui
caractérisent le travail le marché du
travail et donc la retraite face aux
conséquences de la pénibilité et
particulièrement les conséquences du
chlore des cône sur nos territoires ou
encore de la vie chère les disparités en
outre-mer et en hexagone sont pourtant
connus les défauts de déclaration et la
maltraitance institutionnelle contribue
énormément au nom recours au droit dans
ce territoire en raison de l'étroitesse
du marché de travail les salariés des
Outre-mer en trois fois plus de beaucoup
de carrière que la moyenne nationale ils
ont des carrières particulièrement
hachées et on constate qu'ils sont déjà
contraints à partir plus tardivement à
la retraite 65 ans en moyenne en
Guadeloupe contre
60,7 au niveau national en moyenne
rallonger de 2 ans la durée de
cotisation c'est condamné mécaniquement
les salariés des Outre-mer à partir
encore plus tardivement à la retraite
avec des problèmes de santé et vous le
savez pour les cancers des prostate
notamment et pour les femmes des cancers
du sein et des situations de grande
pauvreté en plus en effet les niveaux de
construction sont inférieurs de 10 à 17%
par rapport à ceux de l'Hexagone dans un
contexte d'inflation permanente 9 à 15%
des retraités des Outre-mer sont
considérés comme étant en grande
pauvreté contre 1% en moyenne au niveau
national en Martinique 24% des
pensionnés sont bénéficiaires du minimum
contributifs dont 18% du micro majoré
les travailleurs indépendants les
agriculteurs et surtout les femmes sont
de plus en plus nombreuses
a augmenté entre 2017 de 2017 à 2022
depuis le 40% d'ailleurs en Guadeloupe
mais des questions restent en suspens
concernant la décongivalisation de la
prestation et concernant le montant du
seuil de recouvrement sur l'actif
successoral en fait une concertation
avec les syndicats et les employeurs
publics est nécessaire pour une
véritable prison compte des différentes
primes dans celui des fonctionnaires
monsieur le ministre monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues vous
constatez donc que les sujets des
réformes de retraite en outre-mer sont
très nombreux et très spécifiques pour
mériter plus de concertation de
différenciation la chambre des
territoires le Sénat doit écouter et
entendre les Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président je ne vais pas
pardonner moi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs répondre à chacun des
intervenants vous avez été nombreux mais
simplement peut-être quatre points en
écho différentes interventions d'abord
pour vous remercier de ces interventions
et de ce débat qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
puisque dans chacune des interventions à
la tribune sont exprimés à la fois des
oppositions des soutiens des nuances et
je pense que cela augure de débat qui
nous permettront d'avancer sur un
certain nombre de points la première
remarque que je voulais faire concerne
l'objectif de la réforme que nous menons
je l'ai dit mais je le répète cela fait
écho là aussi à de nombreuses
interventions nous voulons faire cette
réforme pour ramener le système à
l'équilibre tout en l'améliorant si nous
nous contentions de l'améliorer ça ne
serait pas très responsable ce serait
plus facile mais ça ne serait pas très
responsable si nous nous contentions de
le ramener à l'équilibre par des mesures
purement budgétaires sans mettre à
profit cette occasion de débat pour
corriger des inégalités pour apporter un
certain nombre de nouveaux droits mieux
prendre en compte la pénibilité ou
encore relever les petites pensions j'y
reviendrai
nous devons malgré tout et faire cela en
gradant le cap de l'équilibre la réforme
telle que nous vous la proposons va
générer environ 18 milliards d'euros
17,7 milliards d'euros selon les
prévisions qui ont été partagées par les
seules mesures d'âge nous avons prévu
d'augmenter légèrement le taux de
cotisation la CNRS et je sais
l'attachement de votre assemblée à ce
que la loi telle que nous l'examinons
garantissent la bonne compensation pour
les employeurs concernés hospitaliers
territoriaux nous pourrons avancer sur
ce sujet là nous avons aussi proposé
pour rester dans les bornes du système
de retraite que le taux de cotisation
ATMP des employeurs puissent être
légèrement réduit la branche ATMP étant
excédentaire à hauteur d'environ 20% de
ses recettes globales pour à contrario
augmenter légèrement le taux de
cotisation des employeurs et la CNAV et
ainsi générer un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires dans le cadre du système
de retraite c'est ainsi que nous
arrivons autour de 19,5 milliards
d'euros de retraite en 2030 et c'est 19
extrêmement dommageable de mener une
réforme et finalement de ne pas avoir le
bénéfice d'un retour à l'équilibre et
donc d'une pérennisation du système la
deuxième chose que je souhaitais
souligner deuxième remarque fait tiens
compte plutôt ou on fait le lien avec un
certain nombre de propositions
d'amendements et évidemment il y a des
amendements et c'est normal dans un
débat parlementaire qui n'auront comme
seul objectif que de remettre en cause
l'essence même de la réforme que le
gouvernement ne pourra évidemment pas
soutenir évidemment qui vont permettre
d'avancer qui vont permettre de préciser
qui vont permettre de créer des droits
déposés par la quasi-totalité des
groupes et donc le gouvernement avec ce
cette prudence financière que j'ai
évoquée il y a un instant ce sera ouvert
à l'ensemble mais c'est propositions et
je tiens à la fois à le dire et à le
souligner parce que ce texte tel qu'il
sortira du Sénat tel qu'il sera voté je
l'espère par le Sénat devra ensuite
faire l'objet d'une discussion en
commission mixte paritaire et chaque
fois que nous pouvons l'améliorer pour
faciliter les consensus des convergences
et peut-être gommer une partie des
différences ou des oppositions qui sont
exprimés je pense que nous aurons tout à
y gagner il y a une troisième remarque
enfin que je voulais faire avant de
terminer cette troisième remarque
concerne la complexité du sujet je crois
que chacune des interventions là aussi
souligne nous avons un système de
retraite qui est extrêmement complexe
complexe parce que morcelet avec 40 de
régime complexe parce que traversé par
des inégalités ou des injustices parfois
en tout cas des différences sur les
règles qui s'appliquent lorsque j'ai
évoqué dans mon propos liminaire la
question du chantier des droits
familiaux j'ai renvoyé aussi à la
question des pensions de réversion
imaginez que nous avons dans notre
système de retraite aujourd'hui 13
règles en matière de définition des
pensions de reversion imaginez que un
individu avec exactement la même
situation les mêmes revenus la même
situation familiale était ligible à une
pension de réversion dans un système et
pas dans l'autre parce que les
conditions de revenus ce sont pas les
mêmes d'un système de réversion à
l'autre cela relève des injustices et
des inégalités que nous devrons sur
lesquelles nous devrons travailler d'ici
le PLFSS 2024
et cette complexité ce matérialise et je
crois qu'il faut l'accepter sur tous les
points à l'instant madame la sénatrice
jasmin vous avez évoqué la question des
outre-mer et en réalité dans votre
propos on retrouve aussi cette
complexité là vous l'avez dit vous-même
à la tribune aujourd'hui les assurés en
outre-mer dans les territoires
d'outre-mer partent déjà à la retraite
avec un âge effectif qui est supérieur
au Nouvel Âge d'ouverture des droits que
nous souhaitons fixer à 64 ans vous
l'avez rappelé pour la Guadeloupe vous
l'avez rappelé pour la Martinique à
chaque fois c'est supérieur à 64 ans et
cela ne relèvera la solution apporter à
cela ne relèvera pas du texte mais dire
des chantiers que vous avez évoqué en
particulier la question de la
déclaration la question de la fiabilité
des systèmes d'information et la
capacité à garantir des carrières moins
âgées par contre je ne partage pas un
point de votre propos vous avez dit
obligé à travailler deux ans de plus va
les mettre en difficulté en réalité non
le relèvement de l'âge pour les raisons
vous avez évoqué qui sont de a pas de
raison en réalité parce que la situation
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
s'explique par de mauvaises raisons en
tout cas que nous devons combattre
collectivement mais le relèvement de
l'âge légal ne sera pas mordant pour
reprendre cette expression qu'on utilise
souvent pour les assurer un outre-mer
dans la mesure où la geffectif de départ
est déjà supérieur 64 ans par contre ce
qui est mort dans et ce qui est
générateur de petites pensions
d'outre-mer c'est le relèvement de la
durée de cotisation tel qu'il avait été
voté en 2013 et que nos accélérons avec
cette réforme mais il y a de nombreux
chantiers derrière ce que vous avez
évoqué qu'il nous faut ouvrir je pense
par exemple un chantier qui dépasse très
largement le cadre de spel FSS puisqu'il
dépend des seuls partenaires sociaux
mais en Guadeloupe et à la Réunion les
salariés du secteur agricole et je dis
bien les salariés pas les indépendants
pas les exploitants ne sont pas
cohérèrent par la Bretagne
complémentaire agirco alors que partout
ailleurs sur le territoire national la
retraite la complémentaire agir Carco
concerne aussi les salariés du secteur
agricole c'est une décision qui relève
des partenaires sociaux et c'est
l'examen de cette réforme qui est à
titre personnel m'a permis de le mesurer
de la même manière que nous pourrons
avancer sur les questions relatives à la
retraite à ou la situation appelle des
réponses différentes dans la mesure où
le système de retraite n'est obligatoire
que depuis 1987 et que les 2500 ou 2600
assuré pensionnés aujourd'hui à Mayotte
ont une retraite moyenne de 287 euros
mais cette retraite moyenne très basse
s'explique aussi par le fait que leur
cotisation telle que déclarée tels que
transmises mais s'élève qu'à 9 années 9
années de cotisation ce qui explique
cette difficulté à avoir des retraites
plus importantes deuxième sujet
d'illustration de la complexité la
question de la revalorisation des
pensions minimales et je saisis cette
première intervention avant l'examen des
articles la pension minimale ça vient à
l'article 10 je ne doute pas que nous y
serons rapidement et que nous pourrons
apporter toutes les réponses mais
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle rapidement
madame Lubin ça peut être quelques jours
ou quelques heures
mais pour revenir à ce sujet qui est
sérieux quel est l'engagement qui a pris
le président de la République pendant la
campagne c'est de garantir un salarié
qui a une carrière complète rémunérée au
niveau du SMIC le fait d'atteindre 85%
du SMIC net au moment de son départ à la
retraite
c'est l'âme ou la difficulté première
qu'il faut souligner nous sommes sur un
modèle cible d'un salarié qui toute sa
carrière aurait cotisé en étant rémunéré
au SMIC evidemment que dans la vraie vie
si je puis dire certains gagnent un peu
plus un moment d'autres peuvent
malheureusement gagner un peu moins mais
nous avons cet objectif cible mais
surtout comment est-ce que ça va se
traduire ça va se traduire par ça a été
dit par Monsieur le Sénateur lévrier ça
va se traduire par le fait que parmi les
17 millions de retraités actuels un
million 8 je le répète un million 8 dès
le mois de septembre vers l'environ leur
pension revalorisées avec une
revalorisation de fonction du nombre de
trimestres cotisés il s'agit du myco
majoré que nous augmentons pour les
retraités actuels avec une
revalorisation qui va varier d'une
vingtaine pour les plus bases jusqu'à
100 euros et avec 50% d'entre eux 900
000 courront une revalorisation comprise
entre 70 et 100 euros nous parlons de
retraités
qui ont des petites retraites de 800 de
900 de 1000 euros et pour lesquels une
revalorisation de 70 à 100 euros est
loin d'être négligeable ça ne les rendra
pas riches personne ne le dit l'inverse
mais c'est loin d'être négligeable et
cette revalorisation va concerner à la
fois ceux qui ont une carrière complète
à temps plein mais aussi ce qu'on a une
carrière complète à temps partiel mais
avec un principe de privatisation qui
s'applique c'est le nombre de trimestres
cotisés qui va ainsi permettre d'y
arriver et donc c'est une première
revalorisation et pour les retraités
nouveaux je les dis tout à l'heure nous
en avons 800 000 par an à peu près 200
000 auront une pension revalorisée entre
25 et 100 euros nous procédons un peu
différemment puisqu'il s'agit du
relèvement du minimum contributif de
base de 25 euros et du minimum
contributif majoré de 75 euros ce qui
explique que les répartitions sont un
peu différentes et là où la complexité
vient trouver un relief particulier
c'est que nous avons à peu près 40 000
de ces 200 000 retraités qui vont passer
le cap des 1200 euros
nous en avons 40000 qui vont bénéficier
de leur valorisation maximum c'est à
dire 100 euros mais ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes ce ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes parce que tout le
monde ne part pas du même niveau de
retraite et nous savons c'est l'exercice
de transparence auquel nous sommes
livrés que pour la première génération
celle de 1962
le passage du cap des 1200 euros sera à
la fois justifié par la revalorisation
mais aussi par les phénomènes
d'indexation par contre ce que nous
savons aussi c'est qu'entre la
génération 62 et la génération 1972 qui
partira à la retraite 10 ans plus tard
le nombre de ceux qui passeront le cap
des 85 % du SMIC du simple fait de la
réforme va être multiplié par 4 et
globalement je répète ce sont 200 000
retraités avec des petites pensions qui
auront grâce à cette pension minimale
une retraite meilleure que sont la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme enfin je termine
par un dernier point
exercice du travail qui ont été évoqués
la tribune autour des questions de
qualité de vie de conditions de travail
et je fais un chantier pardonnez-moi
pour cet instant narcissique très
personnel de la lutte contre les
accidents gravent et mortels au travail
nous avons 650 personnes chaque année
qui me retravaillent nous en avons 9600
qui connaissent un accident du travail
leur laissant une forme d'incapacité
permanente au moins supérieur à 10% et
donc ce sont des des chantiers que nous
devons conforter et des priorités que
nous devons nous donner et puis nous
aurons aussi des choses sur la
démocratie dans l'entreprise parce que à
l'heure où les collectifs de travail
sont physiquement éparpillés par le
télétravail par le travail entière lieu
par le travail à distance faire en sorte
que la démocratie puisse s'exprimer
différemment et que l'accès à
l'information soit aussi améliorée dans
ces cadres nouveaux ça fait partie de
ces priorités et je ne doute pas aussi
qu'un certain nombre de sujets que nous
aurons a évoquer dans le cadre de nos
débats et qui peut-être n'auront qu'un
lien ténu avec la forme qui a cette
réforme c'est à dire un bel effet SS
pourront le cas échéant trouver la place
dans ce projet de loi pour l'emploi
un travail d'insertion c'est vrai autour
du travail des seniors et puis c'est
vrai pour d'autres sujets qui eux
devront certainement trouver un débouché
ailleurs j'en termine par là
véritablement le président Marseille a
évoqué tout à l'heure la volonté de
sénateurs et de sénatrices de son groupe
de priver les parents qui se voient
retirer définitivement l'autorité
parentale de la majoration de 10% c'est
un objectif auquel je souscris mais nous
savons aussi que d'une part pour une
part c'est déjà prévu et que d'autre
part ça s'apparente plutôt en termes de
projection à une peine complémentaire
que les juges pourraient prononcer à
l'occasion de la condamnation de
violence sur les enfants et dès lors que
nous sommes dans le schéma d'une peine
complémentaire et qui s'ajouterait
j'imagine je ne suis pas juriste code
pénal ça ne relève pas véritablement
d'un pays FSS mais plutôt de texte sur
la justice et sur la capacité Corré la
justice à sanctionner par ses peines
complémentaires des parents qui dès lors
qu'ils sont coupables de violence sur
les enfants peuvent être qualifiés de
parents indiens et donc nous allons
affronter ces débats je crois en ayant
en tête cette complexité en ayant en
tête la difficulté qu'il y a parfois à
bien articuler les mesures entre les
différents textes et les différentes
priorités mais je ne doute pas que dans
quelques jours pour ne pas aller trop
vite et ne pas faire preuve d'impatience
nous puissions à l'issue de ces débats
non seulement avoir examiné en tout cas
c'est le souhait du gouvernement
l'ensemble des dispositions et faire en
sorte que le texte soumis ensuite à la
commission mixte paritaire soit un texte
amélioré en tout cas merci à toutes et à
tous pour vos interventions
merci monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je vais maintenant
lever la séance je rappelle que notre
prochaine séance sera demain matin à
9h30 pour la discussion de la motion
référendaire la séance est donc levée